FIVE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
CORRECTIONS AND YOU SHOULD IS
NOT COME TO ORDER. SO LET ME
JUST OPENED A BUT THAT. DUE TO.
CORONA NAY. IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC INCIDENTS. WE ARE OF
COURSE LIMITING ON GATHERING
AND HEARING TO THE DISTANCING
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
IS CENTRAL HEARING AND WE'VE
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
PROCESS. FOR CONDUCTING HEARING
IN A WAY THAT PROTECTS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF ALL THIS
AS WE COMPLY WITH THOSE ORDERS.
WE ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL OF
TESTIMONY BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ALLEGE THAT ABANDONED LESS
OFFICE. BEING PROVIDED
REMOTELY. WITH THE USE OF A
VIDEO CONFERENCING SYSTEM. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY PLEASE NHI<c.cyan></c>
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. ARE
I. T. PERSONAL MUTE AND UNMUTE
THE VIDEO SERVICE WHEN YOU WISH
TO SPEAK. THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING. THE TERRIBLE
NOISE THAT WE GET IS FEEDBACK.
I ASK EVERY TIME YOU HAVE A
COMMENT OR QUESTION PLEASE USE
THE RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE. AND
THAT THE I. T. WILL THEN
INDICATE WHEN I INDICATE
RECOGNIZED SPEAK. STATE YOUR
NAME AND THE AGENDA ISSUE TO
WHICH YOU ARE REFERRING. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS THE ONE WE
ARE SITTING IN RIGHT NOW AND
ONE ON THE SECOND FLOOR. AND
THEN WE ARE ALSO ALLOWING. THE
PHONE IN WITH A TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR THOSE WHO
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON THE BUDGET SUB
FIVE WEBSITE. HERE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT. IT IS.
1-877-336-4441 THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT FIVE ZERO
SIX ZERO. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH WE WILL DO
AT THE END. WILL NOT DO IT
AFTER EACH ITEM. A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY.
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID THE FEEDBACK MEET THE
DEVICE. YOU ARE. WATCHING THE
HEARING ON SO THAT WE DON'T GET
THAT FEEDBACK. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMPLIANCE WITH THESE IN
YOUR PATIENTS I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING ANY
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
THIS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
OR ADJUSTING TO THE USE OF NEW
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES. SO WE
ASK YOUR PATIENCE. WE HAVE. THE
I WILL ASK MEMBERS IF THERE'S
ANY ITEMS WANT FOR DISCUSS BUT
ON OUR AGENDA WE HAVE SIX ISSUE
FOR DISK. ON OUR A CHAIN. IN
ADDITION TO THE VOTE ON CARE.
AND I WILL BE ANNOUNCING IF
CHANGES IN THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR THE VOTE ONLY WHEN WE GET
TO THAT PART. I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE THAT FOR TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE HEARING ALL OF THE
ITEMS ON THE AGENDA PRIOR TO
TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH
I DID MENTION. AND BEFORE WE
VOTE. SO ONCE WE'VE HEARD ALL
OF THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
WE'LL HAVE A SINGLE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT. SUBSEQUENT TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD. THE
WE WILL. VOTE ON THE AGENDA
ITEMS IN WE'LL EITHER TAKE ONE
pVOTE TO ADOPT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS LISTED OR
SEPARATE VOTES OF MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WHICH CALL ITEMS.
SO FIRST LET US ESTABLISH A
QUORUM CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AND FOR A MEMBERS MAKES
YOUR PICTURE MIKE SOMEONE WHEN
YOU ANSWER. SENATORS SKINNER
I'M HERE MORE LOCK PRESIDENT
BELL. MEMBERS ARE PRESENT
EXCELLENT CHORDS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. ALL RIGHT- SO I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME. WE TAKE BEFORE
I DO THAT LET ME JUST MAKE SURE
MEMBERS IF THERE WAS AN ITEM
THAT IS THERE ANY ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA YOU. IF YOU WANT TO PULL
SOMETHING ELSE FOR DISCUSSION
IS NOT REFLECTED. I KNOW WE
WITH ASSN ADVANCE BUT JUST IN
CASE. CORRECT. I'M CONFUSED
WELL WE DID GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY BUT SINCE THIS IS
BEEN SUCH A CONDENSED PROCESS.
AND I JUST WANTED TO. ADD THE
COURTESY IF THERE IS A VOTE
ONLY ITEM THAT YOU REALLY FEEL
THAT THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE DISCUSSED.
LOWRY TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SIT. I'M COURSE AT THE POINT
WHERE VOTING YOU CERTAINLY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO- WE CAN- VOTE
SEPARATELY EXPECT IF THE FIFTY.
YOU WANT TO TAKE ACTION OTHER
THAN WHAT'S RECOMMENDED ON THE
SHIFT. GREAT CENTER MORE LEFT
THANK YOU AND I'M SURE THERE
ARE A FEW ITEMS ROUTE TO WORRY
YOU KNOW. BOB THE ITEMS RIGHT.
AND SO WE CAN GO TO THOSE WHEN
WE GET TO THE WOULD ONLYWERE
NOT GOING TO VOTE ON THE ON
WILL DO THAT AFTER THE DISCUSS
ITEM NUMBER ONE TWO I DID WANT
TO ASK YOU A QUESTION THE. OVER
THE WEEKEND. SIX FORTY EIGHT.
AND THEN WILL BE ABLE TO
DISCUSS. ALL RIGHT HAVE FUN.
THE BECAUSE THEY'RE SO VOTE
EARLY I'D IS JUST A LITTLE ARE
TO WHICH ONES ARE JUST WHICH
NOW NO CRITICISM STAFF SO JUST
REALITY OF THE WAY TO SUGGEST
DISTRICTS SENSE BECAUSE WE
DOING IT ALL AT ONCE. THIS THE
JUST ONE TO IN TERMS OF MICE.
WHEN YOU SAY DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU WANT TO PRESENT THE
ITEM. YOU'RE REFERRING TO THAT
I WILL START IN EFFECT ON ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON DISK OF THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO. ON A RIGHT THEN. WHAT WE
WILL DO. IS GO TO. FILE ITEM
ISSUE NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN WHICH
IS THE TRIGGER REDUCTIONS IN
THAT'S THE FIRST ITEM WE HAVE
FOR DISCUSSION. AND WHAT I WILL
DO IS WELCOME THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN LA OWES OFFICE. AND
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE OF
ASSOCIATED WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY BUT WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TO PRESENT THE ITEM.
THE I'D BY DEPARTMENT FRENCH
YOU CAN START DRIVE TO INDICATE
TO SOMEONE TO LOVE THEM TO
START. ARE YOU ON MUTE CAN USE.
I DON'T THINK I'M THE PERSON
WHO CONTROLS. THE WAITING FOR
THEM AND THEY'RE TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING THAT THOUGH OKAY. I
MEAN IF I NEED YOU HEAR ME YES
WE. AND JUSTICE FOR AND SOME
SHORTCOMINGS THE- AND
DISCUSSION IN GENERAL AND THEN
IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS ON ANY OF
THAT. ANNE I GOT YEAH YOUR. AND
I WOULD JUST START OFF SAYING
THAT THE BASE REDUCTION AND IN
LAST AND ACROSS ALL. STATEWIDE.
THE FINAL LIST OF THE ISSUE.
FOR OURSELVES AND THE HOWEVER I
WOULD ALSO ADD THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT. YOU WHETHER
OR NOT WE WOULD RESTORE SOME OF
THE FUNDING THERE ARE THOSE
PRODUCTIONS NOT WOULD BE
CONTINGENT ON OBVIOUSLY WHETHER
FEDERAL FUNDS BECOME AVAILABLE
IN MOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
BECOME AVAILABLE AND THERE'S
ALSO LANGUAGE THAT I. PROVIDE
FOR THE FEDERAL FUNDS THAT ARE
PROVIDED HAVE SPECIFIC USES
THAT COMPETE AND MANY. MORE AND
I AM SO HAVING SAID THAT I HAD
IT EXCEPT FOR ONE BECOME
AVAILABLE THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN THAT THE ITEMS
THAT ARE ON THE CURRENT LIST
WOULD NECESSARILY BE RESTORED
CONSIDERED IN THE CONTEXT OF
THOSE HAVE YACHT. A. THAT. YOUR
LAST OLDER BUT WE ALSO. FIRST
IN THE BROADER OF THE STATE SO
THERE'S SOME GENERAL COMMENTS
ON THE GENERAL AND IF YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY OF
THE ONES ARE LISTED. OUR REVIEW
YES IT I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S- I
DON'T THINK I THINK YOU WERE
YOU WERE DOING YOUR TO
ARTICULATED WHICH IS A LITTLE
HARD FOR US TO HEAR US HERE YOU
POLICIES- HOPEFULLY YOU CAN
HEAR US CLEARLY. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU CAN HEAR US
CLEARLY. YEAH YEAH OKAY YEAH I
THINK IT'S JUST KIND OF AN
ECHOING. THE. I DID HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ON THE TRIGGER ISSUES
BUT I WANT TO SEE DID DESERVE
CENTER MOORLACH DO YOU HAVE
EITHER A COMMONER QUESTION ON
THIS YES THEY DO BUT I'M FOR IT
YES I DO PLEASE GO TO FOLLOW
THE CHAIR. YOUR CALL MAY THE
EVERYONE OF US ARE EVEN THOUGH
I HAVE ALREADY CHAIRED ONE OF
THESE COMMITTEES IN THIS
FASHION. IT IS STILL A
DISCONCERTING TO ME SO ANYWAY.
WHAT I'D THIS IS SPECIFIC TO
THE TRIGGER QUESTIONS BUT ALL
FOR TRIGGER CUTS BUT ALSO AN
OVERALL COMMENT I NOTE THAT
WHEN I LOOK AT THAT WHILE WE
ARE STOPPED ME FIVE WE DEAL
WITH CDC ARE. AND TO JUDICIARY
AND DOJ IN A NUMBER OF OTHER.
DEPARTMENTS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
PAGE ELEVEN OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISE. AND YOU LOOK AT THE
CHART OF GENERAL FUND SPENDING.
IT SHOWS EVERY SINGLE
DEPARTMENT WITH A CUTS BUT IF
YOU LOOK AT THE PERCENT NOW OF
COURSE THE EACH EACH
DEPARTMENTS TOTAL DOLLAR AMOUNT
VARIES THE OBVIOUSLY BUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ARCHITECTURAL SCHOOLS IS THE I
BELIEVE THE BIGGEST- DOLLAR
ITEM- SO YOU KNOW THERE'S QUITE
A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A SORT OF
A- FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLAR
AGENCY FOR. A SEVENTEEN BILLION
AGENCY BUT STILL YOU LOOK AT
THE PERCENTAGES. THE AGENCY CDC
ARE ANDTHERE'S A NUMBER A
COUPLE OF THESE CUTS IN HERE
THAT ARE CDC ARE. TRIGGER CUTS
ARM IT IS ONLY EXPERIENCING A
LESS THAN 1% A ZERO POINT 7%
READ GENERAL FUND REDUCTION.
ALL OTHER AGENCIES ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER WITH- THE
NEXT SUPER LOIS PERCENT IS IN
THE ORDER OF ABOUT 6% AND THEN
IT RANGES ALL THE WAY UP TO
NINETY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY WHICH IS A
SMALL AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND
BUT STILL IT'S RECEIPT IS UNDER
THE MAYBE REVISED. RECEIVING OR
BEING RECOMMENDED TO RECEIVE A
90% GENERAL FUND CUT NOW
CERTAINLY WHEN I GO THROUGH OUR
ENTIRE AGENDA I SEE THAT THE
MAY REVISED DID WITHDRAW THE
NUMBER OF EXPENDITURES AND DID
LESSEN OR REDUCE EXPENDITURES
WITHIN CDC ARE AS IT IS IT IT
ALSO IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
DEPARTMENTS THE JUDICIARY DO G.
OTHERS. AND I CERTAINLY THERE
ARE CERTAIN- PROGRAMS ARE
CERTAIN PARTS OF CDC ARE WHICH
I WOULD NOT WANT TO OR EXPECT
AB SEE REDUCTIONS BUT WHAT I AM
SOMEWHAT SURPRISED AT THAT WE
NOT BE MORE EFFICIENCY OUT
THERE COULD NOT BE A NEED SOME
ADDITIONAL NEW SPENT. THAT
WOULD BE READ STE THAT MY
ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR SOME OF
THESE CUTS NOW I KNOW THAT WHAT
WAS JUST EXPLAINED IS THAT IF
THE IF FEDERAL ACT IS SET THAT
THE SEE. THE RIVER THE MIGHT
COME BACK AND SAY LET'S GIVE
BACK ON THESE CARS BUT TRIGGER
QUE. BUT I GET I. WANT TO WHAT
MONEY I WILL GET THAT THE
THAT'S THE HOPE BUT NOT AN
EXPERT. AND WHAT I WOULD ARE
NOT A GUARANTEE AND WHAT I
WOULD HOPE IS THAT WE COULD
FIND SOME ADDITIONAL
EFFICIENCIES AND AS WE GO
THROUGH THE RIGHT OR CHEN. THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DISCUSS
MEANT TO DETAIL. YOU'LL SEE
THAT I AM AT LEAST RECOMMENDING
THE REJECTION OF A FEW ITEMS OF
EXPENDITURE. THAT I FEEL. AT
THIS POINT ARE. APPROPRIATE
GIVEN THE KIND OF DEFICIT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING AND WHILE THE
THOSE ITEMS ARE NOT ITEMS THAT
I'M NECESSARILY. CONJOINING OR
TRYING TO THE TRIGGER ITEMS I
JUST RAISE THEM BECAUSE I THINK
A FEW OF THESE TRIGGER ITEMS.
ARE AREAS THAT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT THEY WERE IMPORTANT
TO THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
WHEN WE ADOPTED IT BUT THE
CONTINUE TO BE IMPORTANT TODAY
FOR EXAMPLE. THE ADULT REENTRY
GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE AS WE
KNOW IN THE NORMAL COURSE OF
BUSINESS ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE RELEASED FROM OUR
STATE FACILITIES EVERY MONTH
THAT'S JUST A NORMAL NORMAL DAY
TO DAY. AND NOW THEY ARE
RELEASED A TIME WHEN THEIR
ABILITY TO GET A JOB AS PRIDE
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN DIFFICULT.
PROBLEM SIXTEEN WE SELL. AND
THEIR ABILITY TO SECURE HOUSING
SIX SEATING WE TYPICAL. SO TO
BE MOVED. THE FIGHT FOR RE
ENTRY SUPPORT. AT THE POINT
WHERE WE KNOW YOU'RE RELEASING
GOING TO THE COMMUNITY. WHICH
TO GET NOT A NEW NUMBER BUT
JUST N THE COURSE OF TEN AND
TO CHOOSE THE ARE. YOU DUG
THROUGH THAT PORT GRAHAM FIRST
OTHER FOR. I JUST REYES AND IN
ABOUT WHICH IS WHY. I WON BOTH
FOR US TO HAVE THE SILENCE
CHRISTIAN ALSO WHY WANTED TO
HOLD IT AND NOT. APPROVE IT
TODAY- BECAUSE I THINK THERE
MAY BE SOME OTHER PLACES.
EITHER IN. SIDE JUDICIARY DOJ
CDC ARE WHERE WE MIGHT FIND
SOME OTHER PLACES TO GET SOME
EFFICIENCIES COMPARED TO THESE
WANTS. TO SENATOR MOORLACH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I KNOW
THIS. CODE NINETEEN RECESSION
OR DEPRESSION YOU KNOW KIND OF
CAME ON LIKE A HEART ATTACK SO%
IT'S BEEN AMAZING TO WATCH SOME
OF THESE NUMBERS BUT- IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT. EVEN THOUGH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES HAD TO
RUSSIAN WORK REALLY QUICKLY TO
GET SOMETHING PUT TOGETHER.
THAT YOU WOULD MAYBE TAKE A-
THE STEP BY STEP PROCESS- THE
FIRST WOULD BE WHATEVER WE
APPROVED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET WE- BACK DOWN
EVERYTHING IS NEW BACK IT DOWN.
THEN YOU DO IT FOR THE- YEAR
PRIOR. EIGHTEEN WITH WHATEVER'S
NEW YORK YOU'RE JUST BACK IT
DOWN WHERE YOU CAN YOU HAVE A
METHODICAL LODGE TO. WHAT WE'RE
DOING AS WE SCALE BACK AND
CONTRACT. BUT IT BUT IT IT
SEEMS. AS IF YOU WOULD DO
ACROSS THE BOARD CUTS. LATER IT
WOULD BE LIKE THE THIRD OR
FOURTH THE FIFTH STEP. AND SO
IT'S JUST SORT OF ITCHING TO
SEEWHAT'S GOING ON I GET THE
IMPRESSION MADAM CHAIR IN
REVIEWING. THE DATA THAT EVERY
DEPARTMENT MAYBE IS TAKING A
10% CUT. SOMEONE'S YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE TELLING ME TO
MIDDLE DIFFERENT BUT- YOU KNOW
EVERYONE'S TAKING A SIMILAR CUT
ALREADY NOW- IN WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE BEGIN WITH BEING GIVEN
SUCH. A DRASTIC- UNEMPLOYMENT.
NUMBERS AND THE REST- THAT IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE WE'RE CUTTING
THINGS CENTER. EMOTIONALLY.
REACTIVE REACTS FULL TO LET ME
GIVE YOU FOR WE'RE GONNA CUT
SENIORS THAN YOUR RACE BECAUSE
GO WHY WHY ARE YOU DOING THAT
BECAUSE- IT'S- IT'S NOW THE
MOST VULNERABLE SEGMENT OF OUR
POPULATION THAT. COULD BE
HARMED BY THE CORONA VIRUS. BUT
IT'S IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IT
ISN'T DONE STRATEGICALLY IT'S
DONE FOR EMOTIONAL REASONS AND-
IN THIS OKAY WE'RE GONNA CUT.
PLEASE PUBLIC SAFETY OR YOU
KNOW. IT'S SORT OF A KIND OF
AVAILABLE KIND OF THREAT TO ME-
TO GARNER SOME KIND OF FEDERAL
SUPPORT ACT I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE- I MEAN IT'S- D.
WHOEVER IT IS ALWAYS A STRATEGY
BUT- NO. IF IT'S- BECOMING OF
THE LARGEST STATE IN THE
COUNTRY SO I'M I'M I'M-
WONDERING MANAGER IT TO GO BIG
AND GO BOLD ONE WHERE WE JUST
MAKING A 10% CUT HERE WHEN WE
MAKE A 25% AND JUST. FOR
LOOKING JUST FOR. THEATRICS TO
TRY AND IMPRESSED WASHINGTON DC
TO DO SOMETHING THE BILL WAS
OUT IN. WE GO BIGGER ANGLE
BOLTS. IN ITS MAYBE MY WAY OF
REACTING TO THE TO THE STRATEGY
HERE BECAUSE I SEE THIS AS A
BLUFF AND I AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK IT'S TACKY JUST. I THINK
OF A BETTER STRATEGY COULD BE
UTILIZED BEFORE WE MAY AT AYE
AYE WILLOW SENATOR BILL AND
THEN WE MIGHT HEAR FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT I
THINK. I THINK THE POINT THAT.
WELL YOUR YOUR POINT CENTER
MORE LIKE IS WELL TAKEN AT
LEAST IN AND DIFFERENT OF WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT NUMBER A VERY
PART MINSITER BEFORE US RIGHT
WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WE HAVE THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH. AB OEM PARTS OF IT NOT
ALL AND WE A FEW OTHER THINGS
CDC ARE AND THE POINT I WAS
MAKING IT IT'S AN I DON'T KNOW
ADVOCATES FOR JUST A FLAT OUT
10% EVERY DEPART. BUT ONLY I
THINK IT I JUST IT AT LEAST IN
THE CASE OF THE DISEASE WHICH
IS A SEVENTY NINE BILLION
DOLLARS THE PART ALL. AMOUNT
THE DIRECTIONS THAT HARPER US
IN THE MAYBE. EQUAL IN TOTAL
LET THAN ONE PER. AND WHEREAS
EVERY OTHER AGENCY REGARDING
REGARDLESS OF ITS DOLLAR SIZE
WHETHER IT'S A FORTY BILLION
DOLLAR A TEN BILLION OR A FIFTY
SIX BILLION HAS A MUCH LARGER
PERCENT CUT THEY DON'T THEY'RE
NOT THE SAME THEY'RE NOT AT ALL.
AND THE ONLY THING THAT.
THERE'S WE ARE I FELT THAT WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO FIND A FEW
MORE EFFICIENCIES WITHIN CDC
ARE- KNOWINGTHAT WE STILL
ABSOLUTELY MUST PROTECT PUBLIC
SAFETY- BUT I ALSO NOTICED THAT
THERE WERE A FEW. WHO OWLS
BEING A RECOMMENDED FOR CDC ARE
SO NEW EXPENDITURES AND AGAIN
NOT THAT WE SHOULD REJECT ALL
NEW EXPENDITURES CLEARLY IN A
TIME OF ENDEMIC THEIR
APPROPRIATE NEW EXPENDITURES
BUT THERE SEEM TO BE SOME THAT
MAYBE RIGHT NOW JUST START
WARRANTED OLD THAT WAS REPLETE
I WAS GONNA BAKE AND THE POINT
I TRYING TO MAKE THIS TO ME
WHEN I CONTRAST. THE WHAT
THINGS WERE SO THE FOR A
TRIGGER CUT VERSUS THOSE THINGS
THAT ARE NEW. OF CENTER ABOUT.
WERE UNKNOWN DIFFERENT TIMES IN
NORMAL AND BUT I NOTICED SOME.
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN THE CUTS
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE NOW AND
THE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE AREA.
AND THE CUTS THAT TOOK PLACE
DURING THE ROUTE LAST RECESSION
IT IS APPEARS TO ME THAT A LOT
OF THE SAME CUTS ARE BEING MADE
WE'RE SORT OF CUTTING ON THE
EDGES OF THE DEPARTMENT. OF A
CORRECTION- PERHAPS NOT TRUE
WITH THE JUDICIARY I THINK
WE'RE CUTTING INTO THOSE ARE
THE BASIC PART OF THE
JUDICIARY- WITH THESE TRIGGER
MECHANISMS BUT- THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS I THINK THERE
ARE CUT IT- THE DIFFERENT
SERVICES THAT ARE. FUNDED OF
THEIR IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY
THE DEPARTMENT AND SO FORTH- I
REMEMBER THE LAST- GO AROUND
TEN YEARS AGO WHEN WE CUT. A
LOT OF THE PROGRAMS. AND THE
RESULT WAS THAT WE I HAD- A
REDUCE RECIDIVISM WE HAD- AN
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
IN- FACILITIES WITH MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS OR BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS OF I'D SAY IT THAT WAY
BE MORE PERHAPS MORE CORRECTLY
PUT IT. AND THAT IT MUST OF
INCARCERATION BECAUSE THE
LEVELS OF THE INMATES SO
INCREASED. SO NOW WE'RE IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE'RE INDEED
HAVING A DECREASING POPULATION
AND IT KIND OF. DOES CENTERS.
PERHAPS. MAKES SENSE TO LOOK AT
A DECREASE IN A POPULATION
WITHOUT AT LEAST EXAMINING WHAT
IS GOING ON IN THAT DEPARTMENT
AND WHAT. WHY WE CAN REDUCE
SAID. BASED ON THE DECREASING
POPULATION SO FOR ME I LIKE TO
KNOW- SOME RESUMES SOME
STATISTICS OKAY WHAT IS THE
POPULATION. NOT NOT IN THE MAY
REVISE WHICH IS AN OLD NUMBER
WHAT IS A POPULATION NOW WERE
WERE GOING THROUGH A TRANSITION
WERE. A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
CHANGING I LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
THE POPULATION AS- OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT
CLUB THING FACILITIES. IS
INDEED THAT HAVE. OF THE VIRUS.
SPREADING IN THE PRISONS. HOW
MANY PEOPLE HAVE THE VIRUS IN
THE PRISONS. I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S ONE OR TWO ONE
PARTICULAR PRISON HAS A LOT OF
THE VIRUS AND I BELIEVE IT'S
THE CHINO FACILITY BUT I'M NOT
SURE THAT IT IS A PANEL FIRST
AND- AT THE SAME TIME WHEN
THEY'RE- THERE IS- THERE'S
REQUIRE US TO. HOLD OFF.
CLOSING A FACILITY THAT HAS AN
OUTBREAK OF THE VIRUS WHICH IS
GOING TO COST US MORE MONEY
DEAL WITH RATHER THAN. MAYBE
LOOK AT YOU HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE A VIRUS IN ONE PRISON
THERE MIGHT BE A DECISION TO
ACTUALLY. LOOK AT IT MAYBE.
SHOULD WE SHOULD WE LOOK AT. IN
A MEDICAL CENTER SHOULD WE LOOK
AT- MAYBE MOVING PEOPLE OUT OF
THAT FACILITY. I'M IS THAT
OFFICE THE- THAT WE SHOULD-
MOVE PEOPLE OUT OF I WOULD
QUESTION THAT I WOULD RAISE
THAT ISSUE. I REMEMBER WHEN WE
HAVE ALEX LEAVER. SITUATION
WITH- PEOPLE OUT OF ONE OF THE
FACILITIES A FEW YEARS AGO. SO
NOW WE HAVE THE VIRUS. AND IF
THE VIRUS AT A CERTAIN LEVEL.
MAY BE. FOR THE SAFETY OF THE
EMPLOYEES AND THE INMATES THAT
ARE IN THEIR FACILITY IN THEIR
BOOKS ARE RESPONSIBILITIES WE
CARE ABOUT- IN TERMS OF THEIR
HEALTH ONCE THEY'RE
INCARCERATED THEY HAVE TO BE.
CHARTER HEALTH. AND ARE. AREN'T
A COURT ORDER. WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S- SO MAYBE MAYBE-
MAYBE IT'S TIME TO MAYBE-
ACCELERATE THE DISCUSSION OF
THAT. HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE WITH
THIS IN THAT FACILITY WHAT
PERCENTAGE. AND THEN THE
QUESTION IS HOW MUCH TESTING IS
BEING DONE IN THE IN THE
CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT. IS
THERE ANY NUMBERS ON CREEK
TESTING I MEAN IF YOU HAVE SO
IF YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
THAT HAVE THE VIRUS ARE THERE
ARE THERE ARE THERE NUMBER. ON
WHETHER OR NOT. TO PUT PEOPLE
IN DANGER SO WE HAVE TO KNOW
SOME ANSWERS. AND THEN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT CLOSING. WHAT IS THE
COST OF RESPOND TO THE VIRUS
DEALING WITH THE PROBLEMS OF
THE VIRUS PLUS THE COST IS THE
AUDITOR AND- THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S POINT OUT THE COST OF
REHABILITATING HIS VERY FIRST
THAT HAVE THE SAME. AND AS A
MORE BILLION DOLLARS. ACTUAL
COMMITMENT WERE BEING ON INTER
CAN. TO REHABILITATE SOME OF
THESE FACILITIES TO ME THE
NUMBERS ARE THIS. BURDEN TO ADD
UP AND TO EXAMINE AND
SCRUTINIZE AND I THINK. THAT I
AGREE WITH CHAIR. I AGREE THAT.
WE HAVE TO EXAMINE THE SINGS
MORE CLOSELY WE HAVE HAD A
PREFERENCE OVER THE LAST DECADE
TO OF FOCUS ON RE ENTRY AND
HERE'S THE RE ENTRY GRAHAM
BEING CLOSE BUT THE- THE COST
OF CLOSING OF FACILITY IS NOT
INCLUDE. THIS BOOK. IS I
UNDERSTAND THE OF. MAYBE I
WOULD THINK THEY'RE GONNA
PROBABLY COME IN AND SAY WELL
IT'S GOING TO COST YOU X. MONEY
TO TAKE CARE OF ALL PLEASE
MEDICAL COST. THIS YOU KNOW
WHAT IS IT FIVE SIX HUNDRED
PEOPLE. HOW MANY PEOPLE THE
REASON I HAVE A MONTH FROM NOW.
I HAVE. OF WHAT IS BEING DONE
TO CURTAIL IT. IS THIS-
DISTANCING POSSIBLE THESE
FACILITIES MY UNDERSTANDING
THERE'S DORMITORY FACILITIES
THEY CAN'T DO SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THIS READING WHAT THOSE WITH SO
FAR. HOW CAN THE DESKTOP WHICH
SOCIAL DISTANCING THEY CAN'T
REALLY SO. IS IT INEVITABLE
THAT THE VIRUS WILL SPREAD IT
ON. IF THE VIRUS WAS SPREAD AND
THEN WE'LL HAVE MORE PATIENCE
INSTEAD OF INMATES. IT'S GOING
TO COST US A LOT OF MONEY. IT
IS WORTH ARE SCREWED NEED TO
LOOK AT THIS AND I WOULD EXPECT
THAT OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
TAXPAYERS A CALIFORNIA IS THAT
WE WOULD LOOK AT THAT VERY VERY
CAREFULLY. AND GET A GOOD
HANDLE ON THAT NOW RATHER THAN
WAIT TILL PROBLEM IS ON. WITH
THEM BOTH OF MOTOR BILLION
DOLLAR FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS BY
I EXPECT US TO DO. SAM AND
THESE THINGS CAREFULLY AND I
THE CHAIR WHAT HER HER
DIRECTION IS ON THE BUT I ALSO
HAVE THAT WE SHOULD AT THESE
ISSUES AS WELL THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT BELL AND A- THE-
IN OUR NEW. IF WE WERE NO DOING
A TURN KEY SINGLE HERE. WE
MIGHT HAVE HAD THE ABILITY OVER
THE COURSE OF OUR MANY WEEKS TO
HAVE A SINGLE HEARING ON SUCH
THINGS AS FOR EXAMPLE THE CDC
OUR POPULATION WHICH YOU ARE IN
EFFECT- RAISING NOW SENATOR
BILL THAT YOU'RE SEEING A VERY
LEGITIMATELY IN THE CAR. OF THE
DEMO. YOU KNOW NOW THAT THE CDC
ARE WEBSITE GIVE US UP HONOR I
THINK DALY NOW OF THE OF STAFF
IN THE NUMBER OF INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE INFECTED.
IN DOUBLE DIGITS SOME. I'D
STILL THOU IN COURSE ENDED AND
A LARGE NUMBER OF STAFF TO THE
MULTI HUNDRED STAFF. AND IT IS
CONCENTRATED IN A FEW
FACILITIES SO OF COURSE- IN IN
SUCH A- IN SUCH A HEARING WE
MIGHT WANT TO HELP INTO WHAT
WHAT ARE THE- WHAT SAFEGUARDS
ARE BEING PUT INTO PLACE FOR.
THE STAFF FOR THE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS AND THEN OF COURSE
BECAUSE WE THE RITUALS AND TO
THE WITH A CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION IF TIME WITH THEIR
SENSES SERVED THEY ARE RELEASED.
AS ALL THE THINGS WE DOING LIKE
THE CITY HI THIS THE PLASTIC
SCREEN IN OFFICE WE. SIX TO
REDUCE COMMUTE BREAD SO FOR
WHAT SAFEGUARD WE TAKE. BY NO
ME WOULD REACH US PREVENT SOME
FROM GOING AT THE POINT OF NOT
TIME RELEASE. BUT ARE WE DO
TEST FOR UC'S. TO ENSURE. THAT
YOU ARE. THEY ARE CARRIER THE-
VIRUSES AND DOES. APPS A
SYMPTOMATIC THERE SO THAT THEY
CAN BE. TOLD QUARANTINE FOR SO
THAT WE REDUCE COMMITTEE SPREAD
BECAUSE THIS IS A CONGREGATE
FOR AND WE KNOW THAT WE'RE THE
SPREAD IN THE MOST STAFFS IN
CAR PLEASE THE NEW HOMES IN.
THERE I TALKED STOP THEIR WAS
NO WHEN I THERE WOULD BE THE-
IT IN TERMS OF WHAT WE CHARGED
WITH TODAY WHICH IS THE BUDGET
IT WAS WE CERTAINLY ARE IN TO
HAVE TO STAY BUT I KNOW WHAT IT
CAN. WHAT I AM PULL OUT FOR US
TO DO WAY IN AT. AND MAYBE YOU
MY FAILURE MEDIA SHOULD OF. MY
MORE THOUGHTFUL AROUND BUT
CERTAINLY WE AS MUCH AS WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE OP. ARE
SYSTEM ANARCHY DASCHLE SO
BECAUSE IS ALL WITHIN OUR
HEARING ART OR YOU IN A WAY
THAT IS OUR OF IS PUBLIC SAFETY.
DISTRICT DISEASE FIFTY. SINCE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALSO
HAVE TO WEIGH IN RELATIONSHIP
TO HOW WE OPERATE THE
CONGREGATE FACILITY AND AS
SENATOR BILL NOTED THE
FACILITIES WHERE E. VIRUSES
MOST OF THE AT LEAST WE'VE MOST
DID IT ARE THOSE FACILITIES
WITH TORY ASCETICS WHERE YOU
CAN'T GET PERCENT FOR THIS. AND
I RAISE WILL THEIR THING WHICH
IS NOT WITHIN OUR- WHICH THE
WORD IT'S NOT AN I'D IN OUR
BUDGET BUT IT AFFECTS POPULAR
NUMBERS. THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T
EXECUTIVE ORDER- BY MORE THAN A
MONTH AGO MAYBE RIGHT IN MARCH
WHERE. THE FOR THAT WERE BEING
HELD IN COUNTY JAIL THAT WOULD
NORMALLY BE TRANSFERRED TO OUR
STATE FACILITIES THEY WERE HELD
TO BE TRANSFERRED. AND THEIR
DAD IS NOW BEEN LIFTED AND SO
THOSE FOLKS WILL NOW GO INTO
OUR FACILITIES AND IT DOES
RAISE THE QUESTION SHOULD ONE
BE SENT INTO. THOSE FACILITIES
WHERE THERE IS SAYS. MOST
PREVALENT. IN BUT THAT'S THERE
WAS. IN THE WAY AGENDA WAS
CONSTRUCT FOR US REALLY WEIGH
IN ON THAT SO I THINK OTHER
THAN EXPRESS. THAT HI YEAH.
INAPPROPRIATE TO PUT ANY PERSON
IN THOSE WE THE MOST CON SPREAD
RIGHT NOW TO THE- AND AYE SIR.
AS IN IF WE AT THE RECEIPT CA.
ON GENERAL BOTH RECEIVER MADE
COMMENTS ARE. THE HEALTH PRO
AND RECOMMENDED THEY'RE NOT BE
TREE BETWEEN SO IN I WOULD
INTERPRET AS NOT ONLY NOT
TRANSFER BETWEEN STATE FACILITY
ACCENT STATE FACILITY WHY BUT
ALSO COUNTY FACILITY TO STATE
FACILITY BECAUSE EVERY MOVE.
ACE POTENTIAL SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS SO ANYWAY- HEY I WOULD.
WE ARE A LITTLE WE ARE NOT
FULLY OFF THE GENDER BUT WE'RE
A LITTLE BIT SO. WE. THE REBEL
BOOK THE MORE COMPOUND ALIVE IS
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE UNDER
WORK WITH THEY PAN OR THE
PEOPLE THERE ARE WHICH OR LEGAL.
UNDER OUR CARE NOT BE PUT IN
DANGER. BY OUR VERY ACTIONS OR
IN ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE. AND SO
I THINK NOW THAT WE HAVE THE
NUMBERS WE KNOW WHAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE. THE QUESTION IS
LET'S TAKE SOME ACTION. IN SOME
WAY TO REDUCE THE REST. AND
WHAT IS THE PLAN THAT HAS NOT
BEEN PRESENTED TO US AT THIS
POINT AND HOW MUCH WILL IT COST
THEM AND WE DON'T KNOW ALL. IS
GOING TO BE A. A RUN AROUND
THAT- WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANSWER
FOR YET I MEAN WE DON'T KNOW
IT'S GOING TO COST SOMETHING I
CAN PREDICT OUT I CAN TELL YOU
IF THERE'S- IF YOU HAD A SING
HOME WITH 26% OF THE PEOPLE IN
THAT NURSING HOME. HAVING THE
VIRUS THEY THOSE PEOPLE OUT
PRETTY QUICK AND TRY TO HAVE
SOME CONSTRUCTIVE PLAN FOR.
WELL THESE ARE NURSING HOMES
CAESAR FACILITIES HAVE FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND- THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND I'M- SO.
AND EVERY DAY PEOPLE ARE COMING
AND GOING FROM THERE EMPLOYMENT
THERE AND THEY'RE COMING AND
GOING BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN PEOPLE ARE BEING
RELEASED- AND IF WE HAVEN'T
TESTED THESE PEOPLE WE DON'T
KNOW. EXCEPT THERE CARRYING THE
VIRUS. MY SAID WOULD BE TO
DEVISE SOME WAY OF. INCREASING
OURS SEE WHAT THEY CAN DO IT
INCREASED- BY YOU KNOW EXPEDITE
AND INCREASE THE TESTING AND
TRACING OF THE ARRESTS COMING
FROM THE FACILITIES. AT LEAST
TRY TO CONTAIN AT SOME POINT
AND THEN PRESENT US WITH THE
PLAN. WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN SO
THAT'S I THINK WE HAVE A MORAL
COMPUNCTION TO DO THAT I MEAN
IT'S THE SORT OF. AT A GIVEN
EVIDENCE THAT WE NOW HAVE. OVER
A THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT'S- AND
THAT'S- TO ME IT'S OUR OWN OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS JUST THE YOU
KNOW. WE'RE SITTING HERE
TALKING ABOUT THESE LITTLE
THINGS HERE BUT I THINK THAT'S
THE BIGGER PICTURE. AT THIS
POINT GIVEN THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO WORK NOW ON THE IMPACTS OF
THE VIRUS. AND THIS IS THE
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST FACTOR
THANK. I DON'T WANT TO SEAL YOU
KNOW A LOT OF DOUBTS AND- THAT
KIND OF SITUATION THAT WOULD BE
THAT DUE TO ANYTHING THAT WE DO
SO. I THINK WE HAVE TO KNOW
WHAT WE CAN DO AND DO OUR BEST
YOU KNOW FIGURE OUT OUR
ASSISTANCE WAY. WE CAN. MOVE
MITIGATE THE ISSUE AND COME UP
WITH A PLAN SO. THAT'S ALL I'M
ASKING FOR. COME UP WITH A PLAN.
ALRIGHT SO THIS ITEM WAS
TRICKERY DIRECTIONS AND. I SEE
THAT THE LA JOH HAS THEIR HAND
UP SO I WILL. ALLOW FOR THEM IS
IT TOO I NEED TO ASK THE
MODERATOR TO ALLOW THE LA- TO
MAKE A COMMENT OR JUST- OKAY
THERE'S. VERY KAELIN OR NOT
THANK YOU STAFF OF THE LA GO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CAITLYN
O'NEILL WITH THE LEGISLATOR
ANALYST'S I DO WANTED TO NOTE
ON THAT ISSUE YOU UP AS A-
AROUND THAT POPULATION AS A
RELAY TO THE FACTS OF THE
NINETEEN YOUR AB. RIGHT THE JAN
YOU MAY REMAIN. BUT JUST THAT
SAYS YOU KNOW WITH CHANGE IN
THE- THAT ARE PART OF THE MAIN.
DON'T HAVE REFLECT THE AND
EFFECTS OF COKE. NINETEEN
GENERAL A LOT OF ANSWER AROUND
WHAT WILL BE NEEDED SUPPORT THE
POP THE POPULATION. THAT WE CAN
SEE ARE GIVEN THAT THERE'S SO
MUCH UNCERTAINTY ABOUT. THE
ACTIONS OF THE STATE WILL TAKE
IN A FEW REGARDING CO IN
NINETEEN FOR. THE TENSION LEE
MADE. ANY JAILING. FOR A LOT OF
TIME WHICH WOULD REDUCE
POPULATION ON THE OTHER THERE
COULD BE OUT. OF FOR SO. OF
READ OF MANY THE RESULT PRO.
THAT COULD INCREASE. AND FOR IF
MADE ARE NOT I MEAN CREDITS AT
THE SAME. THEY WERE UP WASTE.
SO. BUT THAT BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE DIRECTING CDC ARE TO
PROVIDE POPULATION AND FISCAL.
PROJECTIONS BY OCTOBER FIRST OF
TWENTY TWENTY- THAT REFLECT THE
IMPACT OF CO IN NINETEEN AS
WELL AS- ON ON THE POPULATIONS
AND- THAT FISCAL IMPACTS OF
THAT AS WELL. AND THIS WOULD
GIVE THE BUT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO ASSESS WHETHER
IT RE DIRECT POP. IN FACT EACH
OTHER OR GOING TO NEED TO
AUGMENT POPULATION RELATED
FUNDING. AND THEN THERE WERE
COUPLE OTHER OTHER ITEMS ON THE
TRIGGER. I LESS THAT ARE MY
MYSELF MY COLLEAGUES DID HAVE
COMMON SIGN I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
LIKE US TO OFFER THOSE COMMENTS
NOW OR LATER YOU MAY OFFER NO.
OKAY I'M ON THE ADULT REENTRY
KEEP ON REENTRY GRANT WE DIDN'T
HAVE A SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION
BUT CHEN WOULD JUST NOTE THAT-
IN THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND IN
THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
WAIT COURSE. AND THEN ON THE
COMMISSION CAN'T. CONSOLIDATION
PROPOSAL WE DO RECOMMEND
APPROVING BUT- GIVEN THAT THAT
PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE. THAT
WOULD REDUCE THE CAPACITY OF
CAMPS BY ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
INMATES AND THERE'S CURRENTLY
MORE THAN NINE HUNDRED
VACANCIES I'M IN THE CAMP SO
REDUCE. BUT AS A WAY TO IN
OTHER WORDS CREATE. WITHOUT
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF INMATES
IN THE CAMPS. BUT WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERED DIRECTING THAT
PARCHMENT TO INCREASE THE CAN'T
POPULATION THROUGH. INCREASING
ANY INCENTIVES OR- CHANGING IN
MAINE ELIGIBILITY. TO THE
EXTENT THE STATE IS ABLE TO DO
THAT- IT COULD INCREASE THE
CAMP POPULATION- AND REACTIVATE
SUMMER ALL OF THOSE
CONSOLIDATED CAMPS I'M WHICH
COULD REDUCE STATE COSTS SUCH
AS WILDFIRE COSTS. I'M AND THEN
IN MY CAR I NEED A LEVY HAS A
COMMENT AS WELL. SIR CAN THE
HERE FROM THE NEED TO LEAVE. GO
AHEAD I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE A
COUPLE COPIES. XIN RELATED TO
ADD TO THE JUDICIARY- IT REALLY
HAS THREE PIECES AND- WHATEVER
AMOUNT IS FINALLY DECIDED ON.
WE DO RECOMMEND BUDGET THE
LANGUAGE- IN ONE CASE RELATED
TO THE TRIAL COURT
SPECIFICALLY- AT MINIMUM WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE REDUCTIONS
THE ALLOCATED BASED ON
WORKLOAD. TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT ARE COMPARATIVELY LESS
WELL FUNDED ON A WORK WOULD BE
SINCE RECEIVE A SMALLER SHARE
OF THE REDUCTION LEGISLATION
ALSO HAS A FINE ANY ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE. IT IS NOT SUCH AS
INSURING CERTAIN SOME HOLES ARE
MATCHED. FOR THE REDUCTIONS TO
THE STATE LEVEL JUDICIARY ANY
OTHER JUDICIAL BRANCH PROGRAMS
THE CURRENTLY ALLOCATED ON A
PRO RATA BASIS AND THE
LEGISLATION MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER- CHANGING THOSE
ALLOCATE AND- THERE ARE D. DOT
SO FOR YOU. BLOG WOULD USUALLY
COUNT WILL PROVIDE VALUABLE
SERVICES- THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER GIVING THE
SUPREME COURT IN THE COURTS OF
APPEAL A SMALLER SHARE OF THE
REDUCTION TO ENSURE PUBLIC
ACCESS. SERVICE IT'S- I
ACTUALLY HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT BUT WHEN I READ THE
ALEJO'S COMMENT. BECAUSE FI.
THIS IS TO LONG AGENT I DON'T
HAVE TO LEAF THROUGH IT ALL BUT
MY MEMORY SERVES ME WITHIN THE
PERCENT CUT TO TRIAL COURTS WAS
EQUAL TO THE PERCENT CUT TO
JUDICIAL COUNCIL IN THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE DOLLAR AMOUNT SHOP
THREE DIFFERENT JUST AN BUT YOU
SAY. AS WE MIGHT WANT TO. GIVE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THE- A
SUPREME COURT- T FIRST A LOWER
CUT TO GIVE ACCESS THE COURTS
ARE I WONDERED WHO DON'T THE
TRIAL COURT'S OR DATE. AS MUCH
SKINNER. INTERFACING SAID YES
SO I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY WHAT
IT WHERE YOUR DISTINCTION IS
THAT. THE COURTS- SPRING COURT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAVE MY LOOK.
I NEARLY AGAIN- WE ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZE AS I THINK THE CUT
SHOULD REFLECT THE PRIORITIES
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THAT
COULD INCLUDE SHIFTING
REDUCTIONS BETWEEN TRIAL COURT.
THE SENATE JUDICIARY- OTHER THE
OR THE OTHER USUAL RAN WRAPS UP
SO HOW DOES ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE TALK ABOUT THE CUTS TO
THE TRIAL COURT'S WE WANT ABOUT
WHAT WILL SERVE. FOR OTHER
REQUIRE. A LOT YOUR TIME LEVEL
OF FUNDING THAT WOULD BE NEEDED
TO KIND OF MEET THAT
EXPECTATION AND SO THAT
CERTAINLY CAN BE- SOMETHING
THAT THE NUMBERS ARE TO REFLECT
THAT. AND THEN- I SEE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WANTED TO
WIN BUT BEFORE YOU DO. HI I
JUST WANT. JUST AT. SHE WHEN
THE LA- MAKES A COMMENT THAT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE TO WEIGH. ONE
CUT. OVER ANYTHING ELSE TERMS
OF OUR OWN OF AT THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES BUT I
JUST WAS CURIOUS DEBT WHEN I
WENT THROUGH AND- CAN I MAY
HAVE MISSED SOME COMMENTS BUT-
FOR THE LA. SPREAD SHEET AND
THERE WERE WHEN I WENT THROUGH
FOR THE DC ARE BUDGET THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF NEW
EXPENDITURES COUPLE OF THEM
WERE COURT ARE RELATED SO
THAT'S PROBABLY NO HARD FOR US
TO GET. BACK AWAY FROM. A
NUMBER OF OTHERS- WERE. MORE
LET'S CALL ELECTIVE AND I
DIDN'T SEE LA- COMMENT ABOUT
YOU KNOW IT IT WHETHER THOSE
WERE NECESSARY YET SO I'M I
DON'T HAVE THEM DIRECT I MEAN I
HAVE BEEN FRIENDS RATHER THAN
TO THEM TO. BUT THE- JUST A
COMMENT. YES LISTEN NEW
EXPENDITURES WORD DATE TOTALED
A LOT. ALL RIGHT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HE WANTED TO MAKE A
COMIC GO AHEAD. HE SENATOR
SKINNER JUST NAMING DEPARTMENT
FIND A LITTLE LOUDER YOUR HARD
TO HEAR RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU I
JUST NEED TO MAKE A PART IN A
FINANCE I WANTED TO RESPOND TO
YOUR COMMENTS EARLIER ABOUT THE
REDUCTION AND SEE START. POINTS
AT THE FIRST POINT I'D LIKE TO
MAKE IS. YOU AND BY. THE
REMOVAL OF JJ HE STARTED BUDGET
ASKING FIVE PART OF THE OVERALL
BROADER BEELINE ME PROPOSAL. I
HAVE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS EACH PART OF A YEAR
WERE ACTUALLY RIGHT.
PROGRAMMING BY. AND PERCENT
INITIALLY MANY OF OUR MAJOR
REVISION PROPOSALS REDUCE COSTS
SIGNIFICANT YEARS SO THAT BY.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I SEE
STARS BUT YOU. WHAT WHAT
PERCENTAGE REPEAT THAT. 8% A
LITTLE OVER 8% BY. TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. THERE
ARE ONLY NOTE. YOU KNOW I'VE
COURSE PRICE DEPENDING ON HOW
THAT STONE WOULD PROBABLY
WELCOME THAT I WOULD ONLY NOTE
THAT. THE IN THE MAY ROOF THAT
8% IS EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT THE
LOWEST CUT FOR ANY OTHER AGENCY.
SO IN OTHER WORDS THAT'S AT 8%
IS PROJECTED TO BE ACHIEVEDFOR
THIS DEPARTMENT IN THREE YEARS
WHEREAS IT'S BEING RECOMMENDED
AT MINIMUM EVERY OTHER
DEPARTMENT AT HIGHER RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT THAT
8% IS ROUGHLY ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS BY TWENTY THREE I MEAN
IT'S A LARGE DEPARTMENT WITH
SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND. BUT
AGAIN LOOK AT THE CHART ON PAGE
ELEVEN. AND YOU'LL SEE MANY
OTHER DEPARTMENTS WITH FAR FAR
BIGGER BUDGETS WITH A MUCH
HIGHER PERCENT. CUTS WHICH
OBVIOUSLY WOULD MEAN TO VOTE.
DOLLARS BELIEVE THAT. THINK OF
ME MY POINT. I'M THE- SIR WE
DON'T DO PUBLIC UNTIL THE END.
VERY GETTING USED TO THIS AND
SO THE RECOMMENDATION AND WE'RE
GOING TO VOTE AT THE VERY END
ALSO SO THE RECOMMENDATION ON
THAT ONE IS TO HOLD ITS
PROPOSALS- BUT WE WILL GO BACK
TO IT AND WE WILL. WELL THAT
WILL AND WILL NOT HERE MAN SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE- QUESTION
I AM. RIGHT I THINK I'M GETTING
THIS DOWN. IN CENTER- LIKE IF
YOU'RE CONFUSED SO MY BUT JUDGE
DON'T WORRY JUST I WILL I WILL
RECOGNIZE YOU AT ANY POINT YOU
HAVE A QUESTION OR COMMENT I'M
FINE HI. OKAY SO WE WILL NOW.
ISSUE ONE SIXTEEN DESCRIPTION
ITEM AND- AGAIN MY STAFF TO
CATCH ME IF I MAY JUMP IN OR
MOVE INTO SOMETHING I'M NOT
SUPPOSED TO A RATHER OUT OF
ORDER. SO WE'LL GO TO ISSUE
WHAT ECKSTINE VARIOUS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM PROPOSALS WHICH
WE HAVE- FOR DISCUSSION. AND I
THINK THE A- THE FIRST THE
FIRST TWO ARE THE DJJ THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
CHANGE WHICH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST REFERENCED AND- I
THINK IT'S WORTH IT FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUSTICE
SCRIBE OR WHOEVER. TO DESCRIBE
WHAT IT IS THE MINISTRATION HAS
IN MIND NOW FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE. SELECT SEE.
ALRIGHT SO DEPARTMENT FIND IT'S
GO AHEAD IF YOU JUST NEED A
MINUTE PART OF FINANCE AGAIN.
REVISION PROPOSES TO REALIGN
VISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
TOWARDS YOU CAN BE SURE. GEN
OBVIOUSLY IMPLEMENTED BY
GETTING JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE STOPPING ALL IN
EIGHT IN THIS STATE FACILITIES
AND REQUIRING THAT THE COUNTY
SUPPORT AS- YOU CAN I WAS WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE BE SENT STATE
THIRTY. POSING FEDERAL FUNDING
MATTER. AND THEN OVER THE OVER
SEVERAL YEARS- DJJ WOULD BE
DRAWN DOWN TO A POPULATION OF
ZERO POINT CLOSE. I THINK IF
YOU DON'T MIND IF YOU WOULD BE
WORTH IT TO. I FAMILIAR BUT
PERHAPS FOR ANY PUBLIC THAT
MAYBE OR STAFF THAT OBSERVING
THAT THIS IS THAT WE EIGHT A
CHANGE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
THE ADOPTION THE LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET- WHICH- DIDN'T
NECESSARILY ENTAIL CLOSING OF
THOSE FACILITIES BUT MOVED THE
ENTIRE. NATION INTO A DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENT AND- THAT WE WILL
NOT PROBABLY BE EVEN HEARING
THE ITEM I DON'T KNOW THAT FOR
SURE BUT IF IT. IF HE ACTION
TOOK LAST YEAR BEING CONTINUE
TO DO WOULD FRIDAY BE A
DIFFERENT SUBCOMMITTEE WHO WAS
CONSIDERING THINGS FOR THE TO
THE JUVENILES BECAUSE IT WOULD.
PARCHMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. THAT THAT PART OF
THIS CHANGE ALSO ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU- LAST YEAR WE HAD
PROPOSING THAT HAD BEEN PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR
WE WERE GOING TO MOVE IF YOU'VE
BEEN OUT JUSTICE IN HELPING
SIR. YEAH YOU TO CALL. YOU REST.
I'M WITH A DIFFERENT EMPHASIS
TREATMENT AND PROGRAMMING FOR
WORK RATHER THAN IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
HEALTH. SERVICES THE SYSTEM-
BECAUSE IT. OKAY KEEN IN THE
PANDEMIC WE REALIGNING
RECONSIDERED THAT NOW. MOVING
HOUSING. USE IT THEY COUNTY
COMMITTED IN CLOSE GET EVERY
FAMILY MAKING. AND SO BOTH OF
THE ITEMS. FIVE TWO TWO FIVE
ONE FIVE THREE TWO SEVEN RELATE
TO THAT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU.
REFERENCED SAID ONLY COMMON YOU
WANTED TO MAKE ON ITEM FIVE TWO
SIX TWO SEVEN ALSO JUST THAT
OVERVIEW. THANK YOU SEVEN THE
BOARD OF STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS WOULD BE INVOLVED
IN THIS PROPOSAL BY PROVIDING
THE GRANTS AND FUNDING TO
COUNTIES. IT'S PROPOSAL ON
THAT'S WHY IT'S AN- CAN BE. YOU
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT- I'LL MAKE A COMMENT AND
THEN YES SENATOR MORE LIKE
ABSOLUTELY I'LL CALL IN YOU AND
THEN I KNOW LA WANTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT SO IT'S- I CAN
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A LARGE
CHANGE TO DIGEST LAST. BIG
ENOUGH TO YES THIS IS. TODAY
CHEN. ONLY THING I WOULD NOTE
IS THAT INTERESTINGLY MANY OF
THE COMMUNITY ADVOCATES.
FAMILIES OF USE THAT ARE IN
THIS SYSTEM WERE WERE IN YEARS
PAST AND DEFINITELY LAST YEAR
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE BAITING
MOVED TO HELP SERVICES. WELL
THEY WERE SOMEWHAT OPEN TO THE
SHIFT TWELVE NEWMAN SERVICES
WHAT THEY WHAT THEY ALL
PREFERRED OR AT LEAST WHAT THEY
COMMUNICATED WAS THAT THEY'D
WANT. THE HE'S CLOSED WANTED
THE YOUTH TO BE. THEIR
TREATMENT THERE REHAB PROGRAMS
THERE- THERE. THEY'RE BEING
HELD IN COMMUNITY THEY WANTED
THEM CLOSER TO HOME THEY FELT
THAT WHAT THEY WERE EXPRESSED
IS THAT THEY WOULD BE CLOSER TO
THEIR SUPPORT SERVICES AS- AND-
THEY WOULD. REPORT THREE
INTEGRATED ONCE THE HEAD OF A-
OF THEIR- SENTENCE IN SUCH AND
SO IT'S INTERESTING THAT NOW.
AND I'M ASSUMING PART OF THIS
IS DUE TO- YOU KNOW BUDGET
THREE ON THINKING. THAT BY THIS
SHIFT WHAT MAY NOT COME. DOES
THAT IT'S ONE IT IS CLOSER WHAT
IT IS IT IS HOLDING THE A DOES
TO GET INTO OUR JUVENILE SYSTEM
CLOSER TO HOME. AND I THINK THE
OTHER THING THAT MANY OF THEM
POINTED OUT CNET WE HAD REPORT
ON IS THE FACT. SOME YEARS BACK
THE STATE ASSISTED COUNTIES
AND- WE INVESTED A LOT OF MONEY
IN THEM TO EXPAND. THEIR COUNTY
JUVENILE FACILITIES AND THAT WE
WERE FACING IT LAST YEAR THIS
YEAR A VERY SMALL NUMBER OF
YOUTH IN COUNTY FACILITY WE'RE
HAVE HUGE THE SAUDIS WITH VERY
FEW PEOPLE. AND THUS THE COST
PER YOUTH WAS EXPLORED.
POTENTIALLY HIGH BECAUSE THE
FACILITIES. IN MAINE IN
REGARDLESS MANY FOR IT. SO FOR
EXAMPLE WAS A REPORT IN AND
MORE INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALIST
THAT SHOWED I THINK THIS COUNTY
SANTA CLEAR SPENDING SOME FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PER
YOUTH. OTHER COUNTIES THREE IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE. AND WHAT
PEOPLE WERE UPSET BY THE FACT
THAT IN THE STATE WE SPEND
ABOUT. I THINK IT'S RUN ORDER
EARN FIFTY K. FOR YOU WITHIN
THE STATE FACILITIES THE COUNTY
COSTS WERE MUCH HIGHER. SO I
REACHED THAT BECAUSE WHILE THIS
COULD BE AND I THINK IT'S
ANTICIPATED TO BE. A WAY TO
ACHIEVE SOME SAVINGS IF THE
COUNTIES. CONTINUE TO SPEND
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ARE ALL. ONE THE U. THAT WE
WOULD NOT ACHIEVE THE SAVINGS
NOW I APPRECIATE THAT. PART OF
THE ITEM THE SECOND ITEM IS
THAT THERE WOULD BE GRANTS TO
COUNTIES BUT I THINK THAT WHAT.
WHAT I THINK MANY OF US WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT MORE TIME TO
TALK ABOUT THE DETAILS IN
TRAILER. THAT WOULD ALLOW. SURE
THAT THE REHABILITATIVE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY OBJECTIVES ARE
ACHIEVED BY THIS MOVE BUT ALSO
WE CHIEF THE COST CONTAINMENT
WE DO NOT WANT TO BE PENNY WISE
POUND FOOLISH BUT WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO SEE US GO OUT SO
I WAS AMONG THE ISSUE THAT
WOULD NEED TO STILL BE
DISCUSSED. IN THE IN IN FOR BUT
ON SUCH AN ACTION CENTER
MOORLACH Q. MINIATURE MOVING.
THE SIEGE IN ADULTS TO HHS WAS
IT WAS A PRETTY BIG. DEAL LAST
YEAR AND NOW IT LOOKS LIKE LIKE
A KIND OF A WHIPLASH LIKE ALL
OF A SUDDEN. THE ABOUT FACE
KIND OF MOVE SO. I DON'T KNOW.
IF IT'S A LACK OF VISION OR
LACK OF FOLLOW THROUGH OR LACK
OF MONEY- BUT IF IT WAS GOOD
LAST YEAR WERE NOT GOOD THIS
YEAR AND SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION I WOULD HAVE IS.
MOVING THE- INDIVIDUALS NOW TO
THE COUNTIES IS JUST ANOTHER
FORM REALIGNMENT. AND COUNTIES
ARE STRUGGLING TO SO HOW HOW IS
THIS GOING TO. A WORK OUT. WITH
WITH THEIR FINANCES AND I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM C. SACK FOR.
TO PREVENT THIS SITUATION. OR
THE REST THE BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
SORT OF GET THIS LAST NIGHT SO
THAT SO JUST AND REACT TO A
MANAGER AND MAYBE- DEPARTMENT
FINDING IT. BY LITTLE THERE IF
OF THE- HISTORY OF THE THINKING
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY IT WAS A BIG
BOLD THE LAST YEAR. NOW TO YANK
IT IT JUST SEEMS. I JUST LOVE
TO HEAR THE STORY. AT CENTER
ROAD DID YOU WANNA MAKE GOING.
THE BOY. YOU KNOW LAST YEAR I
DID I DID SOME LEGISLATION ON
THIS AND. THE ADMINISTRATION OF
RUN FINANCE OPPOSE THE BILL- IN
A DEAL WITH THE FACT THAT.
COUNTIES WERE ACTUALLY SENDING.
JUNE DOES FOR LOWER LEVEL. THE
FENCES TO THE STATE AND WE WERE
SPENDING THE MONEY TO CARE FOR
THEM IN THE COUNTIES WHERE
SPENDING ANY MONEY WE NEVER
CHARGE THE COUNTY. SO WE
CALCULATED THAT MAY BE. 25230%
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WERE IN THE
STATE FACILITIES. PROBABLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CARE FOR THE
COUNTY FOR THE FACILITIES BASED
ON THEIR OFFENSES AND IT WAS
VERY INTERESTING TO COMPARE
COUNTIES OF SOME OF THE LARGEST
COUNTIES- AND VERY FOR. PEOPLE
TO THE STATE FIRST SOME OF THE
SMALLER COUNTY SAN AT THE A
DISPROPORTIONATE. NUMBER OF
YOU'VE TO THE STATE FACILITIES
SO HE'S COUNTY. HAD A DIFFERENT
APPROACH SOME COUNTIES LIKE TO
SEND YOU KNOW SOME COUNTIES AND
THE JUDGES THERE ARE LIKE TO
SEND PEOPLE TO THE STATE SOME
COUNTIES DIDN'T BUT- WHEN YOU
SEE THAT KIND OF THING YOU YOU
THINK WELL THERE'S SOME.
DISSIDENTS AND THE WAY WE
MANAGE OUT. THERE ARE NO. I'M
KIND OF INTERESTED THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE NOW. DEVELOPING
A REALIGNMENT OF THESE PROGRAMS.
TO GIVE THE COUNTIES A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR ANNUAL PAYMENT. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
20% OF THE USE CURRENTLY HOUSE
IN THE STATE JUVENILE
FACILITIES ARE SIGNIFICANT SEX
OFFENDER TREATMENT. FOR MENTAL
HEALTH A- SO THEY'RE SAYING IS
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GET MONEY FOR
THESE ARE SERIOUS OFFENDERS BUT
WERE. AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE
ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THE STATE FACILITIES. THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE THIS SHOULD BE IN
THE COUNTY FACILITIES. I LIKE
TO POINT OUT FOR MY STEAM
CENTER FROM ORANGE COUNTY THE
ORANGE COUNTY HIT SINCE VERY
FEW. VERY VERY FEW PEOPLE TO
THE STATE FACILITIES. MUCH
THERE ACTUALLY ARE LOWER THAN
MOST OF THE LARGE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK THEY'RE THE
LOWEST FOR EXAMPLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN PROGRAMS AND
THEY- TAKE CARE. IN THE MOST
SERIOUS OFFENDERS. SO I THINK
THIS NEEDS TO BE SQUARED UP AND
SQUARED AWAY. AS PART OF THE US
AND WE'RE WE'RE BEING ASKED TO-
ALLOCATE MONEY FOR THIS OKAY
THAT'S WHY THIS IS A VERY
COSTLY WHATEVER WE DO. WE HAVE
TO I THINK DETERMINE SOME
STRICT GUIDELINES ON HOW AND
ACCOUNTABILITY SO THAT WE'RE
WE'RE SERVE EVEN HANDED ABOUT
THAT'S GONNA PUT BY. ARM WE
ATTEMPTED TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR THEY
DID NOT- SICK WE DID NOT
SUCCEED BUT NOW THEY'RE COMING
BACK WITH THIS PROPOSAL. I
THINK THERE TO BE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY. A RELATIVE TO
THE NEXT SECTION TWENTY. I
THINK THE BORDER COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS ISSUE WE RISK GOT
AN AUTO. THERE IF YOU READ THE
AUDIT I DID I GOT THE AUDIT- ON
THE BORDER COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS AND THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION OF. THE JG CPA
AND THEY SAID THE- OVERSIGHT IS
WEAK. AND OF THE LOCAL CORD AND
COUNCILS OR DOING THINGS
DIFFERENTLY IN EACH COUNTY KIND
OF JUST WHAT I JUST TALKED
ABOUT. IT. I'M SURE I WOULD
PROPOSE SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
WHAT YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT. OF
WE'VE MANDATE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
MEASURES FOR THE COUNTIES ON
THESE TWO PROGRAMS AND THE HAVE
THE BOARD OF COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. HOUSE ROLL THE
FINE THEN FORCED IN TERMS OF.
THE TRAILER BILL THIS DEVELOPED
ON THIS WE GOT TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS. A REAL LINE OR YOU
HAVE TO HAVE SOME STANDARDS WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOME CONSISTENCY.
WE CANNOT COVERED BODY DOING
THEIR OWN THING WE- THAT WOULD
NOT BE FAIR TO THE TAXPAYERS A
CALIFORNIA BE AWARE THE MONEY
IF WE DID THAT IT WOULD BE
MONEY SPENT. DIFFERENT A IN
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT'S NOT THE
CORRECT THING TO DO SO I WOULD
PROPOSE THIS BE ADDED- PERHAPS-
IF YOU ACCEPT THIS
RECOMMENDATION TO ESTABLISH AN
MANDATE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT MEASURES FOR
COUNTIES. AND ABORT. THE BORDER
CAN YOU CORRECTIONS THEN PUT
SOME FORM OF A LANGUAGE ON THAT
ISSUE IN THE TRAILER BILL AT
SOME POINT. ON THE ISSUE IF
FORGET. SO THAT WOULD BE MY
RECOMMENDATION IS A MESS IN MY
COLLEAGUES TO. SUPPORT THE-
ACCOUNTABILITY OF I SPENT ABOUT
TWO YEARS ON THAT BILL IT GOT
THROUGH RIGHT TO THE END AND
THEN. YOU KNOW IT STOPPED WENT
THROUGH THE SENATE. NOBODY
OPPOSED THE REMOTE WAS PRETTY
MUCH. THE SENATE THE WENT TO
THE ASSEMBLY OF GOD STOPPED AND
APPROPRIATIONS. SO I THINK I
TAKE- I THINK THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD RECOMMENDATION OUR HOPE
YOU CAN ACCEPTED MY COLLAR.
CENTER MORE MARK AS WELL THANK
YOU. CENTER WILL APPRECIATE
THOSE. WHAT YOUR EXPRESSION
BECAUSE IT'S CONCEPTUALLY AND I
WILL CALL IN LA NEXT BUT
CONCEPTUALLY I DO KNOW THIS.
WHAT OF WHEN I GOT ELECTED TO
THE ASSEMBLY AND I FEEL LIKE
I'M GETTING TO RE LIVE. I GOT
ELECTED DURING THE I GOT
ELECTED I TOOK OFFICE RIGHT AT
THE POINT WE AT THE SIXTY
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT
SO TWO THOUSAND AND- DECEMBER
OF TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT NINE
ON. AND WAS THROWN INTO MY
FIRST SHOULD VOTE WITHIN A WEEK
OF BEING SWORN IN AND WELL NOT
BUT I WON'T. GET A- MORE
BECAUSE IT. WILL ONLY BRING
BACK ALL THE PTS. BUT THERE ARE
DURING THAT TIME. WE HAD DOUBLE
NUMBER OF WAR IN THE JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND WE WERE SPEND
FIXING AMOUNTS MONEY AND THERE
GREAT DESIRE TO CLOSE THOSE.
WITH WERE MORE THAN AND THEY
WERE IN AND A FIFTH WILL
DETERIORATE. THANKS SO WE MADE
A FEW. THAT WE COULD ONE OR TWO
I CAN'T READ ALL THE WE CHANGE
THE SOME POLICY IN ANY TO THE
NOW WORRIED ABOUT HALF THE
POPULOUS. OF BAD DEBT. RIGHT WE
HAVE A SEVEN HUNDRED. DID YOU
HEY MICHAEL STAFF RATE WITH
RANGE THAT'S HUNDRED SO. EIGHT
HUNDRED. SO IN THIS CHANGE THAT
WORK HARD TO. OR THAT WAS BEING
BROUGHT TO US. IT WILL MOVE
ABOUT EIGHT HOW PEOPLE. VARIOUS
COUNTY FOR AND ALL I WOULD HAVE.
WHY DON'T THE IT'S STATE SPOKE.
IT WOULD TO THEIR COUNTY OF. ON
AND BUT FROM WHAT TO BELLS IS
FOR X. YOU KNOW. ORANGE COUNTY
MAKE IT VERY FOR BECAUSE THEY
SAID FEW AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT
OTHER. ARE LIKE THAT THE WAY TO
SEEN A- BUT ANYWAY SO CAN.
SINCE THERE IS BEEN. LONG
DESIGN. TO CLOSE THOSE STAY TO
SELL FOR NON EVERY WHY BECAUSE
OF THEIR REMOTE LOW. MANY OF
THAT. HAD LESS AT. TO HOLDER.
OF MENTAL HEALTH AND- EDUCATION
AND OTHER TYPE OF PROGRAMMING.
PERFECT EXPERTS IN SUCH. AN
IMPROVISED THE TOP OF. UP
SERVICES THAT THE PEOPLE NEED
IT. YOU TO SEE IF THERE'S TO
REALLY PUT A PAIR OF REBUILD.
AND OF COURSE WE THAT EVERY
AREA OF THE STATE BUT MOST OF
OUR CAL OR- SACKS THAT THEY
HAVE MORE AT. TO THAT TYPE OF
PROGRAMS. SO CONCERT. A THIS IS.
A GOOD MOVE HOW WHAT WE THINK
ABOUT WE HAVE NO OF. CAN
PLEASE. DON'T HOW MANY OF THE
HAVE SENT BOOKS TO JUVENILE BUT
LET. ME WALK YOU GOES BACK TO
ONCE A REMOTE COUNT. NO WAY
THAT DOES FOR. THE FOR THAT
RIGHT WE'VE ONE TO SO I THINK
THERE ARE TWO. SOME THAT WE
WANT HIM OUT REAL BECAUSE WE OP
WE TO INSURE. THAT IF WE GO
WITH THIS PROPOSAL IN SHOULD BE
CAN. THAT WE ARE PROVIDE. THE
LEVEL OF SIR AND AB WE WE'VE
CHIEF THE OF IN THAT NOT
PUTTING ASIDE A IN OF IN A
CAMPER FACILITY THE REAL THERE
IS REALLY NO SOME FOR THEM WE
ARE GIVING THEM SOME THE COUNTY
SOME OUT. DATE IN SUCH A
TRAILER BILL. AND I'M SURE
THERE ARE SOME OTHER THINGS
THAT WE WOULD. WANT TO PUT IN
SUCH TRAILER BILL BUT WHILE I
HAVE LOOKED AT THESE FOR A FEW
MORE DAYS IN A SENATOR MORLOCK
I STARTED READING THEM THE VICE
THE DAY IT DROPPED- I CERTAINLY
HAVEN'T. WE WANT TO ENSURE WAS
PUT IN TO LANGUAGE TO
FACILITATE THIS KIND OF MAJOR
SHIFT. THAT WELL I DESCRIBED BY
COULD CONCEPTUALLY SUPPORT SO-
I THINK THAT ARE. SUGGESTION TO.
BACK TO THE WAS THIS. THE OUR
RECOMMENDATION ON THESE HOLD
THEM OPEN WAS THAT I CAN
WHERE'S THAT. I WILL TELL YOU
BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
DIDN'T KNOW IF I SIDE ANYWAY.
BECAUSE IT WOULD GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT. DUE TO OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION FOR THE BUDGET WE
MIGHT HAVE TO LAND ON A DOLLAR
AMOUNT. FOR OUR- OUR THANK YOU
KNOW IN ORDER TO VOTE. UP
AFFORD BAND ON OR BEFORE JUNE
FIFTEENTH BUT IT MAY TAKE US A
LITTLE LONGER FOR THE TRAILER
BILL. THAT'S NOT UNUSUAL BUT I
THINK OF A SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE
LIKE THIS WE MAY NEED MORE TIME
SO I JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT
OUT. A POSSIBILITY. TRAILER
BILL. THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT
ACTIONS IN ANOTHER CALL
CONSIDER BILL AND THEN CENTER
MORE LIKE AND THEN I WANT TO
CALL IN LA OF I HAD. ONE ISSUE
IT'S REFERRING TO PAGE FIFTY-
GOSH IT'S ON MY OLD PAGE FIFTY
SIX WHAT'S THAT- IS ON ISSUE
FIVE TWO TWO SEVEN OKAY. ED IS
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE REALIGNMENT.
LET ME SEE IF I CAN FIND THE
CORRECT CASEY ITEM THE AREA OF
THE. ZERO FIVE TWO TWO SEVEN.
OKAY AND IT TALKS ABOUT. THE
THREE REGIONAL SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT HUBS FOR WAR TO ME
THE ASSOCIATE CRAP OKAY THAT'S
IN THAT IS RIGHT HERE THAT IS.
JUST. IT'S TO ZERO EIGHT AGES
WHICH- SO IT'S JUST RIGHT HERE
ON THE SECOND PAGE OF THE
TRIGGER SO ARE NOT TRIGGERS
IT'S SEC PAGE IS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM PROPOSALS SO
ISSUE ONE SIX EIGHTEEN. AGAIN
IT DOES HAVE THAT COLUMN NUMBER
FIVE TWO. PAGE FIFTY AND IT'S
NOW PARAGRAPH ABOUT TO SUPPORT
THE COUNTIES. THERE WOULD BE
THESE THINGS INCLUDING THE
REGIONAL HUBS OKAY THE QUESTION
I HAVE IS. IT SAYS. NATION OF
20% OF THE YOUTH CURRENTLY
HOUSED IN STATE JUVENILE
FACILITIES THAT HAVE
SIGNIFICANT. SIX BEHAVIOR
TREATMENT. OR MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT NEEDS. AND THE
QUESTION I HAVE IS WHY ARE THEY
BEING GROUPED TOGETHER IS THAT
WAR SHOULD THAT BE HAND OR IS
IT. IF IT'S AN ORDER IT'S NOT.
PROBABLY APPROPRIATE YOU'RE NOT
MIXING SEX OFFENDERS WITH
PEOPLE WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
SO IF AN END THAT MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE. SO CHECK. I WOULD
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT THAT. SELECT
JUST CLARIFICATION SO ARE
FRIEND THAT YOU WOULDN'T EXPECT
TO HAVE THOSE WHO ARE
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED
FOR WITHIN SEX OFFENDER
TREATMENT HUBS ABSOLUTELY NO
OKAY. THE GOOD. YEAH SO THEN
THEY THEN THEY GO ON TO SAY WE
WANT TO ESTABLISH THREE
REGIONAL SEX OFFENDER HUBS WITH
THOSE- WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR
THAT WHY DID THEY PICK THREE.
HER. PER UNIT YOU KNOW. REMAIN
SO. IS IT LIKE TEN PEOPLE PROOF
FOR EACH ONE. WHAT IS THE
NUMBER WHAT IS THE SIZE OF THE
US HOW MUCH SHOULD YOU KNOW
THEY'RE ASKING FOR AN MILLION
DOLLARS I GUESS. BUT A MAN
SUREST TO BE HELD OPEN. SO I
WOULD HAVE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT OUR SERVICES THREE
REGIONAL MEETINGS THAT THEY
WANT TO HAVE- SO ON THE STATE.
SOME OF THE THINGS KIND OF. I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT YOU KNOW
MIKE. EXACTLY HOW MANY YOUTH IN
THE STATE FACILITIES ARE IN THE
SEX OFFENDER SIGNATURE IT IT'S
WORDED IT NEVER GETS OFFENDER
ALLEGORY. IT WILL. BRING ABOUT.
THE REASON I ASK
IT WOULD BE TEN. IF IT'S LIKE
FIFTY PEOPLE START GOING TO BE.
SEE IT'S GOOD FOR YOU A BOARD
THAT COST WAY MORE NOT. OKAY SO
LET'S HEAR FROM THE LA OF. GO
AHEAD ON THE SIDE OF. RED
RELIEF YOU TO OR YOU CAN SPEAK
TO ONE YOUR VOICE. TOMORROW THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WE RECOMMEND THIS PROPOSAL AS
IT IS TO CONSISTENT WITH OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. BUDGET TRAILER
PLACE YOUR DRESSING UP ITEMS
WHICH WOULD BE CONCRETE FOR THE-
OF. DJJ BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THIS WOULD
AVOID RUNNING THE INSTITUTIONS
WHERE SMALL POPULATION HI COSTS
THIS STATE WELL GIVEN THE
COUNTIES TIME TO. ALONG
COUNTIES TO CONTRACTORS DJJ
FULL COST ASSESS COUNTIES WITH
THE TRANSITION AND BROUGHT. OR
IS IT YOU SEE THEY DON'T HAVE.
IS IT. UNTIL CLOSER DATE AND
YOUR TUNES. CIRCLE THE TWO. THE
WOULD BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR BEFORE THE EIGHT.
OR THREE WORKING. IT FUNDING
FOR COUNTIES WITH AN AMOUNT
THAT THE SEC DETERMINES
NECESSARY TO RUN AN EFFICIENT
PRO. JULY TWENTY TWELVE. ALLOW
EASY TAUGHT ME THAT THE NATION.
AND FIVE IT TAKES STEPS TO DO
SO LIKELY USE BEING SENT TO
STATE PRISON AS A RESULT
REALIGNMENT THAT IS ABOUT THE
AGE OF YOURS. I'M ON THE
RECOMMENDATION ON THAT WOULD
STRONGHOLDS OF THE TRANSITION
TO DO I SEE ARE USED TO THE
RESTORATION WHICH WOULD BECOME
AS OF THE LAST BUDGET. I'M A
STAY IN ON THAT IS. SB FIND OUT
WHEN WE RECOMMEND ELIMINATING
AN ADDITIONAL ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION THAT WAS APPROVED AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TO
SUPPORT TRANSIT. THIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY- WOULD NO LONGER BE
NECESSARY HOWEVER IT IS STILL
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ORINDA CATCH
THAT ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
WHITE HOPE FOR TRIGGER CUT. BY
HAD SPOKEN THIS BOOK IN IT WAS
THE REAL LINE ITEM. THAT WE ARE
THE IT'S TWO REALIGNMENT ITEMS
ON KIJIJI THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD OPEN BUT THE WITHDRAWAL OF
THE TRANSITION YOU WERE GOING
TO PROVE HIS BUDGET. FIVE
THAT'S THE COMMITTEE WE COURT.
OFFICE THEY'RE ALL HERE WHOA
ONE THE FIRST. ONE FIVE TWO TWO
FIVE IS THE- STOP BEING THE
INTO INTO THE STATE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE. WHILE IN
CONCERT HE PART OF THAT SINCE
THE CAN. TO THE- IN EFFECT THE
REALIGNMENT SERVICE WE STOP
TAKING ANYONE THE STATE
FACILITIES BY JUST EXTENSION
THAT MEANS YOU'RE YOU WOULD
EXPECT THAT THE COUNTY WOULD BE.
MMHM SO THE YOU WOULD NEED TO
KNOW WHAT YOU WERE. ALSO YOU
NEED SOME OF THESE. SPECIFICS
THAT WE WERE DISCUSSING SO
THAT'S HOW I SEE THEM LINKED
AND THERE THAT'S WHY
RECOMMENDING ALTHOUGH SO THAT
WE HAVE THE ABILITY WE- THE
AMOUNT OF JUNE FIFTEENTH THE
JUNE FIFTEENTH BUT- IT ALLOWS
US TO DO. YOUR LANGUAGE BUT BY
BEING A GIVE US MORE TIME
RATHER BUT BY IT BY ACTING ON.
THE FIVE TWO FIVE ITEM WHICH
IS. OUR START BEATING DISTRICT
DECISION WE WOULD BAN KI SAYING
YES WE WILL- WE WILL REVERSE
OUR ACTION THE LAST YEAR. WHICH
IS. A D. J. J. INTO A THAT
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES OR
THIS NEW. SORRY I. A BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF THIS REALIGNMENT. WE
WON'T VOTE YET BUT THAT'S WHAT
THE THAT'S WHAT WAS ENVISIONED
BUT I WOULD RECOMMEND THAT WE
PERHAPS MODIFIED THE PREVIOUS
BUDGETED. WE COURT. ALEJO'S
POINT ABOUT THE ONE SEVEN
MILLION. THE ONLY OTHER COMMENT
I WOULD TODAY ALEJO'S I THINK
THE POINT ABOUT MAKING A
SPECIFIC DATE IS GOOD I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT THE OUT. TO THE
COUNTY SPEAK CLEARLY. THE TV-
WILL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT JUST
HOW THIS INTERFACE WORKS AND SO
THE OTHER SPECIFIC THE LA YO
RECOMMENDED I'M BY. I A N.
NEUTRAL ABOUT AT THE MOMENT IS
BECAUSE- I HAVE TO. I WOULD
WANT THEM THOUGHT ABOUT IN THAT
WHOLE CONTEXT LIKE THERE MAY
NOT BE A REASON TO AN INTERVAL
OUNTIES IF WE HAVE. THAT WE'RE
LOSING. THAT MAY BE THEY HAVE
TO DO ANY KIND OF INCENTIVE
VISITATION HOWEVER WE MAY NEED
TO IF WE'RE STOPPING INTAKE. WE
MAY NEED TO THE- MORE SOONER
THAN LATER ENSURE THAT THE
COUNTIES HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES. SHOP. GO AHEAD
SENATOR BILL OF YOU COULD YOU
ADD INTO THE MIX. GIVEN THE
FACT WE HAVE. HELLO AGING
PRISON THAT HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WITH THE VIRUS SENATE. IF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IS
INTENDING TO. USE THESE
FACILITIES THAT ARE MORE MODERN
THAT ARE YOU FACILITIES FOR
THEIR OWN ADULT PURPOSES THAT
SHOULD BE MAYBE. LOOKED OUT.
LIKE THE ONE IN CERTAIN
STOCKTON IS A LOT. NEWER THAN.
THE NEW FACILITY AS A SINGLE
PERSON SELF FACILITY THEN
THERE'S PART OF IT IS A
DORMITORY BUT- I THINK THAT'S-
TO DETERMINE WHAT TO DO WITH
THE PROPERTY SELL TO. YOU WE
CLOSEST HOSPITALS WE HAD A
SPECIFIC PLAN THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
THE TRAILER BILL AT THE TIME
YOU KNOW IN IMPOSED ON THE PART
OF THE- THIS IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PRESENTING A
PLAN TO THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT
HOW CLOSE THE FACILITY. THROUGH
THE PROCESS. BUT WE HAVE AN
THERE'S BEEN NO WORD SPOKEN
ABOUT. IF WE'RE GONNA
TRANSITION AND CLOSE THESE
FACILITIES WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO A WOMAN WHAT THE PER
IS A GONER IS THERE GOING TO BE
DECLARED SURPLUS OR THEY'RE
GOING TO USE FOR. AL'S SOME OF
THE- PEOPLE. PERHAPS IN THE
FUTURE HAVE A REPORT COME TO
THE COMMITTEE OR SOMEHOW GET
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT. IF
WE'RE CLOSE STATE. THIS. OF IT
WE HAVE PRISONS ARE MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR OR MAINTENANCE
AND REHAB WE MIGHT LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE NEWER FACILITIES TO
HOUSE SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE ADULTS SYSTEM I DON'T
KNOW SO WE CAN LOOK. PERHAPS
WELL WERE UNDER THIS PRESSURE
AT THIS MOMENT YEAH TO ACHIEVE
A BUDGET FIGHT ON OUR CONSPIRE
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE PERHAPS.
ONCE OR BUDGETS ADOPTED WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO HAVE A
ADDITIONAL HEARING WHERE WE
COULD DELVE INTO SOME OF THE
SUBJECTS AND- GET A LITTLE MORE
COLDER ENGAGEMENT ALSO AND ALSO
HAVE HAD THE ABILITY THINK
ABOUT A LITTLE MORE. AND THAT
IT COULD HELP US OUR WITH OUR-
THOUGHT PROCESS ON THE TV A
LANGUAGE. AND ADDITIONALLY WE
MIGHT CONSIDER SOME OF THE
THINGS RELATED TO COPE WITH
THAT WE STE THAT WE JUST
BROUGHT UP IN DISCUSSION WHEN
WE OPENED THE HEARING. BUT FOR
WHICH THERE'S NOT A. PARTICULAR
ITEM WITHIN HERE FOR US TO SAY
E. MODIFIER OR HAVE BEEN HAVE
AN IMPACT ON THAT AND SINCE I
CAN I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT
THE VIRUS WILL NOT BE OVER WITH
BY THE WEEK AFTER JUNE
FIFTEENTH BUDGET ADOPTION WE-
IT'S PROBABLY JUST AS RELEVANT
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION.
HEARING SOMETIME THEREAFTER. GO
AHEAD SENATOR MORE LACKEY THANK
YOU MANAGER I GET THE SENSE
FROM REVIEW OF THE MATERIAL
THAT. YOU KNOW TRYING TO GET
SOME. I JUNE FIFTEENTH. ALSO
HAVE TRAILER BACK TO FILL BILLS
FROM THE LANGUAGE ARE WE
LOOKING THEN IT MAY BE SOMETIME
IN AUGUST DOING THIS CAN BUDGET.
TO MODIFY WHAT WE DID TO MEET
THE CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS.
I THIS TIME I'M I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET WELL I OF COURSE THAT IS
FROM WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND I'M
ABOUT DAYS I COULD I CAN LAUGH
AND SAY IT'S ABOVE MY PAY GRADE
BUT- I WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE A
CONSTANT. PUBLIC TO ADOPT IT
ONCE BUT- DOLLAR ME. BY THAT
DATE. DOOR CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION DOES NOT REQUIRE US
TO HAVE LANDED ON ALL OF THE
SPECIFIC POLICY PARTS WHICH ARE
WHAT WE INCORPORATE INTO A. T.
B. L. IN BECAUSE THIS ITEM. IF
WE COMPARE SOME OF THE OTHER
ITEM IN THIS PACKET. ARE JUST
CHANGES IN EXPENDITURES THEY'RE
NOT CHANGES IN POLICY THIS ITEM
HOWEVER BECAUSE WE LAST YEAR WE
DECIDED TO. MOVE DAY G. D. J.
J. OUT OF CORRECTIONS IN INTO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. AND
LEAVE OUR AWARDS THE STATE
FACILITIES. NOW WE HAVE BEFORE
US NOT ONLY A DOLLAR CHANGE BUT
A VERY SICK POLICY CHANGE SO
WHAT I WAS DESCRIBING IS THAT.
WE COULD TEN INCH LAN ON. THE
DOLLAR CHAIN. BY OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DODD LINE BUT
GIVE US SOME MORE TIME TO LAND
ON THE ALL OF THE POLICIES
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. NOW WHETHER
PASS JUNE FIFTEENTH THERE ARE
OTHER BUDGET ACTIONS THAT
RELATE TO DOLLARS I THINK IS
MUCH MORE TO DO WITH FOR
EXAMPLE WHETHER OUR- REVENUES
IN TWO. FROM WHEN THAT PLEASE
WHEN HE MOVED TO THE DATE
INCOME TAX FILINGS AND IF THE
REVENUES GO WAY LOWER THAN
PROJECTED I WOULD IMAGINE. IN
PASSED FROM MY PAST EXPERIENCE
SO IT WILL BE ABLE LOOKING AT
OUR BUDGET BUT A- I YOU KNOW
NOW WE MAY BE. DOING DAHLE.
AFTER THAT A JUNE DEADLINE BUT
WE MAY BE DOING SEVENTY BE OUT
ONCE SAID HELP LITTLE BIT OKAY.
THE RESULT. YEAH OKAY. BOB. ALL
RIGHT- AND. WE HAVE A HAND UP
HELLO YES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOU HAVE YOUR HAND UP. WE HAVE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU OKAY. SO THOSE
WERE JUST THE DJJ ITEMS THERE'S
A COUPLE OF OUR OTHER ITEMS
WITHIN THIS DISCUSS ART. FIVE
THE. THE OTHER ONE THE REPORT
FOR DISCUSSION WAS THE-
RECOMMENDATION THE MAY REVISE
FOR. THE CAP ON PAROLE WHICH IS
WOULD. PROVIDE US SOME SAVINGS
REDUCTIONS AND- ON. I WAS- I
WELCOME TO THIS PROPOSAL
BECAUSE THE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BOTH
SPECIFIC CALIFORNIA'S ACROSS
THE US SHOWS THAT FOR MOST
PAROLEES TWENTY FOUR MONTHS IS
ALL THAT'S REALLY NEEDED FOR-
FOR THAT SUPERVISION AND THAT.
THOSE WHO- WHO HAVE NOT MADE
MODIFICATIONS THEIR CRIMINAL
BEHAVIOR DEMONSTRATE THAT
BEFORE- TWENTY FOUR MONTHS OR
WITHIN A TWENTY FOUR MONTH
PERIOD- SO THE ACTUALLY GIVEN
THE TYPE OF DEFICIT WERE FACING.
I WOULD JUST COMMENT THAT FOR
EXAMPLE DURING THE LAST
RECESSION. SWEPT SOMETHING THAT
MANY MANY FOLKS MENDED BUT WAS
NOT DONE SO WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
ACHIEVE. THINGS THROUGH SUCH
CHANGE LIKE THIS BUT INSTEAD WE
BASICALLY ELIMINATE ALL
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM. THAT
WAS HOW WE GOT SOME SAVINGS
BACK IN LAST RECESSION IN THE-
WE HAVE TO SEE THAT IN.
PARTICULAR MEETING THIS MAY
REVISED THERE'S NOT A WHOLE
SALE JUST ELIMINATION OF OUR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS I AM
AWARE HOWEVER THERE ARE LACKS
THAT ARE HAPPY WITH JUST
BECAUSE KOBE BECAUSE WE'RE- BUT
COME. SO RIGHT NOW BUT THE
REASON I WANTED TO DISCUSS IT
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PUT INTO
STATUTE. THE ABILITY FOR UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS FOR ELDERLY
PAROLE MEDICAL PAROLE AND SOME
COMPASSIONATE RELEASE. AND AS I
PUT. SINCE THE STATUTES WERE
APPROVED AND THEY WERE PROVED
OVER AND IT'S BEEN AT LEAST
EIGHT YEARS THERE BEEN VERY
VERY FEW PEOPLE IN OUR
FACILITIES WHO WERE WHO HAVE
BEEN IT- TO ALLOW. TO USE THOSE
STATUTORY PROVISIONS AND WHEN I
LOOK AT THE DATA WE FOR EXAMPLE
HAVE AT LEAST ONE AND MAYBE
MORE. OF COURSE READ AN
INDIVIDUAL FOR NOW IN HOSPICE.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE HAVE-
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND EIGHT
HI WE ALSO HAVE SOME THAT ARE.
COMPLETELY INCAPACITATED IN IN
HOSPITAL TYPE SETTINGS AND IT
BE PERMANENTLY AND THE REQUIRE
A WHOLE DIFFERENT LEVEL OF. OF
OUR TO PROVISION. THIS IS
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH AND I FIND
IT ESPECIALLY DURING A TIME OF
CODED WHERE IF I WERE THE STAFF
I WOULD NOT WANT TO BE IN A
HOSPITAL SETTING HAVING TO PARK
SOMEONE. AND I SO. I FELT IT
WAS IMPORTANT FOR US TO. FOR
STAFF TO LOOK AT WHAT WERE THE
INADEQUACIES IN THOSE STATUTES.
THAT HAVE LED TO SO FEW
INDIVIDUALS OVER THAT PERIOD OF
TIME. BEING PROVIDED EITHER
MEDICAL OR L. LEE PAROLE WHEN
IF WE LOOK AT THE HEALTH COSTS.
SO WHAT THE- IN THE C. C. OUR
BUDGETING TERMS OF OUR
EXPENDITURES OVER THE LAST FIVE
TO SIX YEARS. IN THE HEALTH
COSTS NOW PART OF THAT IS DUE
TO FEDERAL COURT ORDER THAT
REQUIRED US TO PROVIDE A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF HEALTH TO A
COMPLETELY PRIEST THAT. THE
PART OF IT THIS JUST LIKE IN
THIS. AT LARGE YOU HAVE A SMALL
PER PEOPLE THAT. HELLO
CONDITIONS CAUGHT THE GREAT.
HEALTHCARE COSTS SAME AS IN THE-
AND WHEN WE YOU LOOK AT THE AGE
PRO. OF SOME OF OUR SO. WE HAVE
PEOPLE EIGHTY SOME. COULD IT.
AND THERE NOT ALL OF THOSE ARE
A GREAT TO BUT THERE'S MANY
THAT HORRID COST TO US IN OF
THERE THE MOST MEDICALLY. NOW
UNDER CO IT SO IT SEEMS TO GIVE
THAT THERE THE- IT MAY. WAS
PUTTING FOR. CHANGE AND FOR ALL
THAT WE MY LOOK AT. THE
STATUTES. AND SEE WHAT THE-
WHAT INADEQUACIES EXIST IN THE
THAT IF CAUSED THEM NOT TO
QUITE A CHIU WHAT THE- INTENT
WAS SO THAT WAS MY HOPE AND SEE
IF BY AGAIN. THE NO WAY WHICH
BEFORE US BECAUSE ALL OF IS
WHAT YOU KNOW WE DON'T ALL THE
CAME VERY QUICKLY AND SO. STAFF
FOR DISK IT. THE JUST IS THAT.
SENATOR BILL. CORD THE THIS IS
ISSUE AS YOU POINTED OUT. OF
SPECIALLY THE AND GIVE THE
SEARCH THAT WERE IN WHERE WE
HAVE. THE HI WRISTS FROM. AS A
DETERRENT PAUL HEALTH PEOPLE
HIGH RISK PATIENTS. IN A THIRD.
AB AND THEN BE HAVE WE YOU SAY
THOUSAND PEOPLE SO FIRST THAT
HAVE THE SO I WOULD SAY THIS IS
LIKE. BROUGH IF WE DON'T DO
WEEK BE THE LOW BIT. BUT I'M
I'M- DAD PROBABLY IS. I DON'T
THINK WE OUGHTA ROSS AT THE
ABOUT ON STAFF I MEAN YOU YOU
HAD A PERSON NOT THAT WE'D BE A
TO CHANGE AS FAST ENOUGH SO. IF
THERE'S A CO PATIENT BUT YOU
KNOW IF ONE THE IT. WHO A
CARBON. THEN PUT ON OF IT
BITTER. SEEN IS THAT WHAT THERE
ARE SOME PEOPLE WANT THEIR AND-
DURING. IT BY AND LARGE THE
INTO. ARE INTO BAITED. CUT THE
PERCENTAGE YOUR RECOVERY DOWN.
DO YOU IMAGINE BE THIS WHO HAVE
TO BE IN THE- IN. WORE A. IS IT
CHEATING WHAT WE INTENDED. SO
SIR MOORLACH WITH CDC ARE. WERE
WERE JUST FACING NOW JUST A
MASSIVE. QUICK MODIFICATION TO.
ECONOMIC TIMES- BUT WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT SYSTEMIC ISSUES-
ANALYZING KNOW WHAT CAN WE DO
TO IMPROVE. ENTIRE SYSTEM. THE
LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY APPROVED BILLS
THAT. PROHIBITS THE USE PRIVATE
PRISONS COMPLETELY. MAYBE IN
GOOD TIMES THAT'S OKAY. BUT IN
TOUGH TIMES THE PRICE
DIFFERENTIAL PER YEAR OF WHAT
IT TAKES TO. HOUSE IN IN MADE A
STATE PRISON VERSUS A PRIVATE
FACILITY. HIS RATHER DRAMATIC.
ALMOST FIFTY WITH FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR. SO IF
YOU WERE TO MOVE TEN THOUSAND.
INMATES TO PRIVATE FACILITY
SHOULD SAVE A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS. AND SO I DON'T KNOW
HOW A DISCUSSION LIKE THAT
WOULD START BUT SOME OF THE
SYSTEM MAKE BRING SAID. MAYBE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SHOULD SHOULD LOOK AT WHAT WHAT
CAN WE FIX NOW. THAT WOULD
CARRY OVER- AN AFFRONT TO SEVEN
MONDAY IN THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE WHAT. WHAT CAN
WE DO TO NEGOTIATE DOWN RETIREE
MEDICAL. WHEN I WAS A
SUPERVISOR WHO WE NEGOTIATED
WITH THE BARGAINING UNITS AND
WE REDUCED OUR IN FRONT OF
LIABILITY BY 71% THEY AGREED TO
IT. WE DID THAT HERE AT THE
STATE LEVEL THAT WE'RE PROBABLY
TALKING SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS
WE COULD REDUCE. AND THAT WOULD
FREE UP A LOT OF MONEY FOR.
SCHOOL YOU SEE AN- SYSTEM AND
YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU KNOW SOMEHOW
SOMEWHERE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE A LOOK AT WHAT CAN
WE DO UNDER THESE CONDITIONS
THAT WILL HELP US IN THE FUTURE
THE PENSION PLAN WILL COME BACK
IN HIS HEART AND TWO OR THREE
YEARS. THE WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS VICE GRIP THAT'S COMMON
YOU KNOW AND SO I JUST REGULAR
MANAGER JUST AS WE LOOK AT HOW
WE RUN CALIFORNIA'S AS COMPARED
TO THE OTHER OTHER PRACTICES IN
A WHERE CAN WE TAKE A HARD LOOK
AND MAKE SOME. CHANGES TO
REALLY FIX SOME STE. BEING AS A
AS COULD BE. THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME BROACH THAT SUBJECT
CERTAINLY. SO THE- FINAL ITEM
ON THIS PART OF OUR DISCUSSION
WAS- AGAIN WHEN I PULLED FOR
DISCUSSION WHICH IS THE THAT A
REVISION. BUT HAS SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING THE
GOOD CONDUCT CREDIT EARNINGS
AND- IT I WOULD. I WOULD
ANTICIPATE THAT PART OF THE
INTEREST THERE IS THAT IF GIVEN
THAT THIS BUDGET IS PREDICATED
ON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DESCRIBED ITS PERPETRATED ON
THE- ABILITY TO. CLOSE SOME OF.
FACILITIES WITHIN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS. AND CLEAR
THREE FIVE YEARS IF YOU IF WE
HAVE THE SAME POPULATION. TODAY
IF WE HAVE THE SAME POPULATION
IN THREE YEARS THAT WE HAVE TO
DAY THAT WOULD BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO CHEAT SO- SOME OF
IT IS AROUND IMPROVING OUR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING AND
GIVING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE. IT WENT STRAIGHT.
BUT THEIR SKILLS AND SAY. THAT
DISALLOWED THEM TO EARN THOSE
ADDITIONAL CREDITS TO EITHER
EARLIER TIME TO GO BEFORE THE
PROBE ORDER EARLY RELEASE. OUT
ON THE REASON WHEN THE PUBLIC
WAS FIVE I A SUPPORT IT BUT I.
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE OF EXACTLY HOW THAT
CAN BE ACHIEVED THERE THERE
WILL DEBATE THING WAS THREE
YEARS AGO AROUND WHAT. THE WHAT
THINGS COULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CREDIT IT'S PROP FIFTY SEVEN IS
BROAD AND THERE WERE AND WHAT
WAS WE DID ON WAS FROM SOME
FOLKS HAVE POINT OF VIEW YOU
KNOW DO NOT IT WAS IT WAS A
RATHER. THERE WAS MORE. AND SO.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
WE LOOK AT THAT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND AGAIN WE MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO. RESOLVE IT FULLY
BEFORE OUR I DO BUDGET OPTION
BUT THAT WE HAVE- A GOOD A
ROBUST PROCESS AROUND. WHAT
THINGS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
CREDIT AND WHAT ARE THE
CONDITIONS FOR. KING THOSE
CREDITS. SELF THAT WAS SEVEN
AND WE HAVE BEEN LA- COMMENT I
BELIEVE ON THIS GO AHEAD-
MISSONI OLD. THANK YOU I JUST A
COUPLE POINTS ON THIS ISSUE
THAT I WANTED TO RAISE- THE
FIRST IS A TECHNICAL BUDGETING
ISSUE AND THE SECOND IS A BIG
PICTURE ISSUE I'M ON THE
TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CORES SOME
SAVINGS IN THAT BUDGET YEAR
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR
POPULATION REDUCTION THAT IS
ESTIMATED TO RESULT FROM THESE
CREDIT CHANGES. I'M AND THAT
DOES CHANGE. THOSE SAVINGS
DON'T ACCOUNT FOR SAVINGS AN
INMATE HEALTHCARE COSTS SO WE-
THE MEAT THAT THE SAVINGS COULD
BE HERE ABOUT ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GREATER IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THEN THE
SECOND ISSUE IS THE BIG PICTURE
ISSUE THAT I WANTED TO MENTION-
IS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES THAT THE CHANGES.
INCORRECT ERNIE. THIS YOUR
FROZE WE DON'T HEAR YOU RIGHT
NOW SHE'S FROZE WHICH NAME AND
FORM A COUPLE. OF. RIGHT NOW
YOU'RE NOW YOU'RE SURE YOU JUST
NEED TO THE BLACK LITTLE IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE SET UP ON
OKAY. GREAT SORRY ABOUT THAT-
SO IRATE DID YOU HEAR ME
DISCUSS THE ONE POINT TWO
MILLION AND ADDITIONAL STEPS.
YES OKAY. GREAT AND SO THEN
MOVING ON TO THE BIG PICTURE
ISSUE WHICH IS THAT- BE
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATES THAT
THAT POPULATION REDUCTION
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE- CHANGES
TO GOOD CONDUCT CREDIT EARNING-
RATES WOULD REDUCE. IRAN NINETY
HUNDRED INMATES IN THREE TWENTY
FOUR WHICH IF YOU COMBINE THAT
WITH THAT PROPOSED CHANGES TO
RECEPTION CENTER PROCESS THESE
WHICH WOULD ALSO REDUCE. GEN
WE'D BE LOOKING AT A ROUGHLY
ELEVEN THOUSAND INMATE
REDUCTION BY TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR IN ADDITION
TO THE ON GOING DECLINE IN THE
POPULATION THAT JUST IN CASE
FIND TREND- AND SO. THIS DATA
LEVIN THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
DECLINE WOULD ALLOW FOR FURTHER
PRISON CLOSURES BEYOND IT TO
THAT THE GOVERNOR- HAS
INDICATED HE WOULD CALL. I'M
AND SO THIS COULD CHANGE THE
COMPOSITION OF THE INMATE
POPULATION. AND FOR HER AND
ATTACK- CHANGE OR REDUCE THE
NEED- FOR CERTAIN CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT ARE TIED
TO THE INMATE POPULATION LIKE
THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS BEDS
PROPOSED OR MEDICATION
DISTRIBUTION GROUNDS FOR
EXAMPLE- IT WOULD AND SO FOR
THAT REASON- AND FOR THE REASON
OF. BECAUSE PRESENTS THE
ADMINISTRATION HASN'T BEEN
IDENTIFIED PRISONS OR CLOSURE
IN THE NEAR TERM. WE RECOMMEND-
HOLDING OFF ON AND-
INFRASTRUCTURE PAPA ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROPOSALS AND
TELL THOSE PRESENT ARE
IDENTIFIED AND THE STATE HAS A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW TO
POPULATION REDUCTIONS WOULD
AFFECT THE COMPOSITION AND
INMATES AND THE NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THEN I
ALSO- TO MENTION THAT IF YOU
WOULD- MY COLLEAGUES HAD
COMMENTS ON THE TERMS THAT HE
BE HAPPY T SHARE IF YOU LIKE.
AND BEFORE WE GO TO THE- BOBBI
GET TAKE OUTLAY DISCUSSION
WE'VE GOT THAT IS PULLED ITS
NEXT ISSUE. BUT HI I WOULD
RAISE THAT IT- DE LA DID A
REPORT ON PROP FIFTY SEVEN
CREDITS BACK I THINK TO WHY
DON'T KNOW PLEASE TWO OR THREE
YEARS AGO AND THEY IDENTIFIED
OPPORTUNITIES WERE. IT'S AN OF
THAT WERE NOT INCORPORATED IN
WHAT. WHAT WE'RE NOT
INCORPORATED IN WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE DID THE CDC OURS
PROGRAM AND WHAT WAS IN THAT
FINAL BUDGET AND SO I THINK
IT'S THIS IS PART OF WHY I. DID
STAFF TO RE LOOK AT IT AND THEY
I THINK THEY SHOULD GO BACK TO
LA OWES REPORT BECAUSE THERE
WAS GOOD EXTENSIVE WORK THAT
WAY- REPORT. THAT WE MAY ONE
INCORPORATE IN THE BACKUP FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
IF IT'S NOT THERE. A SO THE-
WAY COMMENT IS IT ON VISA FOR
CAP OUTLAY SINCE CAPITAL A
OUTLAYS NEXT. BY THE OTHER
COMMENT RELATED TO THAT PEARL
TERMS OKAY FILTERS ARE A GO
AHEAD. MY FROM MY COLLEAGUE
LUKE LUKE GO AHEAD. YEAH SECOND
BY FAILING. THE USER YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU WE'RE JUST COMMON THAT
IF THE LEGISLATURE WAR TO
APPROVE THIS PROPOSAL FOR A
PAROLE TERMS- THERE MIGHT BE
ADDITIONAL SAY ABOUT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- DUTIES. RISING
INDIVIDUALS NOT HAVING BEEN
ADJUSTED FOR- FOR EXAMPLE THE
COULD BE SAVINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT WITH YOUR INDIVIDUALS
ON ELECTRONIC MONITORING. THANK
YOU. OKAY GREAT WE LIKE TO HEAR
ABOUT OTHER POTENTIAL SAVINGS.
ALRIGHT SO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE YOU WANT A COMIC GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ROBERT NELSON
PART OF FINANCE. ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION LIST ON THE
WHICH WE DID HEAR THAT ON THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
GOOD CREDIT YES REFERENCE I TT
ALL WORK WITH US CLARIFYING.
YEAH YEAH THERE WAS IT MANY
TIMES RETROACTIVITY I WOULD
CONTACT CREDIT SHE PRIVATE.
SHOULD BE UP BASED ON WHAT THEY
BIRD VERSUS GOING BACK AND
CHECKING FOR THIS YEAR
ASKREDDIT. I'M WELL THAT WILL
HAVE TO BE CUT FURTHER
DISCUSSED BECAUSE THAT HAS BEEN
AN ISSUE- ONGOING ENACT. BUT
CURRENTLY- THERE ARE FACILITIES
THAT FIVE BASICALLY WE IT WOULD
THERE ARE INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS WHO PLEADED PROGRAM
MAX FOR EXAMPLE WHETHER IT'S AN
EDUCATION RATHER. AND THEN THEY
WERE TOLD OKAY THIS WHAT DO WE
DON'T HAVE GOOD NEVER OCCURRED
SO YOU CAN'T USE THAT AS A
CREDIT FOR FIFTY SEVEN BUT THEN
WHEN THEY GO TO RE APPLY FOR
THAT PROGRAM. BECAUSE THEY WANT
TO ENABLE IT TO BE A CREDIT
THERE TOLD NO YOU CAN'T TAKE
THE PROGRAM AGAIN BECAUSE YOU
ALREADY TOOK IT SO WE CAN HAVE
A DOUBLE STANDARD WE CAN'T HAVE
IT WHERE YOU THAT THE SYSTEM
HAS THE RECORD THAT THEY TOOK
THE PROGRAM. BUT DâN DOES NOT
ALLOW THEM TO CREDIT FOR SUCH
PROGRAMS OF THOSE RULES THAT'S
ONE OF THE USE AMONG OTHERS. SO
WE JUST WANT TO A- MAKE SURE
THOSE. HAVE THAT DISCUSSION TO
MAKE SURE SOME OF THESE THINGS
ARE PROPERLY ACCOUNTED FOR.
ALSO LIKE TO COMMENT ON.
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH A PARTY THAT
REASSESSED YOU FALLS YOU
BECAUSE CORTISOL STADIUMS OKAY
GREAT. ALRIGHT SO THAT WAS
THOSE GO AHEAD SENATOR ABOUT
JUST JUST ON GOOD CONDUCT
CREDIT GUESTS. IT SEEMS LOGICAL
THAT GOOD CONDUCT IS. GOOD TO
HAVE IN OUR STATE PRISON SYSTEM
SO ANY KIND OF SYSTEM THAT
INCENTIVIZE THAT WOULD BE
WELCOME I WANTED TO POINT OUT
THAT- IT SHOULD BE EQUALLY
APPLIED TO PEOPLE THAT HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AS WELL AS OTHERS
BECAUSE- OF SOME. THE PEOPLE IN
THE CATEGORIES IN THE
FACILITIES. DON'T HAVE THIS
LEVEL OF OPPORTUNITIES. TO GET
THE CRAP THAT'S SO THAT I HOPE
THAT IT'S EQUALLY APPLIED FOR
OR ALLOW YOU KNOW THEY HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ALLOW PEOPLE THAT
MENTAL HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES TO GET GOOD
CONDUCT CREDITS- I THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND THOUGH THE LEVEL
OF CONTROL THAT THEY WOULD.
UNDER WOULD BE PASSIVE FOR.
LESS BEHAVIOR CHALLENGED WAY IN
THE FACILITIES. SO THAT WOULD
ADDITIONALLY INDIRECTLY SAVE
US. MONEY AND IT WOULD BE
EASIER FOR THE STAFF TO OPERATE
OR FACILITIES. OKAY SHOW TIMES
WE WILL MOVE ON SINCE WE ARE
NOT VOTING TWO BILLION THEN
WE'LL NOW GO TO ISSUE ONE
SEVENTEEN THIS IS THE- VARIOUS
CAPITAL OUTLAY AND- THE REASON
YOU WANT TO DISCUSS THIS ONE WE
DON'T HAVE TO GET INTO. AN
EARLY. WE KNOW THAT OF MOST NOT
ALL BUT MOST EXCEPT FOR THE
MOST THE NEWEST- OUR FACILITIES
ARE AGE TODAY HAVE. AREAS NEEDS
WHETHER ITS ROOF SURVEY YOU
KNOW HOW A WHOLE VARIETY OF
THINGS THAT OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE-
ROLL OUT LATE IN THERE WE
OBVIOUSLY NEED TO MOVE ON.
APPROVING SOMEWHAT CAPITAL DAYS
OF FOR THOSE FACILITIES-
IMPROVEMENTS. HOWEVER WHAT I
THINK MOST OF US WANTED TO DO
WAS ENSURE THAT. WE ARE IN A
SITUATION WE ARE AUTHORIZING A
SIGNIFICANT EXPENDITURE ON A
FACILITY WE INTEND TO CLOSE
WITHIN TWO YEARS SO- I EIGHT I
AM NOT INTO. THAT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PART IN A
FINANCE WOULD SAY TO US TO DAY
OKAY THE EARTH SO THESE WE ARE
CLOSING BUT WHAT I WOULD HOPE
THAT BEFORE. TOO BACK TO RAISE
THE- YOU KNOW THAT THE ONES.
ANY BIG TICKET ITEMS ARE FOR
FACILITIES THAT ARE IN TEND TO
BE DATA. WE INTEND TO CONTINUE
TO UTILIZE. ON BUT CERTAINLY WE
CAN HEAR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GO AHEAD CENTER ROW YOU WANNA
MAKE TOM AT FIRST WHEN I LOOK
AT THIS I LOOK AT THE SAFETY OF
THE- STAFF IN THE- INMATES FROM
THE VIRUS AND- I WOULD ASSUME
IF WE WERE VERY DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THAT. THAT THE OF AT
SOME POINT WE CAN- A
REIMBURSEMENT SO. I JUST WANT A-
THROW THAT IN THERE. BECAUSE OF
pITS THE SAFETY OF THE- STAFF.
AND INMATES IT'S DIRECTLY
RELATED TO THE VIRUS I THINK
THAT COULD BE. POSSIBLY A WE
MET WOULD HAVE A BETTER CASE AT
LEAST FOR REQUESTING A FOR
REIMBURSEMENT THANK YOU. GOOD
POINT GOOD POINT- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE DID YOU WANT TO MAKE
ANY COMMENT. NOT NECESSARY TO
DON'T. I WAS IN A POINT OUT
THAT THERE'S MANY
CONSIDERATIONS THAT BECAUSE
YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE- CLOSE.
DURATION AND- OR EVEN THOUGH
SINCE YOU START LOOKING AT. NOW
IT WAS CLOSE YOU'RE SORT OF THE
DEFINITION YOUR POINTS THE CARD.
THIRTY SEVEN MY PROPOSALS TO
HOLD IT OPEN JUST BECAUSE-
AGAIN LA- WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHICH CLOSED BEFORE AND
ARE NOT. I YOU KNOW I SUPPOSE
I'M A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
LITTLE MORE FLEXIBLE I DID
LEAST WANT TO KNOW ANYTHING WE
ARE. PUTTING SIZEABLE
EXPENDITURES TO ONE ON THE TYPE
OF THE CAPITAL OUTLAY THAT'S
GOT A MULTI YEAR OF A OF A LIFE
FOR VALUE THAT WE WOULDN'T BE
WE WOULDN'T THERE WE DON'T.
APPROVING FOR FACILITIES THAT
WE INTENDED TO AT LEAST. OKAY
SELF WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ITEM
ONE EIGHTEEN. AND THAT ITEM IS-
pBRANCH AND IT WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS APPROVED. IN THE PAST
TO ALLOW FOR- AND THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH TO. THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
FOLKS WHO ARE HE HAVE
INFRACTIONS OR OTHER THINGS
THAT. REALLY ARE NOT IT THE- TO
USE THE WORD AND DID YOU ANYWAY
UNABLE TO PAY THAT THERE WOULD
BE- THE COURTS WOULD BE ABLE TO.
CAMPBELL THAT MORE EFFICIENTLY
WITH AN ON LINE TOOL INSECTS
AND- THIS THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES AN EXPANSION OF THAT
WHICH I THINK IN PRINCIPLE AS
MUCH AS I AM HESITANT TO
AUTHORIZE ANY NEW GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS I THINK YOU'VE GOT
PROBABLY MANY MANY PEOPLE RIGHT
NOW. BE FACING AN END OF THE
DAY HEY BUT THERE WAS SOME
DETAIL. AROUND THE- YOUR BILL
TO INSURE THAT THIS WEEK AND-
HE A THAT IT MEETS THE
STATUTORY INTENT THAT WAS
INTENDED IN WHEN THIS WHOLE
SYSTEM WAS GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
WHEN LAUNCHED AND- I'M SURE
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM SOME
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS A I'M
JUST TRYING TO. NOTES FOR A
MINUTE IF I HAD ANY FOR. BUT.
ONE THING ABOUT- HAVING OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END WE
IT'S A LITTLE HARD TO BUT
ANYWAY THAT'S- SO I THINK IT'S
MOSTLY TRAILER BILL. THAT WE
WOULD NEED TO YOU KNOW HAVE
SOME GET INTO SOME DETAIL ABOUT.
NOT NECESSARILY THE EXPENDITURE
BUT ON MY STAFF THE LA- HAS A
COMMENT OKAY GO AHEAD LA YOU.
ON THIS PROPOSAL- WE ARE
ACTUALLY RECOMMENDING THE
LEGISLATURE REJECTS THE
PROPOSAL- IN THIS IS BECAUSE
THE IMPACTS OF THE TOOL ARE
STILL UNCERTAIN BECAUSE OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM. KEY THIS YEAR ME
AND AS I WAS AND GETTING A NOTE
SAYING THAT YOU'RE TIãU WE
ARE TO. I'M SORRY- SO I
CONTINUED MY- THE IMPACTS OF
THE ONLINE EDUCATION TOOL ARE
STILL UNCERTAIN BECAUSE IT'S A
PILOT. AND IT COULD REQUIRE
MORE PAYING THEM. AND IT'S ALSO
PREMATURE TO EXPAND THE TOLD
PRIOR TO THE COMPLETE TEN.
STATUTORILY REQUIRED EVALUATION
OF THE PART WHICH WOULD NO
LONGER BE REQUIRED UNDER THE
PROPOSAL SH IT'S FOR A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND ON THAT.
THROUGH THE END OF DECEMBER THE
FOR. EIGHT I'LL PORTS.
IMPLEMENTED THE ABILITY TO PAY
COMPONENTS AND THE OTHER
ACTIVITIES THAT WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE TESTED ARE NOT GOING TO
BE IMPLEMENTED UNTIL THE END OF
TWENTY- AND- TWENTY. THERE'S
REALLY BLACK TWENTY EIGHT OF
ANY OF THE COURTS SH. SO THIS
HE HAS YOU KNOW THERE AND
THIRTY IN TERMS OF THE ON THE
COURT USERS ALSO ALL THE
IMPACTS. HAVE UPON THE VARIOUS
STATE LOCAL FINDS. BY THE CAR.
AND THE TAX THAT IS INCLUDE FOR
THAT TRIAL COURTS OVER THE
DIGITAL RASH COULD ACTUALLY BE
HIGHER THAN WHAT CURRENTLY
IDENTIFY WE JUST WANTED TO PUT
THOSE- COMMENTS OUT THERE THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE. ARI EXPECTED
BECAUSE I DID READ THAT COMMENT
BY THE LA- AND IT MAY BE
APPROPRIATE TO POTENTIALLY
LIMIT THE EXPANSION DEPENDING
ON- WHAT MORE WE MAY LEARN
AROUND CERTAIN OF THE COURTS.
BUT I THINK TO ELIMINATE IT
RIGHT NOW AT THE POINT WHERE WE
HAVE. AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE INABILITY
TO PAY- DOES NOT MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME SO. BUT CLEARLY
WILL HAVE THEIR SOME DETAILS
THAT STILL HAVE TO BE. WORKED
OUT DOES ANYONE ELSE HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. OKAY THN WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE- NEXT ITEM WHICH
IS DOJ DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THAT IS ON. THERE IS A- TWO
ISSUES IN DOJ THAT WERE RELATED
TO THE- TESTING OF SEXUAL
EVIDENCE. THERE WAS ONE THAT
WAS. IS NEW MONEY NEW MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT SB TWENTY TWO WHICH
ARE. BASICALLY HAS SOME NEW
REQUIREMENTS AROUND THIS THE
TESTING OF SEXUAL EVIDENCE- BUT
THEN THERE IS THE SECOND ITEM
WHICH IS A RE VERSION OF-
MONIES THAT WERE APPROVED IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET THAT WOULD
HELP THOSE JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE A BIG BACKLOG. SO I FOUND
IT INTERESTING ON THE HAND YES
IT IS TRUE WE HAVE A GENERAL
FUND DEFICIT AND CERTAINLY WE
NEED LOOK FOR EFFICIENCIES COST
SAVINGS BUT THAT WE WOULD BE
DIVERSITY. ONE DOLLAR AMOUNT
THAT HELPED US INSURER. THE
TESTING OF THE THIS SEXUAL
EVIDENCE AND YET WE WOULD BE
THAT FINDING ANOTHER ACTIVITY
THAT MIGHT HELP SO THEY SEEM TO
I MEAN I WOULDN'T CALL IT
CONTRA THREE BUT CERTAINLY- TWO
MILLION. IT WILL NOT WIN THE
KIND OF DEFICIT WE HAVE ANY
DOLLAR AMOUNT WE CAN SAVE IS
IMPORTANT BUT I KNOW THAT THE-
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAD
ALREADY PUT OUT IN OR IF P. AND
THERE WAS A RECENT ARTICLE
SHOWING SOME JURISDICTIONS WITH
VERY SIGNIFICANT BACK LOADS AND
I WOULD EXPECT AND I CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT THOSE JURISDICTIONS
WOULD FIND FREE GRANTS TO IT
THEY GOT RID OF THE DOG. AND I.
BUT SO I WOULD PREFER THAT THAT
THAT NOT BE REVERTED. AND I'M
HAPPY TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENT FROM EITHER DOJ OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
ANYBODY ON THE DíAS. ENTER
SKINNER THIS IS AT THE DRAMA
CHIEF ADDITIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT I'D LIKE TO ASK-
THE DIRECTOR BUREAU FIREARMS
VERY MILLER TO PROVIDE. ARE
THESE TWO THE TWO ITEMS WERE
DISCUSSING ARE ON THE SEXUAL
EVIDENCE. EXACTLY OKAY. RIGHT
YES HELLO SORRY CAN YOU HEAR ME
THIS IS VERY MILLER FROM THE
BUREAUCRATIC SERVICES. YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU GO HEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- AS FAR AS THE- THE
FIRST ITEM AND- ITS RELATION TO
THE SECOND ITEM WE SUBMITTED
THOSE IS TO SEPARATE- ENTITIES
THE RIVERS AND THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT HAS TO DO WITH MONEY
THAT WAS. AND TO DO TO GET TO
ON LOCAL DURING. OUR AS GRANTS
TO HELP SUBMIT AND TEST THAT
EVIDENCE IN AS YOU- POINTED OUT
WE DO HAVE IN OUR STAY OUT
THERE FOR THE LOCALS TO. AND
THAT MONEY. THIS FISCAL YEAR.
THE FIRST ITEM- WAS ACTUALLY IN
RESPONSE TO LEGISLATION SB
TWENTY TWO AND A SPECIFICALLY
GEARED TOWARDS THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE. BASED ON AN
EVALUATION THAT WE DID OF THE
INCREASE IN SEXUAL ASSAULT
EVIDENCE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD SEE ONLY OUR SERVICE AREA
AND I NEED RELATED TO- TESTING
THAT ANTICIPATED INCREASED. THE
NIGHT- M. I DIDN'T THE- HEY I
DIDN'T COMMUNICATE EVERYTHING
THAT WAS ON MY MIND BUT PARTLY
IT WAS I KNOW THAT FORTUNATELY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE LABS
HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB AND THEY
DON'T HAVE A BACKLOG IN THE
AGENCIES THAT YOU SERVER SO
THAT YOUR LEG SIR ALSO AS FAR
AS I KNOW DO NOT HAVE ACKLOGS.
IT IS A OTHER AGENTS THAT DO
AND THAT'S WHY I FEEL IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO RETAIN THE
MONEY THAT YOU JUST PUT THE ARE
PAY OUT ON EMPLOYMENT. TO BE
TWENTY TWO AYE SIR WANT THAT
IMPLEMENT BUT GIVEN THAT THE
THIRTY J. FAR AS I KNOW THE
BACKLOG SOME TIME BY COUPLE
SNAPPLE IT WAS UNCLEAR TO ME
WHAT I. F. T. NEED. GIVEN OUR
THE FISH POSITION. YES MA'AM
SURE- I DEFINITELY UNDERSTAND
THAT- QUESTION- AND WE- HAVE
BEEN CONSISTENTLY WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T EXCEED
THE LEGISLATIVE MANDATE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS FOR THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE BUT IT. AND AT
THIS TIME WE- LOOKING AT THE
INCREASE IN POTENTIAL- SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE WE WOULD SEE
IT IT'S LIKELY THAT WOULD START
TO PUSH UP AGAINST THAT LINE
JUST BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WORKING AT. CITY AND WE HAVE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME. OKAY ALL
RIGHT TO BE CONTINUED. OKAY ANY
OTHER COMMENT. ALRIGHT SO WE
WILL GO TO. YEAH I MEAN I BUT
I'M VERY I AM A ONE SAY KUDOS
TO DOJ FOR KEEPING UP AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT-
WE'RE NOT ADDING F. T. E. I
APPRECIATED ON. SEVEN
DEPARTMENTS COULD BENEFIT FROM
AND I DON'T MEAN TO BE IN
TAKING LIGHTED THIS BUT COULD
BENEFIT FOR NO FTP GIVEN OUR
FINANCIAL POSITION WE ALWAYS
HAVE TO LOOK VERY CLOSELY AT
THAT POINT. RIGHT TO OWN A MOVE
TO THE- LAST ITEM UNDER THIS
BUDGET THIS PART OF OUR HEARING.
FOR DISCUSSION WHICH HIS BSE.
AND ITS RELATED TO SIDE-
SPENDING AUTHORITY FOR A GRANT
THAT IS BEING GIVEN BY THE FEDS
AND. THE REASON I WANTED BOARD
FOR DISCUSSION IS THAT WE ARE
UTILIZING IT WE IT IS TO HELP
US- COVER INCREASED COSTS CODED
FOR PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT FOR
PUBLIC SEE SHOWS AND FOR THE
WHOLE IDEA OF THINGS AS LISTED
AS DESCRIBED HERE RATHER THAN
MY REPEATING THEM- BUT WHAT I
WANT. SURE THAT WE WERE CREATE
FLEXIBILITY I KNOW THAT THAT
THE FCC IS IN TURN GOING TO BE
PROVIDING THIS FUNDING TO
LOCALITIES THIS NOT GOING TO
NECESSARILY BE. BITES AND THAT
WE HAD A SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY AND I WHEN I SAY
LOCALITIES I DON'T MEAN
NECESSARILY INTO SUB CITY
COUNTY JUDGE BUT TO THE
PROGRAMS. THAT ARE. YOU KNOW IT
REGIONALLY AND SUCH IN THAT I
DON'T KNOW YET WHETHER. YES YOU
SEE IS GOING TO DO IT IN AN R.
F. P. TYPE OF MANNER OR WHETHER
THEY ARE YOU KNOW HOW IT'S
GOING TO BE BUT I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THE HOUSE. FLOOR SO
THAT THE- THAT. PERSONNEL WHO
ARE NOT ALWAYS SWORN OFFICERS
BUT THAT WHO ARE SUPERVISING
PAROLE FRAWLEY'S FOR EXAMPLE OR
RUNNING A REENTRY FACILITY WITH
PAROLEES THAT ALSO NEED
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND SUCH
THAT THEY AND ANYWAY THAT THERE
IS FLEXIBILITY. IN B. B.
ENTITIES THAT RECEIVE THIS
MONEY CAN SPEND AND WHAT I'VE
NOTICED IS THAT THERE ARE SOME
THE STATES ARE VARYING EVERY
EVERY STATE HAS GOTTEN SOME
LEVEL OF THIS GRANT AND THEY
HAVE BURIED IN HOUSE- I
DESCRIBED IT OR HOW THEY PUT.
BUT OHIO ILLINOIS VARIETY OF
STATES HAVE BEEN PRETTY
FLEXIBLE STILL MEETING THE
OBJECTIVES THAT ARE LISTED HERE
BUT ALLOWING FOR MORE THAN FOR
JUSTICE WARNER FIRST SHOW ED
BSE SIERRA REVIEW ONE TWO PART
OF FINANCE FIRST YOU WANT TO
MAKE. COMMENTS ARE DIFFERENT AS
THE SEC. HI MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS KATIE HOWARD WITH THE BSE
SEE CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT YES
KATE THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANKS WHERE- THE
FLEXIBILITY TO APPEAR REMOTELY
TODAY- YES WITH- TAKING ANY
MORE TIME THAN IS NEEDED. IN
THE AGENDA IN MOUNT THAT WILL
COME TO THE SEC OR ALLOCATION
OUT TO THE FIELD IS FIFTY EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WE
DID JUST RECEIVE WORK. THAT ARE
OUT PATIENT WAS APPROVED ALL SO
TO SPEAK FUNDING COME ON QUITE
SOON. WE'VE DELIVER CREATE.
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT FINANCE
STATE AND IN THIS FUN IS TO GO
OUT TO STATE LOCAL AND TRIED
GOVERNMENTS YOU DESCRIBED-
CENTERS ENTER THERE IS A FAIR
BIT OF FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THAT
CAN BE ALLOCATED LOCALLY WE'RE
STILL WORKING WITH STATE AND
LOCAL. AND ARE. YEAH MOST WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT AT
LEAST INTERNALLY SO FAR IS THAT
THEIR- THIS. CALL GO OUT AS AN
ALLOCATION FOR THE LOCALS TO
DETERMINE WHAT THOSE NEEDS ARE
RATHER THAN A COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROGRAM OBVIOUSLY THE NEEDS
RELATED TO. CORONAVIRUS
RESPONSE THE ENTIRE STAGE SO
APPRECIATE YOUR-INPUT TODAY
ABOUT AS MUCH FLEXIBILITY AS
POSSIBLE FOR. ORGANIZATIONS
ENTITIES THAT ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES. ALSO BE ABLE TO USE
THIS FUNDING- FOR THINGS LIKE
PETE PETE AN OVERTIME AND SO
FORTH SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE NOW STAFF YOU KILL ME CLEAR
FIVE DO WE DO THE PUBLIC
COMMENT NOW. OKAY ARTILLERY TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY FINAL
COMMENTS FROM YES CENTER MORE
LIKE GOOD OKAY GREAT YES YEAH.
OKAY SO LET ME BE THE FIRST.
TURN TO THERE'S ANYONE
PHYSICALLY IN THE ROOM THAT'S
CORRECT THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO
FIRST ALL RIGHT SO IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS HEARING ROOM WHO
WANTS TO COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
ITEMS WE HAVE EITHER SOME VOTE
ONLY ITEMS WE HAVE. DISCUSSED
NINE LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN. FOR CONFERENCE ROOM
NO ALRIGHT SO I REALIZED THAT
IT DOES TAKE A LITTLE TIME
SOMETIMES FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE BY PHONE. WE DO
HAVE SOMEONE WHO JUST WALKED IN.
BY NO THAT'S MY OTHER STAFF. I
REMEMBER MY FAR DISTANCE IS NOT
AS GOOD NOW I RECOGNIZE YOU- SO.
OUR MODERATOR WE I WILL REMIND
THOSE AS I OPENED IN MY- SCRIPT
THAT IF YOU. YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE IS TESTIMONY BY PHONE.
YOU CAN CALL. 1-877-336-4441
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT FIVE ZERO SIX ZERO. AND
MODERATOR CAN YOU LET ME KNOW
HOW MANY ARE IN THE QUEUE RIGHT
NOW. GERMAN ON THE PHONE LINES
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO GIVE
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. YOUR TONE
INDICATED PLACING QUEUE THE
OPERATOR WILL THEN DECIDE YOU
NUMBER AND YOU'LL BE DENOUNCED
BY THAT NUMBER- AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND AT THIS TIME I AM
SEEN- NINE IN OUR QUEUE OKAY.
I'M. YES NINE SO THERE MAY BE
SOME MORE THAT AD BUT OF WHAT I
WOULD HOPE IS THAT I REALIZE
THAT WE HAVE. IF COVERED THE WE
HAVE NOT SPOKEN ABOUT A LOT OF
ITEMS SERGEANT IS QUITE. SO BUT
WHAT I WOULD ASK IS F YOU CAN
BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE AND I
WOULD HOLD. YOUR COMMENTS TO. I
WOULD LIKE TO HOLD A TWO ONE
MINUTE I'LL BE A LITTLE
FLEXIBLE ON THAT- BUT PLEASE
BE. AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE AND
MODERATOR GO AHEAD YOU CAN
PROVIDE OUR FIRST HOME. ALL
RIGHT THEN FIRST- WE WILL GO TO
LINE FORTY FORTY YEAR LOW AND
IS OPEN. YEAH YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU CHAIR SKINNER AND MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I NEVER
COME OUT ON A SERVICE THAT THE
TOURNEY AT THE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE WRITTEN REQUEST
SUBMITTED BY ARE NO PP IN
CALIFORNIA COALITION RELATED
THE CAL OPS PREVENTING BUT
EXTREMISM AND CREATE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES PROGRAMS. WE URGE
YOU TO DEFY THESE PROGRAMS AND
RICK YES OF IT. OUGHT COVERING
YES PROGRAMS ARE INTIMATELY
CONNECTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT A LONG HISTORY OF
POLICIES ARE HONEST. WHICH IS
THE PRICE. ARE COMMUNITIES
EXAMPLE THESE AND THE TRYING
WHO ACT INCARCERATIONS JAPANESE
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
AND THE NATIONAL SECURITY ENTRY
EXIT REGISTRATION SYSTEM AND
SHORTLYAFTER SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH BUT MEMBERS OF TARGET
COMMUNITIES WERE MARKED. FOR
INSURANCE SUSPICION AND
DISLOYALTY TO THE UNITED
STATES. DHL AND THEN THE- YES
PROGRAMS QUESTION ARE NO
DIFFERENT THEY MARCH FOR
SUSPICION ARE MUSLIM BLACK AND
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES FOR
SIMPLY BEING WHAT THEY ARE IF
THEY ATTEND MARK OR HOUSE OF
WORSHIP THEY ARE SEEN AS
THREATS IF THEY CRITICIZE
GOVERNMENT POLICY. THERE'S IN.
CD PROGRAMS ARE ANOTHER WAY FAR
GOVERNMENT TO DETERMINE WHO IS
IN. AND WHO IS OUT OF OUR
AMERICAN FABRIC WHILE
CRIMINALIZING OUR COMMUNITIES
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE IN A STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
THEREFORE ASKING YOU TO DE FUND
THESE- YES PROGRAMS AND
REQUIRED AGAIN BUT- YES SUBMIT
AN AUDIT OF THAT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION AND FOR
ALL. YOU ARE DOING FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I JUST LIKE TO. POINT FOR THE
MODERATOR. AND WE WILL MOVE
INTO PART BE AS SOON AS WE HEAR
THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON PART A
AND MY APOLOGIES THAT I.
CLARIFY THAT. SO RIGHT NOW WE
WILL BE HEARING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON PART A WHICH IS THE
ITEMS RELATED TO. BERMAN OF
CHEST EDC ARE. DID YOU. DSCC I
MAY HAVE MISSED ONE BUT- TO
AGENCY BUT ANYWAY IT'S THE BEST
AND THE- YES PART IS IN OUR-
VICTIMS COMPENSATION IN YES IS
IN PART BE SO WE WILL GET TO
THAT AFTER. THIS PUBLIC IN OUR
VOTE PARTE ARE A MODERATOR
REMAIN IN THE LINE. ALL RIGHT
AND- SO YOU KNOW OUR QUEUE IS
NOW UP TO FORTY. UP TO FORTY
SELDOM AND- LIKE A SAID TO
EVERYONE THIS IS THE PART HEY
WE WILL HOLDEN TO A MINUTE. GO
AHEAD OKAY THEN WE WILL GO TO
NUMBER FORTY FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. APOLOGIZE OUT FORTY ONE
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY HEARING NOTHING WILL MOVE
ON WILL GO TO LINE OF NINETY
SEVEN LINE SEVEN YOUR OTP. I'M
HERE FOR. ONLY ON THAT PART.
ALL RIGHT THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
WILL GO TO LINE FORTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LIFE IS OPEN.
I AM ALSO HERE FOR PARTY TO
AWAIT FOR THAT AS WELL. THE
PEOPLE IN LINE FOR PART B.
MIGHT WANT TO HANG UP BECAUSE
WE WON'T GET. IT TILL FOR GOOD.
THE WELL AT LEAST THIRTY FIVE
TO FORTY MINUTES. OF A COMMON
APART BE MIGHT BE AN HOUR FROM
NOW SO THOSE WHO WANT TO
COMMENT ON PART B. ONE HANG UP
THEN WE WILL GO TO NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SIX ONE TWENTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN. THANK YOU THAT SAME
ALSO HERE FOR PART B. SO I
MIGHT TAKE THE CENTERS OF ICE
THANKS SO MUCH. WE'VE GOT. WELL
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU DO HAVE ANY
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU HAVE COMMENTS ON PART A-
ONE ZERO. I WILL GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY NINE ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CLICK HERE
TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
AGENDA PARTY I'M I REALLY WOULD
APPRECIATE FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ONLINE FOR PART TO HANG UP
BECAUSE IT WILL ONLY TAKE US
THAT MUCH LONGER TO. PART BE.
WE ARE. RIGHT RIGHT NOW ON PART
A. BY THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE A
ONE FIVE EIGHT LINE ONE FIVE
EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. HI MANY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- MADAM
CHAIRPERSON AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHEN INSTRUCTING
BARBARA FOR SHORT HAUL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE. ASIAN CLINIC NOT. WE
SERVE THE STATE OF HEALTH LEAD
TO THE PUBLIC LEAVE. THE CIVIC
AND PROVIDING FUNDS FOR THE
CARE TO THE CRIMINAL JANET YOU
LOCAL HEALTH ISSUE. AND NEEDS
OF THOSE REGION TO THE TWO YEAR.
XIN COMIC IS BEING ADDED
SERVICE. IN THE STATE WE REDUCE
RECIDIVISM WE HELP WITH
REINTEGRATION AND WE ALLOW
PEOPLE TO MANAGE ALL. MOVE ON.
I HOPE FOR THE COMMITTEE WILL
CONSIDER THE PSC IS INVALUABLE
AND REPRESENTS A GREAT VALUE TO
THE STATE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH. GO AHEAD MODERATOR
NEXT WE'LL WE'LL MOVE TO LINE
ONE THIRTY THREE ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MINISTRATION
REINSTATE THAT MILLION DOLLARS
FOR INDIGENT. PILOT PROJECT I
NEED. MILLION AT E. B. FUNDS
SUPPORT PUBLIC DEFENDER
SERVICES CRITICAL TO ALL DEFINE
SIX AMENDMENT MY TO CAL AND THE
RESULT OF AN PHILLIES
SETTLEMENT IN THE CASE FOR
SHARK THE CULT. I WOULD ALSO
ASK THAT FOR A DIFFERENT
CONTENT YES NO WAY. FOR TO FIND
SOCIAL WORKER. IMPLEMENT I AM
AN OBJECT REFORM YOU'RE TRYING
TO REDUCE COSTLY INCARCERATION.
YEAH THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION RECONSIDER
THE THIRTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
CUT TO THE STC FOR THE ATTACK
REENTRY GRANT PROGRAMS AND YOU
KNOW THAT FUNDING IS CRITICAL
ESPECIALLY DURING THE CALL THAT
HE AND- SURE P. WE- STATE. ARE
PROVIDED THE SIR YOU'RE NEEDED
PRESS. REENTRY WE MATTER WILL
NATIONAL THEIR SIDE OPEN AND-
WE ASK THAT THE WHITE. OF THE
ABILITY TO PAY PILOT PROGRAM BE
STRENGTHENED BY OUR NATION'S
BREAKING DOWN PRIOR TO
ENROLLMENT AND PARTICIPATION OR
INCOME CALIFORNIA. ONE IS
PLAYING IN EXIST. PROGRAM WHERE
OPPOSED THE PROPOSED TO
ELIMINATION OF THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE EXISTING
DATA IS INADEQUATE TO DETERMINE
WHICH ASPECTS OF THE PILOTS ARE
EFFECTIVE. AND LEGISLATIVE OVER
THANK. YOU AND LASTLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ELIMINATION OF THE
EXPANSION BOX. GENERAL I DEEPER
BY CRITICAL AND FEEDING ARE
MADE FOR MORE IMPORTANT DURING
THIS UNPRECEDENTED HEALTH
CRISIS AND WE WOULD ASK THAT
THAT BE RECONSIDERED THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT. THANK. THE
NEXT WILL BE MOVING TO LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FORTY FOUR THE
CARD. FOR YOUR WIFE FOR NINETY
FIVE NINETY NINE ATTORNEY HAVE
HONOR TO SERVE THE TECH BEAT
THE RECORD THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
YOU THINK. THAT HOW MUCH OF
THAT BILL I FEEL COMPELLED TO
EXPRESS THAT I'M STRATEGY. IT
BY. I TOLD DOWN CALIFORNIA YOU
PRISON HOW I AND WE ARE HAPPY
AT THE PORT OF THE GOVERNOR
COULD NOT BE CLOSE FOUND. THERE
ARE THE- BOB. OUR THE PROFIT
ONE THE BALLOT THINKS IF WE
MODEL. IMPROVING LOCAL
OVERSIGHT AND NEW OVER THE FARM
WITHIN HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. ALL YOU COULD
MISS OFFENSE REPROBATE BODY OUT
OF DOING WITH THEIR **** OFF TO
GET AND THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
EIGHT FORTY. FROM ALL INSTRUCT
THE BORDERS BILL REQUIRE FOR
THE COUNTY. AND REPORTING
MATRIX THAT WHAT HAD BURKE
TRANSPARENCY AND PROPER DATA
COLLECTION AND THEN LASTLY
REGARDING THE TAX CREDIT. WE
MANY OF WHAT. PAPA SEVEN THE
POPULATION WITH THE COLLECTED.
ALL REGULATION. I HAVE. THEY'RE
APPROVED THAT APPLY ALL THE WAY
ACROSS IN A PARKING LOT BY THE
VENDOR THAT INCLUDE BALBOA.
LIFE IS THAT WE- SO ARE OF A
GRAPHIC ARE YOU THIRTY AND ARE
STILL IN THERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TIME IN YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WE WILL GO
TO NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY MY
NAME IS LANCE FERRIS I'M A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC AND I'VE BEEN SORT. OF
FOURTEEN YEAR. I WOULD LIKE
KATE BUT THE PAROLE L. IT
CONTINUE WE ARE THE FIRST LINE
OF SERVICE WHEN FOLKS ARE
GETTING OUT OF PRISON I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATED. HEARING
THE LARGE HURDLE OF FOLKS INTO
THE COMMUNITY COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH ALL. OF OUR HIGH RISK
AND VERY OFTEN VOLATILE
POPULATION- THE PANDEMIC IS
CHANGING AND CHALLENGING THE
COMMUNITY AND OUR PRESENT. AND
ALSO PUBLIC SAFETY AND FOR THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FIRST LINE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT TO
FOLKS GETTING OUT OF PRISON IN
THE PAROLE OFFICE FOR WITH HER
LIMIT THEIR TIME IT HAS PROVEN
ON AN ON. WE ARE THE BILL. AND
VERY OFTEN EVEN OUR FOLKS HAVE
MEDICARE ALL PUBLIC- MENTAL
HEALTH COMMITTEE MADE UP WILL
NOT SERVE OUR POPULATION- PO
SEE IS A BUFFER FOR PROVIDING
DIRECT MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT
CAN YOU SUPPORT PUBLIC SAFETY
THANK YOU SIR I'M- THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER ONE
TWENTY FOUR ONE TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MONEY LOS I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A OUR SEAT. OF THE
ART SEAT ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION- WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR CUT WITH A DAHLE READ
ENTRY GRANT. THE FCC THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR BALDNESS OPEN WE'RE
SERIOUSLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE
THAT WERE RELEASED. THOSE
SERVICES THAT ARE BEING
PROVIDED WITH A GROUP OF PEOPLE
ALONG WITH OTHERS THAT HAVE
BEEN TRANSIT. FROM OF. COURSE
BEING THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS LITERALLY THE
WHEAT IT TOOK TIME RELEASED.
ALONG WITH OTHER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS PLAYED AND- YOU
KNOW MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
THAT WERE BEING RELEASED WERE
PLACED IN HOUSING FOR SHAPING
UP THERE WAS NOT A TAKING.
FUNDING WILL YOU TAKE AWAY FROM
MANY OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING OURS
THE BETTER ON THE GROUND DOING
THE WORK TO MAKE SURE THE DISK
TRANSITION OF PEOPLE AND CARS
RATED AS SUCCESSFUL THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE GO TO LINE FIFTY ONLINE
FIFTY YOU'RE YOU'RE OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MANAGER MY NAME
IS BUT NOTHING YEAH I AM A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE CORRECTIONS
REPRESENTING PEROT OUTPATIENT
CLINIC ALSO KNOWN AS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH REINTEGRATION PROGRAM. I
AS WELL AS MANY OTHER SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE PULLED TO THE
CLOSURE OF OUR CLINIC AS IT'S
ALREADY BEEN SAID WE PROVIDE.
NOT ONLY FIRST LINE SERVICES
BUT WE PROVIDE SOMETHING VERY
SPECIFIC AND YU WANT THOSE
ONLY. BEEN INCARCERATED WE DO
NOT PROVIDE SERVICES TO ANY
HEALTH ISSUES MEDI CAL TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO ANY AND HOW
UBER. ARE THEY ABLE BY
FORENSICS THE X. I WENT. WITH A
SOCIAL WORKER FROM A PRISON IN
A LOT ANGELES COUNTY WITH THE
RELEASE PRE RELEASE COREY HER
POINT WAS OUR PARTICIPANTS HAD
A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
NAVIGATING SUCH SYSTEM BECAUSE
ARE. YOU SHOULD TO US AND WE
ARE FOR NATE. SPEAKING
ACCORDING WE HAVE A DIRECT LINE
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. PROBABLY
MYSELF WHO ARE H. AND WE-
WESLEY TOGETHER TO PROVIDE
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY UNIQUE
TO PEROXIDATION CLINIC WE ARE
NOT A DUPLICATION OF MEDI CAL
SERVICES REMEMBER THAT
PROVIDERS CAN POTENTIALLY
ABSORB THE PAROLEES IF WE WERE
TO CLOSE REMEMBER MANY OF OUR
PEOPLE ARE. MADE TO NINETY JEEP
MONITOR WHERE. MYERS PRESS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY BEEN TURNED
AWAY BECAUSE IT INAPPROPRIATE
OR VIOLENT BEHAVIORS AND OUR
RETURN BACK TO US FROM LOCAL
PROVIDERS BECAUSE THERE IS NO
LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE.
PLEASE BE SURE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT IF YOU CLOSE UP PLANET
YOU'LL BE CLOSING A VERY UNIQUE.
SERVICE THAT ONLY TO ONLY PRO
LEASE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO NUMBER
ONE SIXTEEN ONE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BUT ONE FIFTEEN
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON MUTE.
OKAY THE NEXT WE WILL GO TO
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE SEVENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVENTY
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU. OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON TO NUMBER
NINETEEN NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NUMBER NINETEEN. HELLO.
WHEN ANYTHING TO DRINK IN A
SESSION WITH PRO OUTPATIENT
CLINICS I JUST WANT THE SENATE
TO KNOW THAT PROVIDE CLINICS
NOW CALL BEHAVIOR HEALTH
NUTRITION PROGRAMS PROVIDE THE
ABILITY. SERVICES TO CARLY'S
EXTREMIST TRANSITION FROM
PRISON TO CALL AS WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DATABASES AND
INFORMATION THE PRISONERS. TO
HELP IDENTIFY. WITH BEHAVIOR
PROBLEMS. BUT DEPEND SAFETY.
AND GIVE US UP COLLABORATIVELY
WITH THE PRO. AND LONG TO
REDUCE IT TO THE PUBLIC.
FIFTEEN BUT NOT LEARNING FROM
PAST. THE HOUSE OUT A TOLL WILL
BE ABLE MR AND SOCIAL WORKS.
AND WE HAD A GREAT PRO. NOW IT
FIRST PLACE. WHEN PEOPLE CAME
OUT OF. HE VALLEY FEVER PRIVACY
CONNECTED TO HELP PROVIDER AND
NOW WE'RE TO DO THIS THING WITH
PEOPLE COME OUT BECAUSE IT
NINETEEN. SOME TALK ABOUT PEARL
MAKE IT UNLESS. IF YOU WANT TO
CRYING IN THE CURRENT. CLOSE
WORKERS FROM THE INCREASE. WE
SEE THEM AT SOON AS THEY'RE
RELEASED AND IF I. THIS QUITE
UNIQUE JUST TO HEALTH THE
INTEGRATION AND FROM A LOT TO
OF EX. ABLE TO AGENTS BABY I
HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON
PRODUCTS. I CAN BE ABILITY
SHOULD POORLY. THE MORE YOU
HAVE SOCIAL WORKERS WITH STREET
BASEMENT. HOLISTIC AND CULTURE
SENSITIVE APPROACH THE BETTER
CHANCE FOR THE THRONE IT
HAPPENED MAKING IT ON THE
STREET. IT HAS BEEN REDUCING A
DIFFERENT AND- WE WERE THE
WHOLE PERSON. I'M NOT AND MICRO
LEVEL. THE LAST PERSON YOU WANT
TO TAKE AWAY FOM THE PRISON
SYSTEM. IS AN ADVOCATE FOR
PAROLEES. WE HELP UNTIL IN
POWER TO HELP AND CHANGE OUR
LIVES. BUT REDUCING CRIME. AND
PROVIDING A SAFE COMMUNITY. FOR
OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WILL GO TO LINE ONE FORTY ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS RENEE MANNER WITH THE
CENTER ON JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE I AM HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO CLOSE THE STATE'S
DANGEROUS DECATUR CELANESE.
LAST MONTH I CO AUTHORED A
POLICY BRIEF THAT A LARGE ONE
IT SURE THAT THE JJ AND WHAT
STATE CLOSURE OF THE FACILITY
IN FAVOR OF CLOSE TO. TURN
AGAINST. MICHAEL YOU FORM THAT
AND CONTINUE TO EXPOSE YOU TO
HER. I THE STATE INVESTMENT A
UP SHOULD YOUR KNOW THAT THEIR
AND OUR FOCUS TO LOOK SYSTEM.
SHE FOR THE SUCCESS OF THE- I
ASK YOU CONSIDER MY- TO ENSURE
THAT THE SUCCESS. IN PARTICULAR
IT IS THAT WE INVITE CBO IN THE
TRUNK CROSS. DEVELOPED OF
REGIONAL MODELS. ALSO WE- IN
THE LOCAL OVERSIGHT WITH A NEW
OR APART IN THE HELL AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO ENSURE
COUNTY PARK ALONG THE LEDGES.
THE FOR YOUR. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE COMPLETE CLOSURE OF.
URGE YOU TO PASS UNDER PROPOSAL
WITH PROPER SAFEGUARDS TO. THE
TREND. THANK YOU. THEN THANK
YOU FOR KEEPING A ONE MINUTE.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER ONE
FIVE SIX ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DOCTOR PACHUCO I'M A
PSYCHOLOGIST THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL FACILITY. AND LISTENING
TO THE PRESENTATIONS TODAY I'M
SURPRISED THAT THESE DECISIONS
TO CLOSE. HEROES OR D. J. IS
BEING MADE WITHOUT POLICY
CONSIDERATIONS- IN MY COMMUNITY
SANTA ROSA AND THERE ARE NO.
ATTY SO THESE ONE OF THE THINGS-I KNOW ABOUT DJJ IS THAT THEY
ARE STRUGGLING WITH A VERY
DIFFICULT GROUP OF ADOLESCENCE-
AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO PLACE
THEM IN- CRISIS SALUTE.
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE BECAUSE
THEY WEAR OUT THEIR WELCOME
THEY ACT OUT THEY GET PREGNANT
ALL KINDS OF CREATIVE THINGS.
FOR P. C. D. I REFER A- PATIENT
PRESS GOES A- AND THE YOU KNOW
TRANSIT FROM. TO THE COMMUNITY
A CHALLENGE- THESE PEOPLE HAVE
A LOT OF. DIFFICULTIES HAVING A
FULL SERVICE NO HEALTH PROGRAM-
WITH PRO ALLEGIANCE IN THE
FACILITY I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
VALUABLE THAT IS- WHEN YOU
CONSIDER MENTAL HEALTH GRAHAM.
WHO HAVE. AS THE SWEET. SO I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL RECONSIDER
BUT CLOSING APPEAL THE AND DE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE NEXT
WILL GO TO NUMBER ONE NINETY
THREE ONE NINE THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AGAIN ONE NINE THREE
LINES OPEN. OVER THE NEXT TO A
MOVE TO A LINE OF THIRTY EIGHT
NINE THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHAIRMAN AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE MY NAME IS MARVIN
ALL THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR FOR
INTEGRATED SERVICES WILL
MENTALLY ILL PROLLY. CONSORTIUM
COMMITTEE SERVICES AND I. IT IS
SPEAK ABOUT THE END OF.
OPPOSING DELINEATION OF THE- IS
THE PROGRAM AND MISSION OF THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE
KIND OF CATASTROPHIC IMPACT ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. WE HAVE LEARNED
ABOUT HOW HIGH RISK INMATES AND
PAROLEES THAT INCLUDE BOTH
DRUGS VIOLENCE SEX OFFENDERS. I
WOULD SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESS
WHEN THEY'RE BEING RELEASED
FROM CUSTODY AND WITHOUT
ADEQUATE COMMITTEE SUPPORT TO
PROGRAMS TO MEET THEIR NEEDS
THESE GUYS ARE. OFTEN ON GPS
MONITORING AND THEY HAVE OF
THAT REALLY KNOWS SERVICES.
NOTING THIS PRO I WILL
ESSENTIALLY MEAN THAT- IRIS THE
STATE THAT LEVEL OF
CONCERN AND WE'LL PLACE UNDUE
BURDEN IN TWO AND- ON THE HOW.
WE ALSO HAVE LEARNED THAT THE
MEDI CAL SYSTEM THERE EITHER AN
UNDATED GROUP ARE ALSO THERE
AND EQUIPPED TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT CARE FOR RENT.
THEN OFTEN TRAINED LOOKS
POPULATION I WAS REALLY WILL
PROGRAM IS BLACK HOLE FOR THEM
WHERE WE ARE THE- MUCH. EIGHT
FOOD CLOTHING SHELTER BUT ALL
IDEA GRANTED THEM INTO THE CAN
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE BUDDY
BUT THERE PAROLE REQUIREMENTS
IN THE IN CONCERT WITH. HE AND
THE LADY IN IMPACT YOUR LAST
YEAR LOW WE ARE AT ABLE TO
TRANSITION 80% OF OUR CLIENTELE
IN TO PORTLAND INDEPENDENT
HOUSING SO I'LL PROGRAM WORKS
THAT. YOU CAN GET AWAY FROM
THEM WILL BE. IMPACT LOOKS AS
WELL THAT. WILL IMPACT THE CLUB.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FIVE BUT
NEXT WILL GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVENTY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN. ACTUALLY MY NAME IS
SIRIS RB THAT CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST AT DEPARTMENT OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE I'VE WORKED ON
AND SEX BEHAVIOR TREATMENT
PROGRAM FOR THE PAST. THREE AND
A HALF YEARS. AND I WANTED TO.
THE OUR PRO. PROVIDES A
CRITICAL SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AS
WELL AS THE REHABILITATION OF
CALIFORNIA USED. AS OUR YOU
HAVE COMMITTED SOME OF THE MOST.
VIOLENT AND DIFFICULT SEX
OFFENSES IN THE STATE. OUR
YOUTH ARE MANDATED TO TREATMENT
AND ARE OFTEN SENT TO US AFTER.
MULTIPLE OTHER PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTY OF THEIR ORIGIN. OUR
PROGRAM IS COME AND VISIT IN
THAT THE YOU PARTICIPATE IN
PROGRAMMING ACTIVITIES GROUPS
INDIVIDUAL AS WELL FAMILY
COUNSELING- THROUGHOUT THEDAY-
THROUGHOUT THE DAY OF THE WEEK-
IT'S INTENSE HOWEVER IT'S
HEALING AND THERAPEUTIC. THE
ENVIRONMENT IS FAST AND OPENED
GREEN WITH MANY OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO INCLUDING AT NO. AS
WELL AS WHERE AND SHE- AN ADOBE
ADOBE TO NAME A FEW. ARE YOU
DAHLE SO WE ALSO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM OVER ALL BUT
THE LITTLE REFER TO EIGHT SEX
OFFENDER PROGRAM WE HAVE A 4%
RATE AS WELL 37% OVERALL WHICH
IS WELL I. HELLO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE YOU COULD WRAP UP THE
S. YOU'VE BEEN OVER A MINUTE.
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDER.
THE NEXT WE WILL MOVE TO NUMBER
ONE NINETY FOUR ONE NINETY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. AGAIN ONE NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO. EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS WAIT ASK YOU AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY LEGAL SERVICES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COMMENTATING ON ISSUE ONE
EIGHTEEN. LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ABILITY TO
PAY PROCEDURES IN TRAFFIC
COURT. ADLAI SEEN MEASURE
RELIEF FOR OUR CLIENTS HOWEVER
WE'VE ALSO SEEN PROBLEMS WITH
THE ABILITY TO PAY PROCESS THAT
WE PASSED THE ADDRESS TO MAKE
MENTIONED THE PIE. FOR OFFICE
IT A LETTER TO THIS DETAILING
PER CHANGES IN ORDER FOR TO
THOSE WRITTEN COMMENTS FOR
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS. I
JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY EXPLAIN
THEIR NEED. WE'VE SEEN WIDELY
DIFFERING PRACTICES FROM COURT
TO COURT AND WHO TO FIND
ELIGIBLE FOR REDUCTIONS THE
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION REQUIRED
TO PROVE AND AGENCY. THE TYPE
AND EXTENT OF RELIEF OFFERED
AND WHETHER TO CLEAR THE
FAILURE TO UP KEEP LICENSE
SUSPENSION UPON RECEIPT THE
BILL TO PAY LOCATION EMPLOYEE.
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION
ADDRESSES SOME BUT NOT ALL OF
THESE INCONSISTENCIES. EACH ONE
MATTER HOW ONLY SMALL EXCLUDE
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS FROM
THE- YOU NEED BY THE COMMITTEE
THE GOVERNOR. PLEASE READ WE
ARE THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO IN. ARE
RECOMMENDED SMALL TWEAKS TO THE
EXPANSION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WILL BE MONITORING THE TIME
CLOSELY COAKLEY'S SAYS STICK TO
YOUR TIME YOU DID THAT CALL
CLICK FUTURE SPEAKERS THANK YOU.
NEXT YOU'LL MOVE TO LINE TO
THIRTEEN- A LINE TO THIRTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. BEEN TO THIRTEEN
IS A SURE NOT ON MUTE. THE NEXT
TO MOVED NUMBER. ONE FORTY SIX
TO ONE FORTY SIX. HI YES MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MICHAEL WINDOWS ON
ON THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF CUT
IT HE- WANTED TO LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON WORKS ONE FOR
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND ARE
NOW LIVING WATER COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS SPONSORING
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO THREE FOUR
TWO NINE. THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMERCE DROWNED COLA FORMED.
AND WE RESPECT ASK THAT WE BE
INCLUDED AS A RESOURCE AND- ARE
TO. HELP YOU TO CONTINUE. FOR
OF PRO. IF YOU'RE- THANK YOU.
NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO NUMBER ONE
OH FOR- ONE FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. WE CAN
HEAR YOU THE GUN. YES OKAY
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CYNTHIA
WILL GO AND THE JUVENILE
DEFENSE PANEL ATTORNEY YOU
SHOULD RIVERSIDE COUNTY FIND A
COMEDY ON ISSUE ONE SHIFT
IDEOLOGY PRESIDENT AT HOW
ECONOMIC AND FINANCIAL DIRECT
CALIFORNIA EXAM. A BIRD. THE
BALANCE. ONE CERTAIN AND THAT
IS CHIU CONTINUE FACE OF THE
EARTH RISK AND BOTH OLD AND NEW
ESPECIALLY WITHOUT TEACHER DOC
AND OTHER MAN ORDERS HAVE YOU
THE SAME OF THE- WE'RE- UNDER
pSERVICES PROVIDED AT NO COST TO
THOSE IN NEED. IN THE CONTRACT
THE GIMMICK THEN YOU NEED FOR
THESE FREE SERVICES WILL BE
ONLY MORE EFFECTIVE AND DAMAGE
WILL BE AFFECTING THE
POPULATION NEXT FISCAL YEAR. WE
ARE I ASKED THE COMMITTEE CAN
OR NOT PHONE TO TRY FOR
REDUCTION AND RECORD. THESE
CHILDREN DO AND UP BECOMING
PRETTY GOOD RAPPER THE ADULT
THE COVER ENTRY. THANK YOU. I'M
I'M GONNA HAVE TO BE REDUCING
TIME JUST BECAUSE OF THE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE REMAINING. ON I WILL
ANNOUNCE THAT IN A MOMENT BUT
IF- THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
REMAINING PLEASE MAKE YOUR
COMMENTS AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE.
I'M IN MODERATOR GO AHEAD. THE
NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TEN
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT NEXT WILL GO TO NUMBER ONE
ZERO EIGHT. ONE ZERO EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. DOUG MY NAME'S
BUMPER JUST WANT TO GIVE A
COMMUNITY PERSPECTIVE MY
INDIVIDUAL EXPERIENCE I'VE BEEN
THROUGH OF. ALL FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS COME ALIVE TOGETHER
NOW RECIPIENT OF THE OPEN ENTRY
PROGRAM THROUGH THE BE A FEW
KEY AND I JUST WANT TO GIVE A
HARPY OF THE COMMUNITY. THE
PART. AND THERE'S RESOURCE FOR
THEM THERE. SO ARE WE WORK IN
THE CENTRAL REGION AND THERE'S
A LOT OF A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CALL NONVIOLENCE RESTORATION OF
NOT HAVING EMPLOYMENT SO WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE A
RESOURCE FOR THE COMMUNITY AND
BE THERE WITH THEM WITH ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
BUT NEXT WILL BE GOING TO
NUMBER ONE FIVE ONE- ONE FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN
YOUR LINES OPEN PLEASE MAKE
SURE NOT I'M YOU. WILL MOVE ON
TO DO IT NUMBER. ONE FORTY NINE
ONE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FOUR NINE YOUR LINES
OPEN. I AM HERE TO. YET THE
AGENDA. NOT NOW. MODERATOR NEXT.
THE NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY SIX LINE TWENTY SIX YOUR
OPEN. I'M NOT SURE IF ONLINE
TWENTY SIX HELLO. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. OKAY WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS MY
THOUGHTS I'M DOCTOR PETERSON OF
THE STEPS TO CUT JUST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT APPROVAL THE WORKING
HERE FOR SIX YEARS AND IN THE
PRESENCE OF. I'M OPPOSED
ELIMINATION OF THE CROW ALL
CHRISTIAN CLINICS AND- SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR THE CDC ARE. I
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A GOOD
REASON THE P. O. C. WAS CREATED
BACK IN THE FIFTIES. NOW WITH
THE SERVICE I READ. POLICE WHO
MOST OF THAT STUFF PROPONENTS
PERCENT THE MENTAL ILLNESS HE
DID INDIVIDUALS- CAREFUL AND
CLOSELY SUPERVISED TRANSITION
INTO THE COMMUNITY TO HELP US
REDUCE RECIDIVISM RATE MAINTAIN
THEIR MENTAL BUT HELP KEEP OUR
CITIZENS SAFE FROM THEM AS WELL
THE CARD. SO TROUT. WORK WITH
THE HIGHLY TRY. MANY OF BROKEN
BRIDGE STATE HOSPITAL AND SENT.
ONLY WITH THEIR NEEDS. ONLY
COME OUT OF THE DAY AND PRISON
HOUSE COMPLICATED DIFFICULT YOU
NEED WRAP ACTION RIGHT. THANK
YOU NEXT WE GO TO- NUMBER
TWENTY THREE NUMBER TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AGAIN
TWENTY THREE COMPETITION OUT ON
YOU. I'LL MOVE ON TO NUMBER ONE
ZERO ONE ONE ZERO ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIGURE ONE ZERO ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVE ON TO
LINE ONE FORTY THREE ONE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS ARE ROGER STONE I'M A
CLINICAL SOCIAL CRITICAL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC. HOUSE CALLS
OF COURSE MY OPPOSITION TO
ELIMINATION OUTPATIENT CLINIC.
MANY MORE CALL HAVE ALREADY
MENTIONED NOT ONLY. OUR UNIQUE
SERVICE ALSO LIMIT LONG WAIT
TIMES FOR OUR POLICE TO BE SEEN
BY OUR PROVIDER. ALSO A LOCAL
ONE STOP SHOP IN THIS IS THAT
THEY CAN SEE THE CORRELATION.
AS WELL AS WE SEE THEM IN THE
WHOLE TRIP IN THE SAME PLACE.
FOR A LOT OF OUR INDIVIDUAL.
YOU HAVE THAT ACCEPTABLE IN THE
SAME BUILDING IT WILL BE OUR
SPECIAL TO THEM. ALL YOUR MUSIC
WITH A MENTAL WILL ALSO HELP
THOSE WHITE PERSON BEEN DOWN.
FOR TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS OR
MORE. THIS BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY. EVEN MAY NOT SHOW BE
COVERED FOR MEDI CAL ARE NOT
COUNTY MEDICAL BUT NOT BE ABLE
TO SEE MEANWHILE SERVICES FOR
ADJUSTMENT. ARE YOU SUPPORT
JEFF BACK INTO THE CAN SO I
JUST WHAT IN WHAT YOU TO
REQUEST THE- OF THE CALL.
CLINIC THANK YOU INCLUDED LAKES
RIVERS. NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO LINE.
ONE SORRY ONE FORTY THREE ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIS ONE FORTY THREE. BUT AS WE
WILL MOVE TO LINE ONE NINETY
TWO OR NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AND.
WILL MOVE TO LINE OF ONE FORTY
NINE. ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BE JUST A MOMENT.
BUDGET
AS THE DELIVERY JUST MOMENT
HERE. ALL. ONE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN AND MY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO. HELLO
HELLO YES YOUR HONOR THE NEW TO
YOUR- YOU THE DEVICE YOU WERE
HEARING THE LISTENING TO THE
HEARING. THANK YOU THE DEVICE
WITH WHICH YOU WERE LISTENING
TO THE HEARING. OKAY WHAT
NUMBER NINETEEN OUT IT'S OKAY
JUST BEGIN PLEASE IF YOU'RE
SPEAKING APART A PLEASE BEGIN.
IT'S MY TURN YES PLEASE BEGIN
PART A YOU HAVE A- FORTY FIVE
SECONDS WELL HELLO MY NAME IS
AMY AND I'M A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER. WE'RE ALL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC IN GRAND NINE
LOS ANGELES. I HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR. IN CLINIC FOR THE
LAST NINETEEN YEAR. A TRUCK WE
CLOSING OUR PROGRAM IS
RESPONSIBLE IN MY MIND ON WILL
HAVE AN ADVERSE EFFECT ON THE
COMMUNITY HE- CLIENTS INTO THE
COALITION TO SUPERVISE
PROBABLY. WOULDN'T THE GOVERNOR
NEWLY REVISED. HUNDRED THAT
PROBABLY NOW WE SEE MEDICAL
BENEFITS. WE ARE JUST LOOK OF
THE SERVICE WITH THE COUNTY WE
ARE NOT AT THE OF. WE ARE
SPECIALIZED RUN LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH. TREAT NOT COLLEAGUES
WERE RELIEF COMPLETE CREEK AND
CONTINENTAL NEEDS. I ALSO. WANT
ONE IDENTITY. AFTER AB ONE ON
THE PAY WE CAN WRAP UP NOW.
KING LET RESPECT LIKE WE
STRUGGLE CONSIDER. IF YOU TO
RECONSIDER CLOSING CLINIC THANK
YOU FROM THIS POINT ON EVERY
WHO'S INTO OF THE PAROLE
PATIENT CLINICS YOUR NAY AND
THAT YOU SUPPORT IS ALL I WILL
TAKE ENTERED SO. IF YOU ARE.
WATER CALLS YOU OUR IN TO
SUPPORT THE PRO OUTPATIENT JUST
SAY YOU SUPPORT RETAINING THE
PRO OUT PATIENT AND WE WILL
pTHEN GO TO THE NEXT SPEAKER.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD MODERATOR. I
NEXT THERE'S FROM LINE ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE. ZERO ONE FORTY THREE YOU
ARE OPEN. I'LL MOVE ON WILL GO
TO LINE NINETY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
NINETY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN. WELL
IN TWO LINES ONE TWENTY TWO ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY ONE TO HIS GOOD NATURED ON A
MUTANT THIS THROWAWAY. WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE AT TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE RESPONSE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY. WELL ONE ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE SEVENTY YOU ARE OPEN. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI MY NAME IS
SARAH I AM A LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER AND I SUPPORT THE
PRO OUTPATIENT CLINIC THANK YOU.
BUT NEXT WILL GO TO LINE. ONE
SEVENTY TWO ONE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY ONE SEVEN
TWO PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT A MUTE.
MOVE ON TO LINE FORTY ONE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M FORTY
WAS A SURE NOT I'M YOU. MOVE ON
TO LINE UP ONE NINETY EIGHT ONE
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MADAM CHAIR CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED TRIGGER REDUCTIONS IN
THE JUDICIAL COUNCILS LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE- BLACKS.
EACH OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE WILL
INCOME INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE THE
MOST DIFFICULTY GETTING INTO
THE COURTS RIGHT NOW AND ON
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REALIGNMENT PROPOSAL
WE'D LIKE TO SEE MORE DETAIL
ABOUT PROPOSAL BUT WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORTS CLOSURE. OF THE DJ
CELERY SELL ARE MALE FLOCK IN.
THE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR AND WE
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH. ELSE
PROMISE THAT THERE COULD BE ON
OVERSIGHT AND- OF THE- TO THAT
WE ALL LIVE A PROPOSAL YOU.
THANK YOU MOVED TO WELL ONE TWO
A ONE YOU ARE OPEN. SURE MEMBER
TELLING HER THE LAN WHAT THE
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA I DEFINITELY SUPPORT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
TO CALL THE DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE WITH STARTLING
BELIEVE. WHAT HE SAID SPECIAL
RATE SO YOU I NEED A DAY
IMPORTS NOT DELIVERED ON THE
VISION BELIEVE THAT MICHAEL THE-
WE CAN TRANSITION TO
ALTERNATIVE MODELS THAT ARE
THAT MORE. REFLECT OUR IDEALS
THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO LOOKING
AT MORE DETAILS AND ASKING MEN
THANK. YOU. BY NEXT YEAR THE
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY FOUR ONE
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOTTOM SHE IS AS LONG AS AN ON
THE STATE POLICY FOR CUTS
FIFTY- OUT MY COLLEAGUES STATED
EARLIER WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
FOR ALL THE FORM FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS- AND MORE
COSPONSOR THE BILL AB TWENTY
TWENTY TO FORTY TWO WHICH
FUNDAMENTALLY SHIPS PAROLE FROM
A PUNITIVE SAYS. GEN YOU CAN.
IN ANOTHER ACHIEVEMENTS I'M WE
JUST WANT TO THANK OUR OF THE
RESOURCE I AM IN HOPES THAT
YOU'RE BORN CAUSE FOR THE BOYS
WHO TO THE BY TO THE TABLE
AGAIN DISCUSSIONS GOING TO IN
ADDITION WE WANT TO ENSURE THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
ADEQUATE FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THOSE REENTERING BACK INTO
SOCIETY- BECAUSE WHEN YOU
STRIP. OF ARSON OF SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES YOU'RE ESSENTIALLY
STRIP IN NUMBER OF A REAL
SECOND CHANCE THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP I'M WE DO.
THANK YOU. I'M GONNA DONE HOLD
ALL REMAINING TO THIRTY SECONDS
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO LOSE
THE LINE AND WE STILL HAVE TO
DO PART B. AND WE WANT THE PART
B. PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
SO- I WILL BE. PART NEXT A
READER- NEXT WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS OCTOR A
I'M A SENIOR PSYCHOLOGIST
ESPECIALES WITH OVER EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE IF THIS
IS IN SUPPORT OF THE CORAL. SEA
IF THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF A
SORRY CHAINING IF THIS IS IN
SUPPORT OF RETAINING THOSE
CLINICS JUST SAY YOU SUPPORT
RETAINING. THANK YOU. HI SO I
CERTAINLY SUPPORT RETAINING QC
SERVICES DURING TO YOU YOU NEED
THAT'S ENOUGH REFORM AND YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT MODERATOR. A
NECK SO GO TO NUMBER TWO THIRTY
TO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS APRIL GRAYSON STATEWIDE
COORDINATOR WHICH IS JUST A
WORKING COALITION AND I WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION EARLY YOUR LAND.
SENATOR BILL MADE MENTION OF
NOT TRANSFERRED WITHIN THE
INSTITUTION I'M LIKE THINKING
THAT YOU ASK THE GONNA OPEN UP
IN TAKEN AT THE SEVENTY AND I'M
SORRY ABOUT ALL AN IMPACT
COLGATE. AS WELL AS BUDGET
PUBLIC STATE AS A ALREADY
FEMALE INSTITUTION. A HUNDRED
THE COLD A- PLEASE WAIT. TALK
ABOUT THAT ARE TO TALK ABOUT
THAT. PEOPLE HELP AND SAFETY IS
THAT RISK IF YOU COULD AT.
THANKS THANK YOU. BUT NEXT
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT TWO ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES SHARE SKINNER THIS
IS DANTE DIMARTINO FROM-
CALIFORNIA'S BREATHTAKING JACK
THERE. REALLY QUICKLY I WANT TO
SAY WE OPPOSE THE CUTS TO THEIR
ADULT REENTRY GRANT PROPOSAL WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO CLOSE
THE GATE DO YOU. MAY ALL WANT
TO SHARE THAT WITH WE ARE
WORKING ALONG TRY KERR FIFTY ON
THE POOL ONE. AND LOOK YOU AND
GIVE WHAT YOU'RE ALL ON THAT
AND BY. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
CENTER SKINNER WAITING THE
ISSUE OF FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
CORONA VIRUS EMERGENCY
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING GETTING
WITH YOUR OFFICE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. THE NEXT YEAR
THE NUMBER TWO THIRTY THREE TO
THIRTY THREE PLEASE A. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON THE ITEMS MY NAME
IS KYLE MONTHLY ON CHRISTY WITH
COMMUNITY WORKS I'M HERE TO YOU
CAN OPT IN TO THE PROPOSED.
REDUCTION CUT. OF MILLION SEAT
BELT REENTRY RANCH THIS GRANT
THAT YOU KNOW PROVIDES SUPPORT
FOR RE ENTRY SERVICES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE AND THAT
THOSE TYPES OF RE INTEREST.
SURVIVAL NEEDS AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS THAT THIS KIND OF
KIND OF THE KIND OF THING THAT
IMPACTS NOT ONLY THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE COMING HOME BUT ALSO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING HOME TO.
SERVE UP NEEDS BUT THERE ARE
MANY HOUSING- IT. THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. WORK HOME
AND AFFECT. INOPPORTUNE
BATTERIES. THE ARE THINGS THAT
AREN'T. BY LIKE BEST I ALSO
WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
CLOSURE OF THE REMAINING DJJ
FACILITIES. IT'S STILL THESE
AND- HAVE SHOWN THAT. THE FACT
AND BE ABLE TO CARE. AND HELP
REHABILITATE AND AVOID RE
TRAUMATIZING YOUNG PEOPLE AND
IT'S BEEN DEMONSTRATED NOT ONLY
TO RESEARCH BUT ALSO THROUGH
THE TESTIMONY OF TRAUMA HARM
THAT YOU PER DAY AND OTHER
PLACES BY PEOPLE WHO. SPEND
TIME THERE. THE NEXT TO MOVE
THE NUMBER ONE NINETY TWO ONE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
SKINNER COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS THE KIND OF THE PLAYER
AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF THE
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN
AND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE WHO
REPRESENT IN LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
MAINTAIN CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS
FOR STABLE. THE COUNCIL BUT
LIMITED ACT WITH THE COURTS A
GROWING BACKLOG OF CASES AND AN
UNEXPECTED INCREASE. YOUR CARE
POPULATION. THE OTHER BECAUSE
THE ADVOCATE THE NEEDS OF OUR
YEAH AND ARE. OUT THAT. THANK.
TO NUMBER TWO FIFTY TO FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD
COUNTY- BUT THE RURAL COUNTY
ASSOCIATION AS WELL WE JOINED
IN A JOINT COUNTY COALITION
LETTER THAT RELATES TO THE-
CLOSURE OF THE DIVISION YOU
DON'T JUST KIND OF TIME IS
LIMITED. I THOUGHT WE WOULD
JUST URGE AND SET. BACK THE IS
A VERY COMPLEX PROPOSAL AT WAS
AT BY YOUR DIGGING INTO SOME OF
THE VERY SENSITIVE ISSUES
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS WE HAVE A
VERY COMPRESSED TIMEFRAME. AND
WE- HAPPENED A NUMBER OF ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO SORT THROUGH TO
ENSURE THAT WE DO RIGHT BY- THE
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR INITIAL
RESPONSES WE NEED TO OPPOSE
THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE IT. IS
NOT CONSISTENT VERY CLEAR.
REQUIREMENTS IN OUR OWN POLICY
PLATFORMS THAT THAT REQUIRE A
PROTECTION IN THE CONTEXT OF A
REALIGNMENT CERTAINLY SOMETHING
OF THIS SIZE AND SCOPE. COULD
WRAP AND LASTLY I JUST WANTED
TO MENTION. A TO MENTION AS
WELL AS RELATES TO THE ABILITY
TO PAPER ALTHOUGH I WE JUST
WANT TO. IDENTIFY CONCERNED
THAT PROPOSAL ONLY CONTAINS A
BACK FILLED FOR COURTS AND WE
WOULD IDENTIFY SIMILAR SIZE BY.
I HAD TO FIGHT THAT ISSUE THANK
YOU MUCH. BUT NEXT TO GO TO
NUMBER TWO FORTY FIVE TO FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MORNING WASHBURN WITH
THE CENTER ON JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE. WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO CLOSE
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE DJJ- THE INSTITUTION
SUBJECT YOU Q. APPALLING RATE
OF VIOLENCE. AND LEAVE THEM
MORE TRAUMATIZED AND MORE
DISCONNECTED FROM THEIR SUPPORT
SYSTEMS. AND BY ORGANIZATION
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE YEARS
ARE AT THE STATEMENT THAT
CURRENT PROPOSAL TO FULLY
REALIGN. WE NOW IS THE- ACT
WITH YOU. OUR GLOBAL AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENT OF. A
SMALLER IN SIZE POPULAR OF THE
I THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WAS
JUST INFORMED THAT THERE'D BEEN
MANY MORE COLORS TO JOIN THE
LINE WE ARE ONLY SPEAKING ON
PART A WE STILL HAVE TO DO
PARTY WE HAVE A LIMIT ON THE
PHONE LINE SO AT THIS POINT NOW
I NEED TO ASK EVERYONE
REMAINING TO JUST YOUR NAME.
SAY WHAT SUPPORT THAT'S ALL WE
CAN DO. PLEASE PROCEED IN ORDER
TO GO TO NUMBER. TWO FIVE FOUR
TWO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I AM FRANKLIN ROBSON ON AND I
SUPPORT VEHICLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC- THE COUNTIES THAT'S
ENOUGH THANK YOU STRUCTURE TO
THANK YOU NEXT. THE NEXT YEAR
THE NUMBER TWO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE CURRENT
ARMAND HAD LOOKING FOR DISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE WE
SUPPORT RESTORING THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FUNDING FOR
INDIGENT DEFENSE THE PROPOSED
CLOSURE AND AJ. BECAUSE OF THE
REFORM CRAWL AND WE OPPOSE THE
BECAUSE AT THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL THANK YOU. SO
MUCH. THE NEXT TO A NUMBER TWO
SIR TWO PLEASE GO. MARCO GEORGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION-
WE ASKED FOR YOU TO RESTORE THE
TEN MILLION FOR LOCAL PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. KEEP BASIC DEFENSE
DOWNEY ALSO WE ASK FOR YOU TO
FIND ON THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
TO IMPLEMENT JUSTICE REFORMS AS
A CRUCIAL WAY TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF KOBE A DIET TEAM IN
JAIL PRESENTS AN IMMIGRATION.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH. THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT YEAR NUMBER TWO SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CUT TO SIXTY
LINES OPEN. THE NEXT WILL GO TO
LINE TWO FORTY NINE TO FORTY
NINE YEAR LINES OF. TO RAIL TO
CITY JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER
WE SUPPORT THE DJJ CLOSER
CLOSER PROPOSAL THAT ONLY IF IT
BUILDS AN IMMEDIATE PROTECTION
TO PROTECT AGAINST INCREASED
TRANSFER TO ADULT COURT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT
YEAR THE NUMBER TWO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JIM
LINDBERGH FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA- WE
SUPPORT THE CLOSURE OF DJJ WITH
A STRONG STATE OVER WE OPPOSED
TO THE THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR CUT TO- THE ADULT
REENTRY GRANTS FOR COMMUNITY
BASED. ORGANIZATIONS AND WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE. FORMS COROLLA
PAROLE I'M SMALL SCROLL TERM TO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A NEXT
YEAR NUMBER TWO FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LOUISE
CAMINO ON SOCIAL WORKER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FULL AND I
SUPPORT THE ROLL OUT PATIENT
CLINIC. THE NEXT YEAR THE
NUMBER SIXTY THREE SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A BOTTLE OF.
SOCIAL WORKER VICTORVILLE I
MEAN OPPOSITION CLOSING OUR
PROGRAM PEOPLE SEE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. A NEXUS NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LOOK AT THE TYPE POSITION YOU.
I'LL MOVE ON TO NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
TOM ROBBINS OUR AND-
REPRESENTING THE ACTORS GANG
WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR THE LAST
FOURTEEN YEARS IN STATE
PRISONS. WRITING YOUR BILL. IS
OUR PROGRAMS REDUCE RECIDIVISM
WE HAVE 85% REDUCTION IN ONE
FIFTEEN JIM PRISON VIOLENCE. WE
ALSO RUN. REENTRY PROGRAMS IN
THIS. REENTRY 7% EMPLOYMENT WE
FEEL THAT CUTTING THIS PROGRAM
WOULD BE CATASTROPHIC TO PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU THE NUMBER
SEVENTY NINE. SEVEN NINE GO
HEAD. THIS IS SERRA THOMAS WILL
QUALITY FAMILY SERVICES AND I'M
IN OPPOSITION TO LYING SEVENTY
FIVE ELIMINATION OF THIS IS
MEANT PROGRAM. NEXT WE WILL
MOVE TO NUMBER TWO EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MORE
YOU COULD CHECK A WITH THE
JUVENILE COMMITTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT OF
FAITH AND CULTURE OF DJJ IN
ORDER TO PROTECT AGAINST MORE
YOUTH BEING TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER ONE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MONEY
VOLUMES BLOODY I REALLY-
TEACHERS TO SUBMIT YOUR YOUTH
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY WILSHIRE
DJJ. AND. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THE GENERAL DID NOT
RECEIVE THE SAME. THE VISION
AND THE COUNTY THAT WHEN WE DO
IN OUR STATE FACILITIES WE TRY
TO GET THEM. ANYTHING THAT.
THEN LET ME KNOW AND- BUT LIKE
FOR THE END UP THE- END OF. WE
NEED MORE IN THE LONG RUN IN
PART FOR YOU- BECAUSE YOU WALK
YOUR SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BUT NEXT YEAR THE NUMBER
TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IN ORDER HI MY NAME IS NATALIE
O'BRIEN FROM ST LOUIS AND I'M
IN OPPOSED TO THE ELIMINATION
OF BOC YOU NEED TO KEEP OUR
CITY MANAGER. THANK YOU. SIX
ZERO THE NUMBER TWO SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I TOLD ME
CULTURAL DEPENDS ON CALIFORNIA
HAS THE SUPPORT YOU GET CLOSURE
WITH STRONG STATE OVERSIGHT
ENTIRELY THREE D. HHS THAT'D BE
IT. THANK YOU. ZERO TWO NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE THIS IS A.
SUBDIVIDED LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEXT WHERE THE LINE TO EIGHTY
FIVE TO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DOCTOR
LAURA HERNANDEZ AND I'M WITH
PSC AND MY COLLEAGUES OF
ELOQUENTLY EXPRESSED SUPPORT OF
PST SO MY COMMENTS WILL FOCUS
ON A POLLUTING THE ELIMINATION
OF THE INTEGRATED SERVICES OF
MENTALLY ILL CROLY PROGRAM. IS
MATT. FIVE WORKED HER HE IS THE
FOR OVER FIFTEEN YEARS AND IT'S
NOT HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUSLY
WELCOME PROGRAM FOR OUR COOLEY
POPULATION. THE GOAL COUNTY AND
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS HAVE ALWAYS
USED TO THE CRIMINAL HISTORY.
VIOLENCE POTENTIAL SEX
OFFENDING BEHAVIOR AS REASONS
TO REJECT OUR CURLY'S. WHEREAS
IF MATT HAS STAFFING WHO ARE
SPECIALLY TRAINED. AND FOCUS
SPECIFICALLY AND EFFECTIVELY ON
THE CRIMINAL JANET NEEDS OF THE
CURLY POPULATION MORE THAN ANY-
GENERIC CAN MANY CURRENT
COMMUNITY PROGRAM CAN. SO I ASK
YOU TO OPPOSE ELIMINATING THE
EXTENT PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I'M I'VE JUST BEEN
ALERTED THAT WE WILL HAVE WE
CANNOT EXTEND THE LINE. SO AT
THIS POINT I CAN ONLY TAKE YOUR
NAME. YOUR FOLIATION AND WHAT
YOU SUPPORTER POST SOMETHING AT
THE AND OTHERWISE AT THAT IS
ALL WE CAN TAKE RIGHT NOW IN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT SO PLEASE
PROCEED. AND WE HAVE TO WRAP
THIS UP. DURING THE NEXT- WE GO
TO NUMBER TWO EIGHTY EIGHT TO
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL. PHONE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. THE NEXT WILL GO TO
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY NINE TO
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS VICTORIA LARGE SOME
OF THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS IN THE CAMPUS
AREA. I'M COMMENTING ON ITEM
ONE EIGHTEEN THE COURT BUT G.
TO- IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES
OUTLINED A LETTER SENT BY
DIFFERENT LEGAL ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU. NANCY
BUT AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. GREAT I
APPRECIATE THAT I APOLOGIZE
THAT WE HAVE TO DO IT THIS WAY
BUT WE ARE ONLY ALLOWED TO HAVE
THE PHONE FOR CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME. THIS ENTIRE- HIGH I WOULD
THINK THE STAFF FOR THEIR
INCREDIBLE WORK BUT I DO HAVE A
HARD TIME DEFENDING THAT IS NOT
A REFLECTION ANYONE IN THE
STAFF THAT WE WOULD BE PUT IN
THE POSITION OF HAVING TO HEAR.
THE ENTIRE ME REVISE ANY
SINGLE- HEARING BUT THAT IS THE
SITUATION WE'RE IN AND IN A
LIMITED TIME SO WITH THAT I AM
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO- WHAT OUR-
POSSIBLE- VOTES COULD BE. TIME
FOR AS A BLOCK CAN I BELIEVE
YOU ALL HAVE THIS IS A NO SO
MAYBE WE COULD PROVIDE TO- MY
COLLEAGUE SO TAKEN UP FOLLOW
THIS EASIER. THURMOND THERE WE.
I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
APPROVE. FILE ITEMS. ONE THREE
THIRTEEN THE ONES I'M ABOUT TO
LIST OR NOT CHANGED IN THE- IN
THE- RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
LIST SHOULD BE APPROVING ISSUES.
1-313-153-3640 THREE FIFTY
THREE ITEM. FIFTY FIVE FIFTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE SIXTY TWO
THREE SIXTY FIVE SIXTY SEVEN
THREE SIXTY SEVENTY.
SEVENTY TWO THREE SEVENTY NINE
EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FIVE THROUGH. EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY THREE ONE HUNDRED. ONE
OH TWO TO ONE TEN. ONE FOURTEEN
ONE SIXTEEN ONE EIGHTEEN AND
ONE TWENTY AND THOSE WERE ALL
IN THE AGENDA FROM START AS
APPROVED AS BUDGETED. THE STAFF
MAYBE IT WOULD BE EASIER
BECAUSE THAT WAY IF THERE WAS A
MEMBER WHO WANTED TO VOTE
DIFFERENTLY THEY- WOULD HAVE
IT. HEREOKAY GO AHEAD. COULD I
BE RECORDED AS A NO VOTE ON THE
FOLLOWING WOULD THAT BE SIMPLE
ENOUGH THAT COULD BE A THINK
YES GO AHEAD NUMBER FORTY THREE
OKAY. NUMBER FORTY ONE NUMBER
FORTY THREE. FORTY FIVE FORTY
SIX. FORTY NINE THIS. FIFTY SIX
A FIFTY SIX WERE NOT ACTING ON
RIGHT NOW THANK YOU THAT'S A
HOLDOVER ACOSTA SCHOOL YOU
DON'T WORRY. SIXTY TWO. OKAY
SIXTY THREE. K. SIXTY FOUR K.
SIXTY FIVE. SIXTY SIX. JERRY A
SIXTY SIX WERE NOT THAT'S HOLD
OPEN. THE COLLEGE LIES OKAY
OKAY- SEVENTY EIGHT. THREE
EIGHTY EIGHTY IS A HOLD OPEN
THANK YOU. AB ONE QUE. EIGHTY
FOR EIGHTY FOUR IS A. EIGHTY
FOUR IS A REJECT THREE NINETY
TO VOTE NO YEAH ARM ARMOR
OPPOSED TO YOUR REJECTION OKAY
SO WE DO VOTING ON THAT
SEPARATELY SO JUST SO WE'RE
EIGHTY ONE RUNNING THEGOVERNOR
AND NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR NO
WORRIES WE'LL GET TO THAT. SO
NUMBER NINETY ONE. OKAY NUMBER
NINETY TWO OKAY NINETY THREE
OKAY ONE OH TWO. OKAY ONE OF
FOUR. OKAY ONE OF FIVE OKAY ONE
OH SIX OR EIGHT ONE OH SEVEN
EIGHT ONE OH EIGHT OKAY. ONE
SIXTEEN ONE EIGHTEEN RIGHT. I
WANTED TO BUY FOR KATO ONE
NINETEEN DAHLE JUST BE A NOTE-
ON IT JUST TO KEEP IT SIMPLE
OKAY AND THAT ONE IS NOT IN
THIS VOTE ANYWAY OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO THANK YOU- NO PROBLEM AND
I'VE WRITTEN ALL THOSE DOWN
HOPEFULLY SECRETARY HAS ALSO
BUT THERE ARE ON THE TAPE SO-
CENTER BILL IF I CAN GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE AND THEN-
WHEN WE TAKE THE ROLE CENTER
MORE LIFE WOULD BE RECORDED NO
ON THE ITEM HE IS LISTED. AND
BUT I. ON THE ITEMS HE DID NOT
LIST. IS THAT DOES THAT WORK
FOR US IN TERMS OF A VOTER DO I
NEED TO BIFURCATE IT FURTHER.
TWENTY TWO TAKE A MOTION ON
ONLY THOSE ITEMS THAT SENATOR
MORE LIKE IT'S NOT VOTING NO
ONE LET'S DO IT THAT WAY IT'S
CLEANER. OKAY SEVEN WE ARE NOW
MOVE ON ONLY THOSE ITEMS THAT
SENATOR MORE LIKE IS NOT VOTING
NO ONE IN HIS KNOW HIS VOTING
NO STARTED AT ITEM FORTY ONE SO.
THE ONES PREVIOUS TO THAT US
SENATOR BILL ENTERTAIN THAT
MOTION PLUS THE OTHER ONE CITY
DIDN'T STATE IN WITH THAT CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. SENATOR
SKINNER AYE SKINNER AYE CENTER
MORLOCK MOORLACH NO SENATOR
BELL YOUR EYES. MY EYES AND
LET'S SEE HERE I KNOW POLITICS
THESE ARE MY RIGHTS AND I'M AND
I THINK MORE LIKE CHANGE FROM
BUT MORE LOCKED BY SENATOR BELL
CENTRE BELL HI OKAY SO THEN
CENTER I WOULD JUST REPEAT JUST
SO WE'RE CLEAR ON THE RECORD
EXACTLY THE ITEMS THE CENTER
MORE LIKE THE NEXT MOTION WILL
BE ON ITEMS 414-034-0540
640-962-6360. FOUR SIXTY FIVE
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHTY ONE NINETY
ONE NINETY TWO NINETY THREE ONE
OH TO  SIX ONE SEVEN ONE. ONE
SIXTY ONE EIGHTEEN. MOST TO
PROVE SENATOR BREAUX. OF GREAT
ROLL CALL. YOU THE FASTER. DR.
BROUGHT CENTER SKINNER HI-
SKINNER I SENATOR MORLOCK
LIEBERMAN NO IN THIS ONE-
MORLOCK NOW SENATOR BELL.
CENTRE BELL I. EXCELLENT SO LET
US- NOW MOVE ON ITEMS ISSUE
ITEMS ISSUES. 373-854-6670 ONE
EIGHTY FOUR ONE ONE ONE
THIRTEEN AND ONE NINETEEN AND
THESE ARE ALL REJECT. SO IF
THERE'S ANY VIDEOS YOU WANT TO
KNOCK REJECT YOU WOULD VOTE NO.
IF YOU AGREE TO REJECT THE MORE
YOU WOULD VOTE YES THERE WAS
ONE THAT WE DISCUSS WHAT WHAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE FROM
THAT RIGHT THAT I WAS
SUPPORTING THE GOVERNOR THAT
WAS. OKAY STORY ALLEGE HE WAS
THAT WE LOOK FOR THAT ROLE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR MIGHT OF
ANY FOR. NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR
OKAY RIGHT. IN ONE NINETEEN
RIGHT SO WE WILL REMOVE EIGHTY
FOREIGN ONE NINETEEN FROM THIS
VOTE. SEC WOULD THAT BE GREAT
OKAY SO WE ARE DâN AT US AND-
BOTH OF IT OKAY SO THE MOTION
373-854-6670 ONE ONE A ONE AND
ONE THIRTEEN REJECT. BROKAW
CENTER SKINNER HI SKINNER I
SENATOR MORLOCK CENTER MORE
LUCK I SENATOR BILL. SENATE
BILL I THREE IN A MOTION TO
REJECT ITEMS ISSUES SORRY
ISSUES EIGHTY FOUR AND ONE
NINETEEN. WHO GREAT. CENTER
SKINNER HI CENTER SKINNER I
SENATOR MOLOCH CENTER MORE LUCK
NO CENTER BELL. CENTRE BELL I.
OKAY. NOW I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE IN THE ACTION WE
TAKE ON THE DJJ ITEMS THAT WE
ARE INCORPORATING THE FACT. THE
ADDITIONS TO OUR MOTION THAT
SENATOR BILL HAD SPECIFIED SO
DO I NEED TO REVISE ANYTHING.
DID WE ALREADY DID WE VOTE DO I
NEED TO. OKAY I'M SORRY. AND
EVERYTHING. NO DESSERT SENATOR
BILL HAD A SPECIFIC MOTION ON
THE DJJ. OKAY REALIGNMENT BUT I
THINK IT'S GREAT. AND I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
INCORPORATE SENATOR BILLS. MY
PUBLIC- THOSE ARE IN THE HOLD
OPEN OKAY SO WE WOULDN'T BE
VOTING TODAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S
JUST WHAT I WANTED TO ASCERTAIN
OKAY THAT'S GREAT WE JUST NOTE
DOWN ON THE MINUTE SO WHEN THEY
GO AHEAD BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA
COME UP SOMEWHERE AND YES AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING. YEAH ABSOLUTELY
ABSOLUTELY I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
WE'RE DOES AS BY AGREED WITH
HIS. COMMENTS AND WE ADDED SOME
ADDITIONAL ONES. OKAY SO NOW-
ISSUE EIGHTY TWO. WE ARE. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS. IT'S A
REJECTION CORRECT IT'S A NINETY
POINT EIGHT MILLION REDUCTION.
TO REJECTING EIGHTY TWO. RIGHT
SO THAT ONE WE DID NOT VOTE ON
YET I WOULD LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO REJECT ISSUE EIGHTY
TWO WILL. OKAY. QUESTION YES GO
AHEAD. I PREFER THE LA-
RECOMMENDATION TO DELAY BY ONE
YEAR SO THEN I'LL BE IN OVER.
ALL RIGHT. IN A COURSE WHAT
REJECTION ANSWER DOING IS
ALLOWING US TO NEGOTIATE SUCH
THINGS BUT THAT'S RIGHT I WANT
TO GET ON THE RECORD THAT
SENATOR ARE LOCKED IN A
LEVERAGE OF ALL SUPPORT YOU BUT
IT'S OKAY BECAUSE IT'S CLEAR
YOU WANTED I MEAN I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE SO THAT STAFF
UNDERSTANDS THAT IN TERMS OF
SENATOR MORE LAX- VIEW IT WOULD
BE THE LA OWES RECOMMENDATION
AND SINCE WE ARE. YOU KNOW
WHATEVER THESE MOTION SIR CAN
BE QUITE CONSTRUCTED LIKE THAT
IT JUST WOULD TAKE A NOTE OF
THAT FOR THE MINUTES. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION TO REJECT EIGHTY
TWO. DO YOU DO THERE ROLL CALL
TO. CENTER SKINNER- HIGH-
SKINNER AYE CENTER MORLOCK
CENTER MORE LOOK NO SENATOR
BELL. CENTRE BELL I. OKAY SO
NOW ON ITEM ONE SIXTEEN. I'M
NOT SURE WHAT MY MOTION IS
GOING TO BE ON THAT ONE ONE
MOMENT. ISSUE ONE SIXTEEN. ROPE
WITH. THERE WAS ONE WE
DISCUSSED CORRECT. WITH A
LITTLE FOR. YES SIR IT IS JUST
STILL HOLDING IT OPEN ISN'T IT
WILL OPEN. A FEW OF THEM. OKAY
I JUST IT'S JUST THAT IT'S ON
THIS LIST AS MARK I GET I GET
IT WE'RE JUST MODIFYING IT NOT
ALRIGHT BUT IT'S JUST REPEAT
THAT TO HOLD OPEN SO THERE'S NO
NEED TO VOTE. SO I CAN DO FOR
THIS RIGHT NOW. HISTORY ONE
SIXTEEN IS HERE AND ONE SIXTEEN
IS HERE. REQUIRED SO OUR WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT TAKING TO VOTE
ON IT. AT. WE NEED A BETTER
NUMBER SYSTEM ON THIS YEAH
WHICH WHICH PART. YOU CAN EARN
YOU KNOW JUST IF I CAN HEAR YOU
MUCH BETTER IF YOU'RE NEAR THE
THING FOR VIOLATING IF YOU'RE
NEAR THIS PLASTIC. YES THE
OVERALL AND THAT WE MIGHT SCORE.
TO ADD THE LA- GRECO SPONSOR WE
NEED A MOTION THAT WOULD JUST
BE ON THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE TRANSITION WITHDRAWAL.
WE ARE APPROVING IT IS BUDGETED
BUT WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
SAVINGS ARE SCORED REFLECTING
THE POINTS THAT LA MADE. SO A
CENTER BILL OR MORE LACKEY WERE
YOU CONCLUDE WITH THE MOTION
LIKE THAT OKAY. RIGHT TO CENTER
MORE LIKE MOVES. LET SIDE. WITH
SEVERAL CALL. SENATE SKINNER
HI- SKINNER EYES CENTER MORE
LOCK OR FOR MORE LOOK I CENTER
BILL SENATE BILL I. YEAH IT'S
TOO BAD WE PRICE TO THE NUMBER
DOES DIFFERENTLY BUT THAT'S
RIGHT ONE ELEVEN WE WANTED TO
FOR WITHOUT PREJUDICE. SOMEONE
WILLING TO MAKE A MOTION ON
THAT ALRIGHT. FOR WITHOUT FOR
THE. WE HAVE A MOTION ANY
COMMENTS AND OR MORE LIKE. THE
MOVIE IS THAT RIGHT CENTER
BUILDERS IN THE CENTER THE WHAT
TAKE THE MORE LIKE MOTION EVEN
THOUGH CENTER BUILDING THAT'S
OKAY CENTER MORE LIKE MOVED.
WHAT ELEVEN WITHOUT PREJUDICE
GO AHEAD ROLL CALL CENTERS
SKINNER I CAN- SKINNER AYE
CENTER MORLOCK CENTER MORE LOG
BY SENATOR BELL. CENTRE BELL I.
WE ARE HOLDING OPEN JUST SO. HI
I CAN IMAGINE THAT THE- FOR
ANYONE WHO'S JUST WATCHING
SCREENS VERY HARD TO FOLLOW BUT
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT
WE'RE NOT VOTING AND HOLDING
OPEN ISSUES FOURTEEN ISSUES
TWENTY NINE. ISSUES THIRTY NINE
ISSUES FIFTY SIX. ISSUES SIXTY
AND SIXTY ONE ISSUE SIXTY SIX
ISSUE SIXTY NINE. ISSUE EIGHTY
ISSUE EIGHTY NINE ISSUE ONE
TWELVE ISSUE ONE FIFTEEN EN
THESE SPECIFIC ITEMS IN ONE
SIXTEEN. AND THEIR SPECIFIC
ITEMS IN ITEM ONE SIXTEEN OUR.
THE. THE REDUCTION OF POSITIONS
IN THE D. J. J. REALIGNMENTS.
IT'S A LITTLE KNOWN EXPENDITURE
AND THE- BSE SEE ITEM IN THE
DJJ REALIGNMENT AS WE DISCUSSED.
RIGHT SHOWN SEVENTEEN. YES
SORRY AND ONE SEVENTEEN OH YES
THANK YOU YES WE ARE HOLDING
OUT OPEN WHEN SEVENTY KNOWS OF
THE CAPITAL OUTLAYS. KATIE I
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET CLOSER
I CANNOT HEAR YOU. YOU I THINK
YOU CAN WITH THIS YET. ALRIGHT
HERE WE HAVE THIS GUARD SO YOU
CAN QUE THEY WERE. YEAH THOSE
THAT I HAVE TO SPECIFY. OKAY
RIGHT OR THEY CAN I WILL I BE
ABLE TO TELL THAT FROM JUST
TURN INTO THAT ITEM OR SHOULD I
LOOK. I KNOW WE DISCUSSED THEM
IT'S JUST MY- MEMORY BANKS AT
THIS MOMENT OR NOT CAN WORK
WELL. YES I DID STATE DOES WE
VOTED ON REJECTING THIRTY SEVEN.
MORE RIGHT THERE LISTEN THE
GENDER BUT WE TOOK THE VOTE TO
REJECT. I MEAN IS. THAT'S HOW
IT'S. TOWARDS THE TWENTY NINE
FOURTEEN. YEAH WE TOOK THE
MOTION TO REJECT THOSE OF WE
DID WHAT WE DID AND I READ
EXACTLY THOSE. OKAY YEAH I'D
APPRECIATE THAT SO I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE WE DID TAKE A
MOTION TO REJECT ITEMS THIRTY
SEVEN. THIRTY EIGHT FIFTY FOUR
SIXTY SIX SEVENTY ONE. EIGHTY
FOUR ONE OH ONE ONE THIRTEEN
AND ONE NINETEEN WE DIDN'T TO
MOTIONS BECAUSE SENATOR MORLOCK
VOTED NOT TO REJECT EIGHTY FOUR
AND ONE NINETEEN. OKAY BUT WE
DID IN TO MOTIONS BUT WE DID DO
IT. BUT IT'S BY PRE SHEET STAFF
CLARIFYING BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- HEY CAN
UNDER THIS IS A VERY. UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT WE ARE FOR
OPERATE LEE RECORDING OR
ACTIONS. EXCELLENT SO. UNLESS
THERE IS ANOTHER THING THAT
EITHER I MADE A MISSTEP ON
WHICH I DON'T MIND ANYONE
TWENTY NO IN TERMS OF PARTY. I
WOULD MOVE ON THEN TO PART BE
AND AS STAFF IF THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU CATCH THERE
IS SOMETHING ALREADY OR OKAY
RIGHT WHICH ITEM IS IT. YES YOU
ROLL. FIND YES AND THAT THERE
ARE THOSE TWO ITEMS IN ONE
SIXTEEN ALL RIGHT SO I GUESS I
NEED A SEPARATE MOTION. BECAUSE
WE BETTER SPECIFY AND I
SPECIFIED ON THE OTHERS. ITEM
ONE SIXTEEN WHICH ARE ALL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM ITEMS
BUT SINCE WE VOTED INDIVIDUALLY
ON MOST OF THEM. WE LEFT
HANGING OUT THERE THE REDUCED-
PAROLE TERMS INTERNS JUST
CHARGE SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
DO. IT IS ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
ON THE ONE ON REDUCE PAROLE
TERMS. THAT ALLOWS US TO ADOPT
THE PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE AND- ADDITIONAL
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WE
WILL THEY ARE STILL TO BE
DISCUSSED SO OBVIOUSLY WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY LATER TO
VOTE ON THAT. BUT AS A DOCTOR
THIS PLACE HOLDER AND THE
ACTION TAKEN WITH THE WITH THE
NOTE THAT THERE MAY BE
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS THAT COULD
BE SIX CORD. BASED ON THE LA
OWES- INPUT SO WE'RE GOING TO
ADOPT THE ACTION AS IT'S LISTED
IN TERMS OF THE SAVINGS OR THE
REDUCTIONS THAT THE-
ADMINISTRATION IS LISTED BUT WE
ARE GOING TO INCLUDE IN OUR
MOTION THAT IF THE LA OWES
ESTIMATE IS ACCURATE THAT IT BE
IT. BE OUR- THE DOLLAR FIGURES
BE ADJUSTED ACCORDINGLY- SURELY
I MOVED- BUT I WANTED TO POINT
OUT THAT I A REQUESTED UNDER
THAT GOOD CONDUCT MEASURE.
SPECIFIC TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
DEALS WITH- MENTALLY ILL AND-
DEVELOPING DISABLED INMATES
MAKE SURE THEIR ELIGIBILITY IS
EQUAL TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS OKAY
I RODE SO JUST SO YES WE WILL
AT THAT TIME I'LL COME. TO YOUR
LEADER A MOVE THAT WITH THAT
YES I WILL ASSUME YOU'RE MAKING
THE MOTION AND WE WILL ADD
THAT. TO IT. COOL OKAY LOCAL
CENTER SKINNER I CENTER SKINNER
I SENATOR MOULA WHO CENTER MORE
LOG NO SENATOR BELL. CENTRE
BELL I. OKAY AND THEN WE WOULD
ENTERTAIN A FINAL MOTION ON THE
WHAT'S LISTED AS ISSUE ONE
SIXTEEN BUT IS THE SPECIFIC
ACTION ON THE GOOD CONDUCT
CREDITS. AND THE MOTION I WOULD
ENTERTAIN IS TO APPROVE AS
BUDGETED AND- WITH- PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE THE. ROONEY
COMMUNICATE THIS APPROPRIATELY
THAT WE FACTOR THE FULL RANGE
OF CREDITS THAT PROP FIFTY
SEVEN ALLOWS. THAT INCLUDES THE
CREDIT THIS IS REQUIRED YES
THIS IS A GOOD CONTACT CREDITS.
EDIT YEAH OKAY SO ALL RIGHT SO
WE ARE ADDING TO THAT MOTION
THAT DID THAT IT ALSO THE
TRAILER BILL ENSURE THAT AS
THOSE- INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE MENTALLY ILL ARE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED HAVE
ADDITIONAL AVE NOT ADDITIONAL
BUT ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
CHRIS THE DAY BE INSURED. RIGHT
WITHOUT WILL DO A ROLL CALL.
CENTERS SKINNER HI CENTER
SKINNER AYE CENTER MALL MORE
LOOK. CENTER MORE LOOK NO
CENTER BILL SENATE BILL I. OKAY
SO STAFF TO RESCHEDULE. OKAY OR
DO IT CORRECTLY IT'S BEST WE
COULD CONSIDERING EVERYTHING.
RIGHT SO- THANK YOU- MISTER
FRANCIS FOR THIS INCREDIBLE
WORK AND- I WOULD SAY MORE IN
TERMS THANKS BUT I WANT TO
BRINGUP THE SALICIN GET TO BE
RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE I KNOW WE
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON IT. SO
LET'S START PARTY. WE ARE NOW
BEGINNING PART B. AND- THIS IS
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES IN THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD WE HAVE ONE ISSUE FOR
DISCUSSION ON THE AGENDA IN
ADDITION TO VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR AND I WOULD LIKE TO
NOTE AGAIN WILL BE HEARING ALL
THE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA PRIOR
TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN
VOTING. AND WANTS TO BE A FOR
THOSE ITEMS. WE WILL. SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE HEARING
ROOMS TO SPEAK AND IF NO ONE'S
IN THE HEARING ROOMS WILL OPEN
THE- THE PHONE. THE PHONE LINE
AND ONCE WE HAVE HEARD THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL VOTE ON
THE AGENDA ITEMS. SO I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME THE DIRECTOR OF CAL-
YES MARK KILLER DO CHI AND ALSO
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING- REMOTELY. SKEWS
ME. AND SINCE OUR FIRST ITEM
IS- E. S. DIRECTOR GIRL WOULD
KILL OUR D. G. DO YOU WANT TO
PRESENT THE ITEM. OKAY GROW
GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I WILL BE VERY
BRIEF HERE- AS YOU KNOW THE MAY
RE. REVISION PROPOSES FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL PREPAREDNESS
MEASURES THE POSTER COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY AND BUILT ON THE
200-019-2000 TWENTY OUR
RESILIENCY INVESTMENT KNOWN AS
PS YES. GRANTS IN THIS TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY YEAR OR WE
EXPECT OUR USE ARE YOU ARE YOU
LED POWER SHOT OFF A BRANCH. TO
FOR FIRE MITIGATION- EFFORTS TO
CONTINUE- AND TO CONTINUE TO BE
AN ESSENTIALLY AN IMPACT THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPERATIVE THE STATE CONTINUE
TO INVEST IN MITIGATION ACTIONS
THAT WILL REDUCE THE IMPACTS.
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS TO
INCREASE READING THIS AND
RESPONSE CAPABILITIES TO
ENHANCE OPERATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS. WITH THIS ROUND
OF FUNDING WE INTEND TO
CONTINUE TO SOME BUILDING LOCAL
CAPABILITIES THROUGH GRANTS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WE WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT PARTICULAR DURING
THIS TIME SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
ARE THEY COLLECTIVELY MANAGE
MANY CRITICAL LOCAL SERVICES
CALIFORNIANS RELY ON SUCH AS
WATER AND WASTEWATER WASTE
MANAGEMENT HEALTH CARE
TRANSPORTATION COMMERCE BURIAL
SIX SENTRA. ALL THESE SERVICES
WERE DIRECTLY IMPACT IMPACTED
BY LAST FALL'S PS PS ADVANCE.
WELL I AM WITH THE POTENTIAL OF
COVERT NINETEEN IMPACTS
OVERLAPPING WITH PS YES ON THIS
YEAR AS A STATE WE NEED TO
ENSURE THE SERVICES CONTINUE TO
OPERATE. LIKE LAST YEAR WHEN
DETERMINING WHO SHOULD RECEIVE
THE GRANTS. WE WILL A DATA
DRIVEN PROCESS WILL FOCUS ON
HOLD COMMUNITY NEEDS. AS WELL
AS OPERATIONAL CONSIDERATIONS
IN MAKING A DECISION. YES
CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RECORD YOUR DUTY AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK DURING
THIS TIME YES IT'S BEEN FOR
VERY SICK ROLE I MEAN WE'VE
YOU'RE USED TO HEARING FROM YOU
DURING HIGH ALL THE FIRE SEASON
AND WE- KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE
ONE AGAIN. BUT WE'VE ALSO.
SENIOR OFFICES GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP TO ALL OF THIS
PANDEMIC- IT'S ANY I HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM ON THE
RESILIENCY SHUT DOWN BUT I
WOULD SEE MY COLLEAGUES TO GO
AHEAD CENTER ONE QUICK QUESTION
UNDER SHIRTS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN. MODIFICATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S EARTHQUAKE EARLY
WARNING SYSTEM- WE ARE. NOW
GOING TO HAVE A REPLACEMENT OF
A GENERAL FUND LOAN WITH A LOAN
FROM THE SCHOOL LAND SPANK FUND
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION. FOR SEVENTEEN
MILLION PLUS AND WE DID GET A
CHANCE TO ASK THIS TYPE OF
QUESTION ON PARTY BUT SOME OF
THESE. FUNDS OF KIND OF
ACCUMULATED QUITE A BIT MORE
BORROWING FROM THEM AND I'M
JUST KIND OF CURIOUS HOW DOES
A- OUT OF THIS LAND FOR AND GET
TO. A BUILD UP TO SEVENTEEN
MILLION AND IN A YOU KNOW AND-
OVER HOW MANY YEARS IN ARE WE-
ARE WE CHARGING TOO MUCH ARE WE
SUPPOSED TO CHARGE. WHAT IT
COSTS AND I'M JUST SORT OF
CURIOUS IF I COULD MAYBE USE
THIS AS AN EXAMPLE FOR A LOT OF
THE OTHER FINE ART SO- THIS ONE
WAS ON THE VOTE ON THE CALENDAR
BUT WE CAN PULL IT. BECAUSE YOU
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT IT.
HOWEVER WE MAY NOT HAVE A STAFF
THAT CAN ANSWER IT WE MAY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU MAY
BE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD. WELL
THIS ONE IS REPLACING ALONE
FRONT THIRDS FROM SCHOOL LANDS
AND STATE LANDS- IT MINISTERS
BUT MARK HOPEFULLY YOU CAN. SO
WE'RE GOING TO PULL THIS FROM
VOTE ONLY AND ADDED TO THIS
DISCUSSION. SO THAT OF A
SENATOR MORAL CAN HAVE HIS-
QUESTION ADDRESSED- DIRECTOR
DEALER D. G. OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE YOU ABLE TO. BUT
THIS THIS IS MARK ARCH I'LL
DEFER WERE TO FINANCE AND THEY
CAN GIVE YOU THE SPECIFICS ON
THIS PARTICULAR OUTSIDE. OKAY
STEVEN BEDS WITH THE PART OF
FINANCE- WHAT WE CAN GET BACK
TO SOME OF THE DETAILS I THINK
THAT THE NATURE OF THE REVENUE
THAT GOES INTO THAT FUND IS A
RELATED TO- AT LEAST REVENUE
THAT COMES OFF OF LANDS THAT
WERE USUALLY GRANT THE- STATE
USERS COLIN'S AND- SO WE CAN
GET BACK AND SOME OF THE
DETAILS FROM THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AS TO. HOW THAT FELT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEASURE BECAUSE INTERNALLY IN
SECTION OUR PARTY WE- CERTAINLY
WERE BORROWED FROM SOME FINDS
pTHAT RATE. IN CANADA- GENERATED
BY FEES THAT ARE COLLECTED SO
JUST. LOOK CONCERNING HOW THEY
DEVELOP CERTAIN LARGE BALANCES.
PROBABLY NICE TO HAVE THEM BUT-
MAYBE MAYBE A POLICY SHOULD BE
REVIEWED. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU MARK. OKAY SO ON THE-
SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO NOTE
THAT WE WILL BE. VOTING ON THAT
SEPARATELY BECAUSE WE DID
PODESTA DISCUSSION SO- BUT LET
ME NOW TURN TO THE- PLAN TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT DOWN
AND THE- FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ITEMS. AND LEE AS
WE EXPERIENCED IN THE LAST FIRE
SEASON NET SO SHOCKED THOSE
POWER SHUTDOWNS. REALLY
IMPACTED- THEY IMPACTED PEOPLE
MEDICALLY THE IMPACTED.
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE PACK
IMPACTED PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE BECAUSE INTERNET
WENT DOWN I MEAN THERE WERE SO
MANY THINGS AND STAND. THERE IT
WAS IN ELEGANT IN THAT THERE
WERE- MANY COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE EXPERIENCING SHUT DOWN FOR
MANY MORE DAYS THAN PEOPLE
MIGHT HAVE EXPECTED WE
CERTAINLY KNOW THAT THEY ARE
NECESSARY. IF I WITH THE HIGH
WINDS CIRCUMSTANCE A HIGH WIND
IN A HOT VERY HOT CONDITIONS
BUT WE CERTAINLY WANT TO. MAKE
SURE THAT WE HEAR THAT IN
FIXING YOUR CRISIS WE ARE TO
EXACERBATING A CRISIS SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S PART OF
WHAT THIS MONEY IS TRYING TO
DO. SO WHILE I KNOW THAT IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT THE- SOME
NUMBER THE STATE AGENCIES
RECEIVE FUNDING. FIVE IF YOU
KNOW FOR THIS PURPOSE FOR
EXAMPLE ON THE STATE TOTALS-
DURING ONE OF THE SHUTDOWNS-
THE CALL THE CUT TONAL WAS
CALTRANS DID. I DON'T NOT QUITE
SURE WHY BUT THEY HAD TO CLOSE
THE ENTIRE TUNNEL. BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T COULDN'T FIGURE OUT HOW
TO YOU HAVE TO BE EXHAUSTED
STEM OPERATE. IN THE COURSE THE
DANGER OF THAT IS HAD THERE
BEEN ANY FIRE- ON THE- OTHER
SIDE OF THE TUNNEL WE WOULD
HAVE. GIVEN THE WEIGHT THAT THE
ROADS IN THAT AREA ARE HE WOULD
HAVE COMPLETELY IMPEDED EITHER
PEOPLE'S ABILITY TO GET OUT.
FOR SOME LEVEL OF ASSISTANCE TO
GET IN. SO WE DON'T WANT THAT
TO HAPPEN SO I'D APPRECIATE
THAT WE WOULD NEED POTENTIALLY
SOME FUNDING THERE. BUT THERE
ARE SOME DOLLAR AMOUNT HERE. I
WONDER- WHETHER WE NEED ALL OF
THAT TO THOSE STATE AGENCIES
AND THE REASON I RAISE THAT IS
BECAUSE WHEN I LOOK AT THE
COUNTY ALLOCATIONS- I A LOOK AT
FOR EXAMPLE- YOU KNOW SOME OF
OUR- HI. FIRE AREAS THAT WHILE
THEY MAY NOT HAVE EXPERIENCED
ABOUT FIRE IN THE LAST TWO
COUPLE SEASONS HISTORICALLY
THEY HAVE BEEN AREAS WITH THE
WORST FIRES. AND YET THERE
ALLOCATION. MAY NOT BE ADEQUATE
FOR THE NEED ADDITIONALLY I SEE
THAT THIS IS ONLY COUNTIES AND
NOT SPECIAL DISTRICTS. AND IF
WE TAKE AGAIN I'LL BE VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT MY DISTRICT.
WHICH HAD THE WORST FIRE PRIOR
TO THE SANTA ROSA AND THE-
ORDER DID I SAY THAT RIGHT FOR.
WHAT WAS THE COMMUNITY IN THE
LAST. PARADISE NOT POOR EXCUSE
ME DEAD CENTER IS IN PARADISE
ENDED UP BEING WORSE THAN THE
OAKLAND BERKELEY TOTAL FIRE IN
TERMS OF BOTH LIVES LOST IN
STRUCTURES DAMAGE AND SUCH BUT
FOR A GOOD TWENTY YEARS THERE
THAT THE OLD. CALL THE CARD I
MEAN THE OAKLAND BERKELEY FIRE
WAS THE WORST IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY. AND IT'S ONLY JUST A
MATTER OF A WIND PATTERNS
RELUCTANT WE HAVEN'T HAD
ANOTHER ONE THERE AND THE NEXT
ONE COULD BE THAT BAD DEAR. AND
IT IS THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THAT OFFER FIRE SERVICES IN
THAT AREA. SOME MUCH OF IT IS A
LAND FOR EXAMPLE UNDER EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT WHICH
HOUSING FIRE DEPARTMENT- MUCH
OF THE CELL TOWERS ARE ALSO ON
THAT LAND. AND THERE'S JUST
THERE ARE CERTAIN SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THAT EITHER MANAGE A
LOT OF LAND IN THE WE IN THE
URBAN WILDLAND INTERFACE. FOR
THAT PROVIDE FIRE SERVICES AND
SO BASS DATE THEIR ROLE IN THE
IN THE POWER SHUT OFF WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY- ARE
ADEQUATELY PER AT OUR
ADEQUATELY RESOURCE SO THAT THE
POWER SHUT OFF DOES NOT IMPEDE
THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE. THE
EMERGENCY SERVICES THAT THEY
PROVIDE SO I JUST RAISE IT
BECAUSE THE WAY THIS IS
STRUCTURED. THEY WOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO ANY OF THESE FUNDS SO
I THINK THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE. IN TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TRAILER BILL IS DIRECTED
TOWARDS THE HIGHEST NEED AREAS
THAT ARE BOTH. THE MOST LIKELY
TO EXPERIENCEWE'D HAVE ALL THE
DATA THE BILL. A SERIES
WILDFIRE AND THAT WILL BE MOST
IMPACTED BY POWER SHUT OFFS. SO
THAT. IS WHY I WOULD APPROVED
THE ALLOCATION BUT WITH PLACE
HOLDER TRAILER LANGUAGE SO WE
CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY BEST WAY
TO ALLOCATE THAT FIFTEEN
MILLION. WE'RE NOT VOTING YET.
END UP POLICIES FOR ALL THE
COMMENTARY BUT- BY WAS IN
OFFICE DURING THAT FIGHT FIRE
AND- I WAS ALSO ON THE BOARD
LATER ON THE BOARD OF THESE BE
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT WHEN. UP
CONFIRA KURT. I'M OKAY SO WE
OTHERWISE ALL THE OTHER ITEMS
EXCEPT THE ONE THAT- CENTER
MORE LIKE CALDERON VOTE ONLY SO
I BELIEVE- STAFF TO FIND WHAT I
SEE THE LA- HAS THEIR HANDS UP
LET'S HEAR FROM WELL FIRST
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEN LA-
YES THEN THEY WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. THIRTY ONE YOUR
COMMENTS I THINK GREATER WHY
THIS NEXT ROUND OF FUNDING IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET WE
ARE FOCUSING ON A LOCAL
ASSISTANCE IN TRYING TO ALSO
OUTLINES DOING IT KIND OF A
IMMEDIATE A MATCHING GRANT
PROGRAM EXCEPT THAT'S AVAILABLE
TO TRY AND GET FUNDING ALLOWS
SPECIAL DISTRICTS AND OTHERS TO
BE ELIGIBLE. THIS YEAR'S ROUND
FUNDING. SO I POINTED OUT TO
GET AND IT GOES TO SOME OF OUR
THINKING BEING SOMEONE LINE
BEFORE YOUR COMMENT THANK YOU
IT'S NOT- IT WASN'T CLEAR THAT
SPECIAL DISTRICTS MIGHT BE
ELIGIBLE AND THE DIFFICULTY OF
JUST DOING IT BY COUNTY IS THAT
SOME SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE
COVER MULTIPLE COUNTY SO JUST
THESE THE KINDS OF THINGS WILL
DISCUSS AS WE LAND. THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FILIALES. DEAR ME
THIS IS TIME YES GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING AT YEAR
END SENATORS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK- BRIEFLY
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER REDUCING THE FUNDING
LEVEL FOR THIS PROPOSAL JUST
GIVEN THE CONDITION OF THE
GENERAL FUND AND THE LACK OF
CLARITY ABOUT THE AMOUNT NEEDED
FOR THIS PURPOSE. AS WAS NOTED
THERE WAS FUNDING LAST YEAR
THAT WAS PERMITTED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION- IF APPROVED TO
RECOMMEND TO ACTIONS FIRST
ADOPTING LANGUAGE THAT FURTHER
DEFINES HOW FUNDS TO BE USED
SUCH AS THE AMOUNT FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE VERSUS THE
OBLIGATION SO AND WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS BECAUSE
CURRENTLY THE LANGUAGE IS VERY
BROAD. BASICALLY CAN BE USED
FOR ANY COMMUNITY RESILIENCY
ACTIVITIES BY STATE OR OR LOCAL
ENTITIES AND SO IT'S NOT CLEAR
EVEN IF THE LEGISLATURE OR EVEN
IF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INTENSITY THAT MOSTLY FOR
LOCALS THAT IT'S NOT CLEARLY
DEFINED IN THE LANGUAGE. ON
THIS SURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
I CAN'T. REQUIRE YES REPORT ON
HOW THE FUNDS OLD. USE AND I'M
WHAT OUT ARE ACHIEVED. WE KNOW
THAT THIS TYPE OF REPORTING WAS
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET- BUT IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
PROPOSE FOR INCLUSION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- LANGUAGE. AND WE
THINK THIS WILL GIVE THE
LEGISLATURE'S ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AFTER THE FACT AND
HOW THE- MONEY WAS USED AND
HELP ENSURE THAT. WE CAN REALLY
ESTáN. IN THIS AFTER THE FACT.
THANK YOU. LET'S SEE OKAY SO
THAT WAS ALIEN DELAP WE HEARD
FROM THEM GREAT ALRIGHT SO. NOW
I BELIEVE WHAT I WOULD DO NEXT.
IS HERE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT IS
THAT CORRECT. OKAY SO- HAVING
HEARD FROM THE DEPARTMENTS AND
DISCUSS THE ONLY ITEMS WE'RE
DISCUSSING EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
MANY MANY ITEMS HERE. AND I
MEAN WE ALSO IN IN THIS AGENDA
WAS- FOR EXAMPLE. OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
ADDITIONALLY VICTIM
COMPENSATION FUND SO CERTAINLY
WE MAY HAVE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THAT I TO WANT TO PREDICT
BUT WHAT I WILL DO FIRST SO
PEOPLE WHO ARE CALLING IN- WE
WILL GET YOU VERY SOON SO- THE
PHONE NUMBER IS ON THE.
COMMITTEE THE SUB FIVE WEBSITE
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WANT TO
SCREW IT TEARS CURLED ON THE
SCREEN NOW- BUT FIRST WE WILL
LOOK TO THIS ROOM AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE. WHO WANTS
TO- SPEAK ON ANY OF THESE ITEMS
AND I WOULD SAY NO BECAUSE IT
IS OUR SAME STAFF WERE IN THE
pROOM. AND I WILL THEN ASKED TO
LEAVE THE ROOM ON THE SECOND
FLOOR MY GUESS IS THERE'S NO
ONE THERE EITHER OKAY THERE
ISN'T. SO THAT MEANS THAT WE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES. I'M SORRY
GO AND- BILL GO AHEAD. WELL IF
YOU COULD LOOK AT PAGE SIX AND
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE SIX. AND I'M REFERRING TO
ITEM NINETEEN OVER. IT IT SAYS
GENERAL FUND MINUS FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THERE HAS ALL THESE
ITEMS. EACH ONE OF THEM IS
DIFFERENT AMOUNT THE TOTAL MORE
THAN FIVE MILLION OBVIOUSLY- SO
COULD SOMEBODY EXPLAIN I DO-
DIED IN A STAND ON IT WAS ON
VOTE ONLY BUT WILL PULL IT
THAT'S OKAY WE'LL JUST- NOT NOT
IT'S NOT IT'S JIM IF YOU ASK
THE QUESTION I CAN'T.
UNDERSTAND IT RIGHT RIGHT SO
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN THAT IS
CURRENTLY ON THE VOTE ONLY WE
ARE PULLING AS WE DID FOR THE
ISSUE FOR CENTER MORE LIKE SO
THAT THE QUESTION THAT SENATOR
BILL RAISED. ON WHICH IS A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION CAN BE
EXPLAINED. BY LET'S SEE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GO AHEAD.
SURE ENOUGH HERE- WHAT THE
DISTINCTION AS A SENATOR IS.
THE FUNDING WITH THE- FORTY ONE
MILLION IS CURRENT YEAR FUNDING
WHERE IS THE FIVE MILLION
PROPOSED IS BUDGET YOUR FUNDING.
THE REVERSION GOALS WAS TO.
RIVER TO ENCUMBER BALANCE OF
THE CURRENT YEAR DOLLARS- AND
THEN SHORT ONE PARTICULAR GOALS
ALL ITS TO MURDER FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN BUDGET YEAR AND
ANOTHER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
BUT YEAR PLUS ONE THEONE THAT
IS A PROPOSAL WHICH ONE WHICH
PROPOSAL. IT IS THE INTERNET
CRIMES AGAINST CHILDREN
PROPOSAL THAT WAS- ALLEGE
INVESTMENT FROM LAST YEAR.
WHERE IT IS REMOVING THAT
INVESTMENT. IS THAT CORRECT.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
IT IS TO- RIVER AT THE END OF
COMBAT ROUNDS OF THE CURRENT
YEAR DOLLARS AND ALSO TO
WITHDRAWAL THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS PROVIDED AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ALSO TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO IT
WAS A- PROPOSAL THAT PROVIDED
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS OVER A
THREE YEAR. HELLO COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THAT. IN TERMS OF THAT
INTERNET FOR IS THAT MEAN THAT
IMPLEMENTED IS THIS ACTION
BASICALLY- PREVENT THAT
LEGISLATION FROM BEING
IMPLEMENTED. CRITICS YOUR YOUR
ACTION WOULD- REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL- AND-
DEFERRED TO FUTURE
DELIBERATIONS OKAY YOU'RE
YOU'RE RIGHT I WAS JUST READING
IT WRONG. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RECOMMENDATION WOULD ENSURE
THAT THE AND AGAIN I'M NOT
TRYING TO. ADD A VALUE
STATEMENT JUST THAT THE-
LEGISLATION WAS IMPLEMENTED IN
OUR REJECTION OF IT WOULD ALLOW
FOR SOME MORE DISCUSSION TO A
POTENTIALLY HAVE SOME ASPECT OF
THAT PROGRAM STILL IMPLEMENTED.
I CHARACTERIZE THAT CORRECTLY
OKAY IS THAT HELP- CENTER ABOUT
ALL THE ALL THE OTHER YOUR
BALANCES. OR GO TO BE SWEPT.
NOT NOT EXPANDED SO WE HAVE
SEVERAL PROGRAMS HERE THAT WE
VOTED ON LAST YEAR. THE IN THE
BUDGET AND THEN THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE. APPROVED OF OR ARE
THERE GOING TO BE FROZEN AND
THE MONEY IS GONNA BE TAKEN
BACK CORRECT IS THAT THE KIND
OF THE. IF SHE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION- WORK TO HOLD IN
THE- THE- SUBCOMMITTEE REJECTED
THE PROPOSAL BY THE
ADMINISTRATION- THEN THE UNDER
COVERED BALANCES OF. OKAY THOSE
LEGEND BEST FRIENDS WOULD NOT
RIVER AS OF JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY NINETEEN- FOR REJECTION
DOES AB BASICALLY WOULD NOT
REVERT ANYTHING. IT IS HARD THE
DIFFICULTY WITH A LOT OF MONEY
YET THE DIFFICULTY WITH THE
CHART AND I APPRECIATE THAT. IS
THAT THIS CHART IS SHOWING MAY
REVISE BECAUSE THE MAY REVISED
ASSUMES THAT THE ORIGINAL THE
JANUARY BUDGET IS. JUST LIKE I
DON'T MEAN IT TO I DO WANT TO
SAY ADOPTED BIRD LIKE WE'RE
JUST OPERATING FROM THE G.
THREE BUDGET. AND SINCE WE
DIDN'T EVEN GET TO HAVE OUR
HEARINGS ON THE CHECK PERFECT
COACH THAT THE CHARTER
CONFUSING FOR US SO IN EFFECT.
WELL IT SHOWS IT THAT. WERE
REALLY REJECTING THE REVERSION
OF ANY OF THESE LEGISLATIVE
ITEMS BY. OUR BY THE
RECOMMENDATION HERE. THAT OKAY.
HI I HOPE THAT MADE SOME SENSE.
OKAY YOU KNOW I'M REALLY GLAD
YOU DID ASK BECAUSE I'M LIKE I
GOT BRIEFED AND I THINK I PRY
UNDER SNOW LIKE A BRIEF BUT I
COULDN'T RECALL IT RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN TRUST AND WHO. ALRIGHT
SO WITH THAT WE WILL- GO TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE HAVE THE
PHONE LINES AND ALL EXPLAINED
VOTING AFTER THAT. RIGHT PHONE
LINES. MODERATOR PLEASE JOIN ME
ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU'D LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO JOIN THE QUEUE AGAIN
ONE ZERO TO JOIN THE QUEUE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND- IF YOU DO
YOU COULD TELL ME HOW MANY ARE
IN THE QUEUE SO I CAN DETERMINE
THE TIME ALLOCATION ONLY
BECAUSE WE ONLY HAVE THIS PHONE
LINE UNTIL BUT WE HAVE A
SPECIFIED TIME. ABSOLUTELY AT
THIS TIME I AM SEEN TWELVE IN
OUR QUEUE. OKAY SO I WOULD ASK
THOSE FOLKS IF YOU COULD. FIVE
MAKE YOUR COMMENT WITHIN A
MINUTE I WILL GIVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY BUT IF WE START
GETTING MORE CALL INS ON THE
LINE I MAY HAVE TO MODIFY THAT.
RATE AND APPRECIATE YOUR
ASSISTANCE THANK MODERATOR GO
AHEAD. FIRST WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
TWO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU- MY NAME'S
MOHAMMED TIME SORRY AND I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT THE
ACLU OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M
SPEAKING THIS AFTERNOON TO ADD
THE ACER USE VOICE TO YOU WHAT
I THINK WILL BE A COURSE OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
ONLINE THAT ARE REQUESTING
THAT- THIS GROUP NOT FOND OF IT
CREATING SAFER COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY CAL- IS
ARE YOU STRONGLY OPPOSES THE
CREATING SAFER COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S PROMISED
ON THE PLOT IDEA. THAT'S
INDIVIDUALS ON A PATH TOWARD
COMMITTING VIOLENCE AND
TERRORISM CAN BE READILY
IDENTIFIABLE IDENTIFIED IN THE
WAY THAT IT WORKS IS THAT BILL-
BILL NUYS ON POPULAR BELIEFS OR
POLITICAL DISSENT AND
UNORTHODOX RELIGIOUS CUSTOMS
ALL OF WHICH ARE PROTECTED
FORMS OF SPEECH THAT THE SO YOU
DEPENDS ON A DAILY BASIS. SO WE
WOULD ASSN INSTEAD OF FUNDING-
THAT CREATING SAFER COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. AND PROGRAMS LIKE
SOUND BETTER. KLAY UNTESTED AND
ARE BASED ON. SALES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD INSTEAD
RESPOND TO THIS MOMENT OF
CRISIS BY COMMITTING RESOURCES
IN THE SOCIAL SERVICES THAT
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
NEEDS THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK.
NEXT TO A NUMBER TWO ELEVEN
AGAIN TWO ONE ONE YOUR LINES
OPEN. SH HI ED YOUR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FIVE MINUTES.
ERICA PLAN SEVEN MANY FOUR
HUNDRED A ONE YEAR OLD YOU CAN
TO THE LIMITATION IN LA AND
ACROSS THE US WHAT CALLING ON
THE DATE REJECTED FUNDING TO
CREATE ONE OF THE PERKS.
PROGRAM OR YEAH YEAH MINISTER
BY THE CANAL- YEAH BUT YES THE
PROGRAM IS FUNDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF OMELAND SECURITY
AND PRIVATE PILOT PROGRAM IT'S-
A VEILED THREAT. AND YOU COULD
CALL IT. WOULD FOR YEARS
CONVENTION FACE. FRANKLY
HEALTHY JOB HOUSE. BLANK FACES
AND SERVICES FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES. HE HAS FUNDING WILL
NOT ACHIEVE THIS VISION
QUICKLY. IT HAS A HAS A
HORRENDOUS RECORD OF HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS. INCLUDING
RECOUP FAMILIES APART INCLUDING
THOSE WITH MY WORK WENT ON MY
OWN WHEN I WAS FOURTEEN YEARS
OLD WE CANNOT TRUST EACH OTHER
SUPPORT THE HEALTH NEEDS THE
AUTHOR OF THIS FOR YOU. THE
COLOR ESPECIALLY MOST ONE
BLACK. YOU AN IMMIGRANT GROOVY
WE URGE YOU TO REJECT THE HELLO
YES FUNDING REQUEST. FOR THE
CREATING. PAPER COOLEY PROGRAM
YEAH. THANK YOU. FOR A NEW WE
GO TO NUMBER TWO SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GOD. HELLO TO SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BERMAN.
WHILE WE'RE WAITING MODERATOR
AYE DISTURBANCE QUESTION IS
STAFF WOULD APPEAR. THAT THIS
ITEM IS NOT IN THIS AGENDA SO
IT IS NOT A FUNDED ITEM FOR US
TO DISCUSS BUT. WHO CAN GIVE ME
THE DEFINITIVE ANSWER ON THAT.
IS MY UNDERSTANDING THIS WAS A
FEDERALLY FUNDED PROGRAM THAT-
YES ADMINISTERED TWO YEARS AGO.
AND I BELIEVE IT IS NOW THE
FINISHED. YES SO IS NOT EVEN
BEFORE US BUT IF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CAN YOU OR- YES CAN
YOU CLARIFY THAT. CHERYL HELLO
YES JUMPED IN THAT THEY NEED TO
BUILD ON THIS RIGHT BUT THERE
IS NO PROPOSAL IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OR MADE
PROVISION. RELATED TO THIS
PROGRAM THERE IS NINE HE SAID
THERE YEAH THERE IS NO NEW
PROPOSAL. OR YOU REGARDING THAT
PROGRAM OKAY SO WHEN YOU SAY NO
NEW. SO NOT ONLY IS THERE NO
FUNDING IN THE MAY REVISE FOR
THIS PROGRAM THERE'S NO FUNDING
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET FOR THIS
PROGRAM CORRECT. THERE WAS NO
PROPOSAL FOR THE PROGRAM- YES
BABY CLARIFY WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S ANY FACE FEDERAL
FUNDING BASELINE FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT GOES. I AM I'M
WHAT CERTAIN ASPECTS. OKAY GO
YES. YEAH I WANNA ADD UP. THERE
IS NO PROPOSAL IN THE GENERAL
FUND BUDGET FOR THIS BUDGET
CYCLE OR THE NEXT. THERE THERE
WE DO HAVE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
WE WERE WORKING THROUGH THE
CREATING SEVERAL COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM- WE REVAMPED THAT
PROGRAM WORKING WITH.
STAKEHOLDERS MANY INCLUDING THE
ACLU AND MANY OTHER. GROUPS TO
SHAPE A PROGRAM THAT ADDRESSES
OF MINE DOWN- VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. SO IT'S INNOCENT
AT NEW FORM OF BEING ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT. AND BUT IT IS NOT
FUNDED ALL WITH STATE DOLLARS.
THREE INDEPENDENT OF WHETHER TO
RUN IT BY STATE DOLLARS IS AN
ONGOING PROGRAM THAT YES IS.
ADMINISTERING IT IS. OKAY SO. I
SUPPOSE IN THAT REGARDS IT IS
WITHIN OUR JURISDICTION. THE
YOUNG DO YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO
THAT HERMAN I'M ASKING STAFF
RIGHT NOW IF WHETHER THERE'S
ANY. IF THE AND ASK THEM TO
PLEASE INDICATE WHETHER THEY
ARE. OPPOSED TO THE
CONTINUATION OF THAT PROGRAM.
OKAY LET ME JUST GAS GO YES SO
HAS THERE BEEN ANY NEW FOR HAS
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME- E. S.
EITHER APPLIED FOR OR RECEIVED
FEDERAL MONIES FOR THAT. THIS
PROGRAM WE'RE DISCUSSING. A
MANAGER WE RECEIVE FOR FUNDING
THAT COMES IN- UNDER THE HOME
ITS SECURITY TO DO SECURITY
RELATED EFFORTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND- IT'S A PART OF AN
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION- THAT- WE
UTILIZE TO ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR PROGRAM. TWENTY
MINUTES IT PART OF AN ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION THE FEDS GIVE US
THIS MONEY ANNUALLY. THEY DO WE
GET GRANT MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT EACH YEAR
FOR A NUMBER OF HOMELAND
SECURITY INITIATIVES AND- BASED
UPON. TRAGEDY VESTED
JUSTIFICATIONS THAT ARE BUILT
AROUND THAT- ADDRESSING- OF
PLANETS IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
TO BE ABLE TO OFFSET THINGS
LIKE ACTOR SHOOTERS OKAY SO
EVEN IF IT'S A FEDERALLY FUNDED
PROGRAM EVEN IF WE'RE NOT
PUTTING GF IT'S GOT TO BE IN
THE BUDGET SOMEWHERE. ALL FOR
TO FIND IT'S WHERE IT'S IN THE
BUDGET- I THINK WE ADDRESS OVER
ALL THE- OUT OF FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WE GET ACROSS THE BOARD AT
A WE ASK WITH A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT FEDERAL PROGRAMS. BUT
STEVEN MAYBE YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT A LITTLE MORE. WILL BE A
PART OF THE- I'M OUT IN THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. OF THE BUDGET
THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT YES IN
MINISTERS THAT- YOU STRUGGLE
FUNDING PORTION OF THE DOLLARS
IN THAT ITEM WOULD BE TOWARDS
THIS PROGRAM. OKAY SO WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENTERS DO IS JUST INDICATE
IF YOU OPPOSE THE FINDING OF
THAT IF YOU OPPOSED- YES
ADMINISTERING PROGRAM THAT'S
ALL YOU NEED TO SAY I DON'T
HAVE ANY MATERIALS RELATED TO
IT AND I DON'T HAVE TECHNICALLY
AN ITEM BEFORE ME. SO IT CAN
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE CAN TALK
TO STAFF AND SEE WHETHER
THERE'S ANYTHING ANY TYPE OF
ACTION RELATED TO THIS IN THE
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE. WE MIGHT
TAKE BUT I CAN'T REALLY ACT ON
IT TO DAY BECAUSE IT IS NOT IN
MY AGENDA BUT I WILL ALLOW YOU
TO CONTINUE BUT I WOULD LIKE
YOU JUST INDICATE YOUR NAME.
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND JUST
STATE YOU- TO OPPOSE. THE F.
YES ADMINISTERING THIS FEDERAL
PROGRAM. HI MODERATOR GO AHEAD.
THE EIGHT. NUMBER FORTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. GREAT THANK YOU
HI MY NAME IS NOT A TROLLEY AND
POWER CHANGE A MOST FROM
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION AND
ALSO PART OF ITS NO KEY IN
CALIFORNIA COALITION- SO I AM
REITERATING THAT I OPPOSE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM AND I
JUST ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
IT WASN'T IN THE JANUARY BUDGET
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIALIZED TRAINING INSTITUTE.
AND I'M JUST REITERATING CALL
FOR A THE FUNDING OF IT ALSO
POINTED. OF THE PRE EXISTING
PVC PROGRAM AT ALL THIS
UPCOMING PS THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
CLARIFICATION. RESIDENTS IN
SPECIALIZED TRAINING WILL HAVE.
TO LOOK AT THAT GO AHEAD NEXT
NEXT DO NOT FORTY FORTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES HI THERE MADAM
CHAIR- THIS IS A MODEL OF FROM
THE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS AGAIN I
HAD EARLIER MAKE CON AND IN THE
PARTY CONFUSION WANT TO
REITERATE OUR OPPOSITION- THIS
WAS IN THE JANUARY BUDGET UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIALIZED
TRAINING INSTITUTE WE DO A
BECAUSE- YEAH BECAUSE GRADING
SEPARATE. PROGRAM OR ASKING
SUBCOMMITTEE TO BE FUNDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWO NINETY TWO TO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME CARMEL CUT THEM AND ON THE
POLICY NOT BECAUSE HE MANAGER
AT- THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
CHAPTER OF CARE CALIFORNIA THE
LARGEST AMERICAN LOOK FROM
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATION- AND
I'M HERE. TO REITERATE- THAT WE
ARE OPPOSED HELLO YES IT IS-
FUNDING SORRY WE WOULD LIKE TO
HOLD THE FUNDING OF CALI AT THE
CFT PROGRAM- AND URGE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE BE FINE- AND- AND
MINISTERS AN AUDIT THANK YOU.
THE NEXT TO GO TO NUMBER ONE
SIXTY TWO LIZA AND- HI MY
NAME'S JOHN KENNEDY ON TALKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THIRTY
SEVEN WORLD COUNTIES MANY OF
WHOM BORE THE BRUNT OF LAST
YEAR'S PSP ESTEBAN'S. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CAL- YES
COMMUNITY ENERGY WAS GOING TO
YOU ARE FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL OUR LOCAL RESOURCES
WILL REALLY STRANGE- RESPONDING
TO LAST YEAR'S. CHARACTER THAN
TO SPECIALLY FOR CRITICAL
FACILITIES- BUT ONE THING THAT
WERE ESPECIALLY INTERESTED IN
IS THAT WE CAUTION AGAINST
REQUIRING A LOCAL COST SHARE
BECAUSE THAT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT FOR UNDER RESOURCE
JURISDICTIONS. DRAW DOWN STATE
RESOURCES WE HAD A DIFFICULT
TIME LOOKING PRETTY MORTALITY%
CRISIS AND DRAWING DOWN CD
EIGHT EIGHT FUNDS- SOMETIMES IT
WOULD BE A YOU COUNTIES ENTIRE
RESERVE THAT HAD TO BE
COMMITTED TO DROP DOWN STATE
FARM'S SO URGE YOU TO. GIVE
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION TO
REQUIRING LOCAL COST SHARES AND
PROVIDING WAIVERS IF SOMETHING
IS INCLUDED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
STRONG. URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BUT NEXT YEAR THE
NUMBER THREE OH ONE THREE OH
YOU OPEN. GOOD EVENING SURE
MEMBERS OF THEIR DAHLE CAN HAVE
LEGAL CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME FUNDS FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITY RESILIENCY OF
FUNDS THE CAL YES IS OFFERING
AND I HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
OF COURSE IN THOSE FUND BE
DEDICATED DIRECTLY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS LAST YEAR- CITY HAD
AROUND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO THEM WITH FORTY
CITIES RECEIVING THESE GRANTS
AND THEY WANT TO THANK SUCH AS
PROCURING BACKUP POWER
GENERATION FOR POLICE AND FIRE
STATIONS CITY HALL. WE WATER
OPERATION SENIOR CENTERS AND
MORE- WE ALSO SHARE THE CONCERN
BUT WORLD COUNTIES DO ABOUT THE
CAR SHARE GIVEN THE- EXTREME
IMPACT THAT CITY BUDGETS HAVE
HAD YOU TO CALL THE NINETEEN
BUT ULTIMATELY ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS ITEM HEARD YOUR SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. NEXT
TO GO TO NUMBER NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JEFF AND I AM TALKING ON BEHALF
OF ITS NOT LAWS- HEALING
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION BASED IN
LA COUNTY- SO I WANTED TO CHECK
IN OPPOSITION CHIU PVD SO
ASKING FOR IT TO BE TO FUNDED
CALING FOR THE HOLIDAY. BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO ACQUIRE FOR THE
IN ADDITION TO THE FACT THAT
THIS IS ALREADY ON THE JANUARY
BUDGET SHE WAS PREVIOUSLY IN
EFFECT TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY IN
WAS ENTIRELY FUNDED BY DHS- AND
ALSO IN CALIFORNIA TV IS VERY
CLOSE TO IT TO ANOTHER PROGRAM
CALLED CUNNINGHAM EXTREMISM. IN
WHICH A COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUCCESSFULLY FOUGHT
AGAIN SO THERE'S A LARGE
COMMUNITY OPPOSITION TO ANY
TYPE OF PROGRAMMING LIKE
PREVENTING MANAGING AT THEM
LIKE COMING BACK NEXT YEAR. THE
TRACK RECORD FOR THIS BEING
OPPOSED AND WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THEIR TO BE AN AUDIT.
AND WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
BE TO. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT WILL
GO TO NUMBER TWO THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK YOU-
HELLO COMMITTEE THIS IS TRACY
ROSENBERG AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OPEN PRIVACY. AND
MEDIA ALLIANCE. WE ARE CALLING
IN TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE YEAH DON'T
BUDGETARY REQUEST FOR STAFFING
FOR THE CREATING SAFER
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM FORMERLY
CALLED PREVENTING VIOLENT
EXTREMISM. THE DOLLAR G. OF
THESE PROGRAMS IT IS
PROBLEMATIC AND A DHS MARKERS
FOR TERRORISM ARE REACTIONARY
AT BEST. THANK YOU. THE NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LORRINE I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF AND POWER CHANGE AS WELL AS
THE TV NEED NO PVN CALIFORNIA
COALITION I'M CALLING TO
REITERATE- WHAT MY COLLEAGUES
WERE SAYING AND THAT WE ARE
ASKING THAT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
DE FINDING AUDIT HELLO YES THIS
PREVENTING VIOLENT EXTREMISM
AND CREATING SAFER COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM. AND SPECIFICALLY THEIR
QUEST TO FIND STAFFING
POSITIONS IN THE AGENCIES
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIALIZED
TRAINING AND IF YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WITH A LINE
TO NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ABOUT THE APPLE OF MY COLLEAGUE
GOT THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL YES YES THE BEST MAN
INVESTMENT WHICH INCLUDES
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES PREPARING FOREIGN
RESPONDING YES YES A FENCE.
CONSISTENT WITH OUR POSITION
LAST YEAR WE WOULD REGISTERED
TO A LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDING
THE LANGUAGE A FRAMEWORK FOR
DIRECTING AS MUCH OF THESE
RESOURCES TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AS POSSIBLE IN AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE YES YES OF THEM SEASON
WILL BE UPON US QUICKLY IN
THESE EVENTS GENERALLY CREATE
LOCAL EMERGENCIES LIKE LOCAL
COORDINATION BUT I'LL USE. WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT DISTRICT IN
RESPONSE TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WITH
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY SHOULD BE
DONE MOST OF. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE ONE
MORE IN THE QUEUE- SO NEXT WILL
GO TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE YOU GLAD
TO BE ABLE TO CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH AND
COMMUNITY JUST STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THE FUNDING AND
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE INVOLVING-
ALL YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
RIGHT BUT TO MAKE SURE THERE
WERE NO OTHER CALLERS WHO MIGHT
HAVE GOTTEN DISCONNECTED OR
WERE ABLE TO YET REGISTERED
THEIR PUBLIC COMMENTS. BEFORE I
CLOSE OUT THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO WHAT ONCE AGAIN IF YOU DO
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME THERE'S
NO FURTHER COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MODERATOR THANK YOU PUBLIC
COMMENT ALL THOSE WHO- OFFERED
IT AND- APPRECIATE YOUR-
BEARING WITH US UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES TO HAVE TO DO IT
QUICKLY AND TO HAVE TO DO IT ON
A PHONE LINE. ALL RIGHT SO WE
HAVE NOW THE VOTE ONLY IN THE
VOTE ONLY WOULD BE THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS IS LISTED BUT
WE WOULD REMOVE FROM THE VOTE
ONLY BECAUSE WE ARE YOU DID
ITEM THIRTEEN FOR AN ITEM-
NINETEEN THE REPORT ON THOSE
SEPARATELY. AS WE DISCUSSED
ROOM JUST FINE- BUT WHAT I'D
LIKE TO DO IS SEE. CENTER MORE
LIKE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY OF
THE. RATHER THAN PUTTING YOU IN
THE POSITION OF HAVING TO VOTE
NO FOR EXAMPLE OR YES IF
THERE'S SOME ON THE STATE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO DO DIFFERENTLY
THEN THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
WE COULD HAVE A SEPARATE MOTION
ON THOSE ITEMS JUST NUMBER
SEVEN MADAM CHAIR OKAY THANK
YOU YOU'RE WELCOME ALRIGHT SO
WE'RE GONNA PULL NUMBER SEVEN.
NUMBER SEVEN NUMBER THIRTEEN
AND NUMBER NINETEEN WILL NOT BE
IN THE MOTION THAT I AM FOR
CHANGE. UNLESS OF COURSE
SENATOR BILL YOU HAD ANY ON
THIS LIST THAT YOU WANTED TO DO
DIFFERENTLY OKAY MADAM CHAIR
WILL NUMBER TWENTY ONE BE IN
THAT BLOCK AS WELL WITH THAT
SEPARATE FROM THE ROLL DOWN NO
TWENTY ONE IS. OKAY SO WHEN
APPLE LARK AND THEY ARE. I WILL
BE CLEAR THE RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE DIFFERENT SOME OF THEM ARE
PROOF MOST OF A MORE PROOF BUT
SUMMER REJECT. AND BUT I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON THOSE
ITEMS AS STAFF IS RECOMMENDED
WITH THE IN OTHER WORDS THEM
THE MOTION WOULD BE TO TAKE
ACTION IS STAFF RECOMMENDED ON
ALL ITEMS ON THIS LIST EXCEPT
FOR SEVEN. THIRTEEN AND
NINETEEN MOVE IT. SORRY I CAN'T
HEAR YOU. A LOT. FOUR ONE THREE
AND FOUR RENEWABLE DOPANT OKAY
APOLOGIES THAT I SEE THAT YOUR
RATE SHE A I THINK I WAS SENT A
NOTE. BUT. I GUESS I'M JUST NOT
QUICK ON MY FEET TODAY. ALRIGHT
SO ITEMS ONE TWO AND THREE JUST
WILL SET ASIDE FOR NOW THEY'RE
BEING RECOMMENDED TO BE HELD
OPEN. ONE TWO AND THREE. SO YOU
SEE ONE NOT ONE TWO AND THREE
ONE THREE AND FOUR OKAY GOOD
GUY MAKE IT ALL CLEAR OKAY ONE
THREE AND FOUR. WE WILL. FIVE
THEY ARE LEGISLATIVE ITEMS NOTE
THAT MAKES SENSE. BECAUSE THE
FOR REGISTER STOP THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A BILL THAT
ARE ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES THE
WE SUPPORT AND WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW. ALRIGHT SO. ONE THREE AND
FOUR ARE REMOVED NOW FROM THIS
LIST. S. IS SEVEN. THIRTEEN IN
NINETEEN ALL OTHERS ON THE
LIST- I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ACT AS THE STAFF IS
RECOMMENDING TRIED AGAIN ON
MOVE SO CENTER MORLOCKS MOTION.
AND I THINK I'VE MADE IT PRETTY
CLEAR SO A HAVING HAD REPEATED
IT SO WHEN YOU CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I BUY MORE LOCK ALL RIGHT
NOW. OKAY NOW ITEMS ONE THREE
AND FOUR WE WILL NOT NEED A
MOTION FOR BECAUSE WE ARE
HOLDING THEM OPEN. BUT WE WILL
NEED A MOTION NOW FIND ITEM
SEVEN. AND ITEM SEVEN DAYS
CYBERSECURITY INTEGRATION
CENTER THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE
WOULD REJECT THIS PROPOSAL IN
THE FOR THE JUNE BUDGET BRACKET
DEFERRED DELIBERATION FOR A
LATER DATE. ONE ALRIGHT WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THAT. WOULD YOU
ROLL CALL. FIVE DINNER FIVE
MORE LOCK NOPE. WELL. THIRD NOW
WE WILL ACT ON ITEM THIRTEEN
WHICH WAS THE MODIFICATION OF
THE EARTHQUAKE WORLD WARNING
SYSTEM WORDS ARE REPLACING A
GENERAL PHONE FIND LOAN WITH A
LOAN FROM. A FIND ADMINISTERED
BY STATE LANDS IS HERE A
MOTION ON THAT ITEM WILL. RIGHT
WE'VE GOT A PROMOTION IS CENTER
BELL AND- WOULD TAKE BROKE OFF
INNER BY. MARLA RIGHT NOW ALL
RIGHT. VERY SO NOW WE WILL TAKE
A MOTION ON ITEM NINETEEN WHICH
IS THE REVERSION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE INVESTMENTS AND WE
WOULD BE REJECTING. THIS
PROPOSAL FOR INCLUSION IN THE
BUDGET AND DEFERRED
DELIBERATION FOR A LATER DATE-
WE HAVE A MOTION. OVER RIGHT
SENATOR BILLS MOTION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTER AYE FLORA.
WELL I'VE OKAY GREAT NOW WE
HAVE ISSUE TWENTY ONE WHERE.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE
WOULD APPROVE- FIFTY MILLION.
INCLUDING IN THE BUDGET A FIFTY
MILLION. PART OF FUNDS FOR POST
PAID PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT
DOWN RESPONSE BUT THAT WE WOULD
DETAILS EXACTLY HOW IT'S GOING
TO BE. DISTRIBUTED IN. THE
PLACE HOLDER BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE SO THAT WE CAN ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED GO AHEAD SENATOR MORE
LIKE MINIATURE LIKE TO BREAK
INTO TWO ONE IS TO APPROVE THE-
FIFTY MILLION IN THE SECOND. IS
MOTION ON THE PLACEHOLDER BILL.
I'D I'D SUPPORT THE FIFTY
MILLION BUT SINCE I HAVEN'T
READ THAT THE LANGUAGE I YEAH
WE DON'T HAVE THE LANGUAGE YET
THAT'S WHY A PLACEHOLDER. I
SHOULD EXPLAIN THAT EARLIER A
PLACE HOLDER BILL WOULD BE THAT
WE STILL ARE GOING TO DISCUSS
LANGUAGE NO WE AS A COMMITTEE
WILL GET TO SIT DOWN AND
DISCUSS IT. BUT INSTEAD THAT.
IF THE LANGUAGE CAN BE FIGURED
OUT. THIS IS WHERE WE CAN PUT
SOME INPUT NOW. THEN IT WILL GO
BEFORE THE FULL. OF BUDGET
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE ADOPT THE
WHOLE BUDGET BUT IF THEY CAN'T
FIGURE OUT THE LANGUAGE BY THAT
TIME THEN WOULD COME BACK TO
US. AT A SUBSEQUENT DATE AT
THAT POINT IF THAT MEANS IT'S
AFTER JUNE FIFTEENTH WE MIGHT
GET TO HAVE ANOTHER HEARING
POSSIBLY. BUT OUR ABILITY TO
INFLUENCE IT. BY SAYING PLACE
HOLDER IF IT'S ACTED ON BY THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLIGHT
DEADLINE OUR ABILITY TO
INFLUENCE IT WILL BE AT THE
WHOLE BUDGETARY. SAID HELP IF
THAT HELPS. OUT THE I'M I'M
FINE I MAKE IT ONE MOTION THEN
OKAY THIS ONE. YEAH YOU WANT TO
BE ABLE TO PUT SOME INPUT IN SO
YES. AND AS- MISS SALAS I THINK
AS OUR STAFF YOU WOULD BE.
WORKING ON THAT SO- WHILE IT'S
POTENTIALLY NOT CUSTOMARY EACH
OF US CAN BE ABLE TO GIVE YOU
INPUT. WRECKED K. SO WE WERE TO
GIVE ALL THE MONEY TO BERKELEY
USES HER. NO NO I DO NOT. THERE
CERTAINLY I DO NOT WANT TO BE
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE FIRES- ART
SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO. APPROVE
IT WITH PLACE HOLDER BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE LET'S GO. AND
CALL. DINNER BY MARK RIGHT NOW
ALL RIGHT. THAT'S OUR BUSINESS.
WELL I WOULD NEVER IN MY LIFE
WOULD THINK THAT I WOULD HAVE-
ACTED ON AN ENTIRE. BUDGET OF
MY A SEVEN AREA HAVING BEEN
CHAIR OF EITHER A SUBURB THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE M. FOR MOTHER
MULTIPLE YEARS. THAT WE WOULD
DO SO IN ONE MARATHON HEARINGS.
AND I HOPE THAT WE WILL NEVER
HAVE TO REPEAT THIS BECAUSE AS
MUCH AS I'D HIGHLY HIGHLY
APPRECIATE THE INCREDIBLE WORK
THE STAFF ALL THE STAFF. ARE
SERGEANTS ARE ALL OF THE STAFF
IN PUTTING THIS ALL TOGETHER
AND OF COURSE THERE STAFF WE
ANALYZED IT I GREATLY GREATLY
VALUE YOUR WORK I NEVER WANT TO
REPEAT THIS. SO YEAH. I THINK
WE HAVE NO FURTHER BUSINESS I
APPRECIATE MY SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS INCREDIBLE PATIENCE FOR
THIS AND- WITH THAT I THINK IT
I DO NOW ADJOURN IS THAT
CORRECT. WE ARE ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU MANAGER.